In this video, we have a compilation of
all of the different practice exams for
the CompTIA Security Plus SYO71.
This covers every single section from
the SYO71
exam objectives, general security
concepts, threats, vulnerabilities,
mitigation, security architecture,
security operations, and security
program management, including everything
here as well as the acronyms at the very
end. There is a lot of content here. So,
let's get it started.
If you guys are not familiar with this
little software application that I
wrote, we have the question. We have
four possible answers. We have this
little skull down here which is going to
remove some of the incorrect answers
until we are left with the correct one.
Then we have the exam that we're drawing
from and the section that we're drawing
from on the top right hand corner. So,
which of the following is considered a
technical security control? Firewall
security policy, security awareness
training or CCTV surveillance, technical
security control.
Correct answer is a firewall.
Which of the following best describes a
managerial security control? Encryption
algorithms, security policies and risk
assessments, intrusion detection
systems, or badge readers? Which of the
following best describes a managerial
security control?
Correct answer is security policies and
risk assessments. Which security
category focuses on day-to-day
procedures and processes to maintain
security? Managerial, operational,
technical or physical.
Correct answer is operational. Which of
the following security categories
involves measures such as fences,
security guards, and locks? Operational,
technical, physical, or managerial.
Correct answer is physical. And if you
guys need some more time, you can always
pause the video as well. Uh, which type
of control? I'm trying to give you a
couple seconds to think about the
correct answer, but if you need some
more time,
which type of control is designed to
stop a security incident before it
happens? Detective, corrective,
preventative, or compensating
before it happens? Correct answer is
preventative.
Which type of security control is
designed to discourage an attacker from
attempting malicious actions? Detective,
deterrent, corrective, or directive?
Correct answer is deterrent. I feel like
there are some softballs at the
beginning. It's not going to be it's not
going to be this easy throughout the
entire thing. Don't worry. Which
security control type is used to
identify and record security incidents?
Preventative, detective, compensating or
directive?
Correct answer is detective. Which type
of control is implemented to restore a
system or process after an incident?
Corrective, deterrent, preventative, or
detective?
to restore a system or process after an
incident.
Correct answer is corrective.
Which type which control type is used as
an alternative when the primary security
control is not feasible? Detective,
compensating, preventative or
corrective?
Correct answer is compensating.
Which control type provides guidance on
security requirements and procedures?
Directive, compensating, preventative or
deterrent?
Correct answer is directive. Which
principle of the CIA triad ensures that
information is only accessible to
authorized users? Availability,
confidentiality, integrity, or
non-repudiation?
only accessible to authorized users.
Correct answer is confidentiality. So, a
lot of people see the videos and they
ask, "Where can I get the app? How can I
do these practice quizzes for myself?"
The honest answer is that it's too
expensive to develop and advertise a
free app in the way that it really needs
to be developed. So, we designed it for
use internally to make quiz prep videos.
However, as with literally every other
YouTube channel on Earth, we did, of
course, get a sponsorship offer from
Rage Shadow Legends, and we want to take
their money and use it to build an
awesome free app for you. So, if you
want to help us take their money for
your free app, please try out the game
with this QR code or link in the pinned
comment. Just to be clear, I am not
asking you to buy anything. Just
download and try the game. Also, our
link gives you a bunch of free stuff.
And there's a big Ninja Turtles collab
happening right now in the game as well,
including a 100% free Michelangelo as
the 7-day login bonus. And of course,
you can use one of these promo codes on
the screen for a very strong legendary
unit of your choice right at the
beginning of the game. So again, help us
take their money to build you a 100%
free exam prep app. The money's got to
come from somewhere. I don't want to
take your money, but I don't mind taking
theirs. Win.
Which security principle ensures that a
user cannot deny taking an action such
as sending an email or making a
transaction? Non-repudiation, integrity,
authentication, or authorization.
Cannot deny taking an action.
Correct answer is non-repudiation.
Which of the following is a key function
of authentication in the AAA model?
Enforcing access policies, tracking user
activity, encrypting stored data, or
verifying a user's identity.
Key function of authentication.
Correct answer is verifying a user's
identity. Which method is commonly used
to authenticate systems rather than
users? Biometric authentication, digital
certificates, multiffactor
authentication or security questions?
Authenticate systems rather than users.
Which method?
Correct answer is digital certificates.
Which authorization model grants access
based on predefined roles assigned to
users? Mandatory access control,
discretionary access control, role-based
access control, or rulebased access
control.
Access based on predefined roles
assigned to users. Predefined roles.
Correct answer is rolebased access
control. I was trying to give you the
answer. I was trying to because the
answer oftentimes if you reread the
question and make sure you don't try to
read too fast. You re you read it slow
and you understand every word in there
because there's a lot of times where
it's like which is the most effective,
which is not the correct answer or which
is the least effective,
etc., etc. So really I I have done this
every every one of these exams that I've
taken is reread the question make sure
you understand specifically what it's
asking not just try to skim it uh what
what is the primary purpose of gap
analysis in cyber security to evaluate
and compare current security posture
against desired security standards to
encrypt sensitive data in transit to
monitor network traffic for anomalies or
to detect and prevent unauthorized
access attempts.
Correct answer of gap analysis in cyber
security is to evaluate and compare
current security posture against the
desired security standards.
Which principle of zero trust focuses on
verifying user identities dynamically
based on risk factors? policydriven
access control, threat scope reduction,
adaptive identity or policy
administrator.
Correct answer is adaptive identity. In
zero trust architecture, what does
threat scope reduction aim to achieve?
Minimizing the attack surface by
restricting lateral movement within the
network. Enforcing least privilege
access control policies. Implementing
multiffactor authentication for all
users or auditing user access logs for
anomalies.
Threat scope reduction. What does it aim
to achieve?
Correct answer is minimizing the attack
surface by restricting lateral movement
within the network.
Which zero trust concept ensures access
decisions are enforced based on
predefined security policies? Threat
scope production, adaptive identity,
zero trust control plane or policydriven
access control.
Which zero trust concept ensures access
decisions are enforced based on
predefined security policies?
Correct answer is policydriven access
control. In the zero trust model, what
is the role of the policy administrator?
To define and enforce security policies
based on contextual data, to monitor all
network traffic for threats, to
authenticate users before granting
access to resources, or to encrypt all
network communication,
the policy administrator.
Correct answer is to define and enforce
security policies based on contextual
data. In a zero trust architecture, what
is the role of the policy engine in the
data plane? To enforce access controls
at network endpoints, to monitor network
traffic for anomalies, to encrypt data
in transit or to authenticate and
authorize access requests based on
security policies. The policy engine in
the data plane
Correct answer is to authenticate and
authorize access requests based on
security policies. Which term refers to
a security zone that assumes all users
and devices are potentially untrusted?
Policy enforcement point, implicit trust
zones, policy engine, or data plane.
Correct answer is implicit trust zones.
In the data plane of zero trust
architecture, what is a subject system?
An entity such as a user or device
requesting access to a resource, a tool
used to enforce access policies, a
mechanism for analyzing security events,
or a database that stores access control
rules.
What is a subject or system?
Correct answer is an entity such as user
or device requesting access to a
resource.
What component in zero trust
architecture is responsible for
enforcing security decisions at the
resource level? Policy engine, data
plane, policy enforcement point or
implicit trust zone.
responsible for enforcing security
decisions at the resource level.
Correct answer is the policy enforcement
point.
Which physical security measure is
designed to prevent vehicle-based
attacks on buildings and pedestrian
areas? Ballards, access control,
vestibule, fencing, or lighting.
prevent vehicle-based attacks on
buildings and pedestrian areas.
Correct answer is Ballards.
Which type of sensor detects heat
signatures for security monitoring?
Microwave sensor, infrared sensor,
pressure sensor, or ultrasonic sensor?
Detects heat signatures for security
monitoring.
Correct answer is infrared sensor. Which
security measure is commonly used to
detect unauthorized access attempts in
high security areas? Microwave sensors,
pressure sensors, infrared cameras, or
video surveillance.
Detect unauthorized access attempts in
high security areas.
Correct answer is pressure sensors.
Which type of deception technology is
designed to attract attackers by
simulating a vulnerable system? Honey
file, honeyet, honeypot, or honey token?
Correct answer is a honeypot. Which
deception tool consists of network of
decoy systems to detect unauthorized
access attempts? Honey file, Honey Pot,
Honey Net, or Honey Token. A network of
decoy systems used to detect
unauthorized access attempts.
Correct answer and it's in the name is
Honeyet. What is the purpose of a Honey
token in cyber security? To mimic a
vulnerable system and attract attackers
to serve as a fake credential or data
entry to detect unauthorized access. to
create a network of decoy systems or to
encrypt stored files and prevent
unauthorized modifications.
The purpose of a honey token
sounds like an NFT, I know. Correct
answer is to serve as a fake credential
or data entry to detect unauthorized
access.
Which business process ensures that
security related changes receive proper
authorization before implementation?
Approval process, standard operating
procedure, maintenance window or impact
analysis.
Ensures that security related changes
receive proper authorization before
implementation.
Correct answer is approval process. In
security operations, which concept
refers to the individual or entity
responsible for a system or data asset,
impact analysis, ownership, approval
process, or backout plan.
The individual or entity responsible for
a system or data asset.
Correct answer is ownership. Which term
refers to individuals or groups who have
an interest in security decisions and
outcomes? Backout plan, stakeholders,
standard operating procedure or approval
process,
individuals or groups who have an
interest in security decisions and
outcomes.
Correct answer is stakeholders. Which
process is used to evaluate potential
security risks and their effects on
business operations, impact analysis,
test results, ownership, or maintenance
window? I feel like a lot of these ones
are
kind of not that challenging. It's going
to get it's going to get more
challenging in the other uh the other
sections. Don't worry.
Correct answer is impact analysis.
Why are test results important in
security operations? They define
security roles and responsibilities.
They determine the required level of
stakeholder involvement. They schedule
maintenance windows for system updates
or they provide evidence of system
vulnerabilities and effectiveness of
security measures.
Why are test results important in
security operations?
correct answer and it's just ironic that
this is actually outside of the button
is they provide evidence of system
vulnerabilities and effectiveness of
security measures. This bothers me so
much the fact that these are outside the
button. The buttons are changing based
on um the length of the content inside
of them. But sometimes there's still
spillover and I I have not been able to
figure it. I mean I haven't been in
detective mode trying to figure it out
but yeah I'm not I'm not sure why it
does that sometimes. I I wrote the code,
so there's no one to blame but myself.
What is the purpose of a backout plan in
security operations? To provide a
documented procedure for reverting
changes if an issue occurs, to determine
the impact of a security incident, to
manage stakeholder expectations during
security updates, or to define who has
an ownership over a security process.
The purpose of a backout plan.
Correct answer is to provide a
documented procedure for reverting
changes backup plan reverting changes if
an issue occurs. Uh which business
process involves scheduling security
updates and changes to minimize
operational disruption impact analysis
standard operating procedure maintenance
window or test results.
The beautiful thing about it, and you
guys, if you're new to the industry or
haven't entered it yet and are doing
this as part of school, then you're
going to realize this soon enough, is
that you always seem to be working when
systems are going down and things are
broking
things that are broken, but even things
that you aren't expecting to go down, it
it just always feels that way. Uh so the
correct answer is the maintenance
window. Which document provides
step-by-step guidance on performing
security related tasks consistently?
Standard operating procedure,
stakeholder agreement, impact analysis
report or approval process
documentation.
Half the time when I say things going
down, I mean like electricity and air
conditioning and things like that as
well. So step-by-step guidance on
performing security related tasks
consistently is standard operating
procedure. Which security measure
controls which applications, websites or
services can be accessed on a network?
Legacy applications, service restart,
allow lists or deny lists or
dependencies?
Which applications, websites or services
can be accessed on a network?
Correct answer is allow lists and deny
lists. What is the primary purpose of
restricting certain activities on a
corporate network? To improve employee
productivity, to enhance security by
preventing unauthorized or harmful
actions, to reduce software licensing
costs, or to enforce compliance with
software update schedules.
What is the primary purpose of
restricting certain activities on a
corporate network?
Correct answer is not to improve
productivity. Sorry. To enhance security
by preventing unauthorized or harmful
actions. They don't they care about you
going on Facebook at work, but not that
much. Not not that much. They care more
if their databases are breached. Uh
which of the following is a potential
security risk when using legacy
applications? They often lack support
for modern security updates and patches.
They require additional server capacity.
They do not support multiple user
authentication methods. or they
automatically update without
administrator approval.
Potential security risk when using
legacy applications.
Correct answer is they often lack
support for modern security updates and
patches. What is a key technical
implication of downtime in an enterprise
environment? reduce network latency,
increase risk of service disruptions and
security vulnerabilities, enhance system
performance or automatic failover to
legacy applications.
Key technical implementation uh sorry
key technical implication of downtime in
enterprise environment.
Correct answer is increased risk of
service disruptions and security
vulnerabilities. Why is it important to
restart a service after applying
security patches? To finalize the
installation and ensure the updates take
effect, to reset user access
permissions, to automatically update
firewall rules, or to remove inactive
user accounts?
Why is it important to restart a service
after applying security patches?
Correct answer is to finalize the
installation and ensure the updates take
effect. Which of the following is a
reason to update network diagrams
regularly? To improve the performance of
the outdated software, to comply with
software licensing agreements, to
reflect changes in the infrastructure
and ensure accurate security planning or
to optimize database indexing.
Correct answer is to reflect changes in
the infrastructure and ensure accurate
security planning. Why is it necessary
to update security policies and
procedures? To improve application
performance, to automate the patch
management process, to ensure they
reflect new threats, technologies, and
compliance requirements, or to enhance
encryption algorithms.
Correct answer. I again, the one that's
outside of the box to ensure they
reflect new threats, technologies, and
compliance requirements. What is the
primary benefit of using version control
in security documentation? It tracks
changes over time and allows roll back
to previous versions if needed. It
automatically enforces user
authentication policies. It provides
real-time network monitoring
capabilities or it restricts users from
modifying security configurations.
Correct answer is it tracks changes over
time, allows roll back to a previous
version if needed. Which component of
cyber security provides a framework for
managing digital certificates and
encryption keys? Key escrow, encryption,
private key or public key
infrastructure.
A framework for managing digital
certificates and encryption keys.
Correct answer is public key
infrastructure
like the little smart cards. Uh what is
the function of a public key in
asymmetric encryption? Encrypts data
that can only be decrypted by the
corresponding private key. Decrypts data
encrypted with the same public key.
Manages the storage of encryption keys
or ensures data remains unchanged during
transmission. The function of a public
key in asymmetric encryption.
Correct answer is it encrypts data that
can only be decrypted by the
corresponding private key.
Which of the following is a
characteristic of a private key in
asymmetric encryption? It is shared
publicly to allow data encryption. It
can be used to verify digital signatures
only. It is kept secret and used to
decrypt messages encrypted with the
public key or it is stored with a key.
It is stored in a key escrow for public
access.
a characteristic of a private key in
asymmetric encryption.
Correct answer. And we we basically just
touched on this in the previous question
is it is kept secret and used to decrypt
messages encrypted with the public key.
And this is another thing that I want to
mention. I probably mentioned it too
much, but when you're actually taking
the exam, if you're unfamiliar and
you're confused by a question, skip it.
Flag it to make sure you know where to
come back to. flag it, skip it, and then
continue answering questions that you
know because oftentimes in the later
questions, you'll have some indicators
to what the correct answer is in earlier
questions. So, the exam itself gives you
some tips and hints along the way and
definitely use that to your advantage.
Uh, what is the purpose of key escrow in
encryption? to generate encryption keys
for data encryption, to store encryption
keys securely for retrieval by
authorized parties, to distribute public
keys among users, or to prevent
unauthorized encryption of sensitive
data. The purpose of key escrow in
encryption
and you can also think about how regular
escrow services where they hold money
is very similar in key escrow. So to
store encryption keys securely for
retrieval by authorized parties.
Uh what is the primary function of
encryption in cyber security? To convert
data into an unreadable format to
protect confidentiality to restrict
access to files on a system to create
digital signatures for authentication or
to detect unauthorized modifications to
data.
Primary function of encryption in cyber
security. Correct answer is to convert
data into an unreadable format to
protect confidentiality.
Which term refers to the scope at which
encryption is applied to a system or
storage device? Partition, key escrow,
public key infrastructure or level.
The scope at which encryption is applied
to a system or storage device?
Correct answer is level. Which type of
encryption ensures that an entire hard
drive's data is protected? Full disk
encryption, file encryption, partition
encryption, or public key encryption.
Ensures entire hard drives data is
protected.
Correct answer is full disk encryption.
What type of encryption protects a
specific section of a storage device
instead of the entire disc? full disk
encryption, public key encryption,
partition encryption or key escro
encryption.
Correct answer is partition encryption.
Which type of encryption protects
individual documents without encrypting
the entire system? File encryption, full
disk encryption, partition encryption or
key escro encryption?
Correct answer. And we already know the
other two. We already know it can't be
full disc, it can't be partition, and
it's not key escrow. So, it is file
encryption. I say that for one of the
easiest ones on the entire uh which
encryption method is used to secure an
entire storage unit such as a disk or
logical volume? An entire storage unit?
Database encryption, volume encryption,
record encryption, or symmetric
encryption.
to secure an entire storage unit such as
a disk or logical volume.
Correct answer is volume encryption.
Which security measure ensures that
sensitive data stored in a database
remains encrypted? Record encryption,
transport encryption, key exchange or
database encryption
ensures that sensitive data stored in a
database remains encrypted.
Correct answer is database encryption.
Which type of encryption protects
individual entries within a database?
Volume encryption, key exchange
encryption, record encryption, or
symmetric encryption.
Individual entries within a database.
Correct answer is record encryption.
Which type of encryption secures data as
it moves across a network? Transport
encryption, database encryption, volume
encryption, or asymmetric encryption.
Secures data as it moves across a
network.
Correct answer is transport encryption.
Which encryption type uses a pair of
keys, one for encryption and one for
decryption? symmetric encryption, volume
encryption, asymmetric encryption or
record encryption.
A pair of keys, one for encryption, and
one for decryption?
Correct answer is asymmetric encryption.
Which encryption method uses the same
key for both encryption and decryption?
Symmetric encryption, asymmetric
encryption, key exchange encryption, or
transport encryption? the same key for
both encryption and decryption.
Correct answer is symmetric encryption.
What is the purpose of key exchange in
encryption? To generate random
encryption keys, to store encryption
keys in a database, to encrypt sensitive
data using a shared key or to securely
share encryption keys between parties.
The purpose of key exchange in
encryption.
Correct answer is to securely share
encryption keys between parties. Which
component of encryption defines the
mathematical process used to encrypt and
decrypt data? Encryption algorithm, key
exchange, symmetric key or asymmetric
key?
Which component defines the mathematical
process used to encrypt and decrypt
data?
Mathematical process.
Correct answer is encryption algorithm.
What factor in encryption determines the
strength of a cryptographic key?
Algorithm type, encryption mode, key
length or transport protocol.
The strength of a cryptographic key.
Correct answer is key length.
Which security feature is a dedicated
chip that provides cryptographic
functions such as key storage and secure
boot, trusted platform module, hardware
security module, key management system
or secure enclave
which provides cryptographic functions.
A dedicated chip that provides
cryptographic functions such as key
storage and secure boot.
Dedicated chip.
Secure boot. I feel like secure boot is
the biggest hint right there in this.
And the correct answer is the trusted
platform module, also referred to as the
TPM module, even though it's redundant.
Uh, which device is specifically
designed to manage and protect
cryptographic keys in high security
environments? trusted platform module,
secure enclave, hardware security module
or key exchange protocol
specifically designed to manage and
protect cryptographic keys in high
security envi environments.
Correct answer is the hardware security
module. What is the main purpose of a
key management system in cryptographic
security? KMS key management system to
securely gen to securely generate,
store, distribute and retire encryption
keys to encrypt data at rest and in
transit to store cryptog cryptographic
keys in a hardware security module or to
ensure hardwarebased authentication.
The main purpose of a key management
system,
correct answer is to securely generate,
store, distribute, and retire encryption
keys. Also, if you uh if you think about
these a lot of these acronyms,
if you get a question for an acronym at
the beginning of an exam, whether it's
this one or another one, sometimes they
are, as I mentioned before, sometimes
they are actually fully written out in
questions at the end of the exam or
another part in the exam. So, keep that
uh keep that in mind. Uh I think that's
one of the things that I mentioned in
the exam tips video that's on the
channel. Uh, which security feature
creates an isolated e execution
environment within a processor to
protect sensitive data? Isolated
execution environment within a processor
to protect sensitive data. Hardware
security module, key management system,
trusted platform module or secure
enclave,
isolated execution environment within a
processor. Correct answer is secure
enclave. Which technique involves
deliberately making source code
difficult to read and understand to
enhance security? Stenography,
obfiscation, tokenization or encryption.
Deliberately making source code
difficult to read and understand to
enhance security.
I believe that technique is to hire bad
developers.
ironically enough as I can't even get
the the code in my own application
working correctly apparently. Uh so the
answer the correct answer is
obfiscation. Which data hiding technique
involves embedding hidden information
within an image or audio file?
Offiscation, tokenization, stenography
or hashing. Embedding hidden information
within an image or audio file.
Correct answer is stenography.
Which security method replaces sensitive
data with it with a nonsensitive
equivalent reducing the risk of
exposure?
Sensitive data replacing sensitive data
with a non-sensitive equivalent.
Tokenization, stenography, obfiscation
or encryption.
Replacing sensitive data with a
nonsensitive equivalent.
Correct answer is tokenization.
Which security technique replaces
sensitive data with altered values to
protect personal information? Hashing,
salting, encryption, or data masking?
Replaces sensitive data with altered
values to protect personal information.
Correct answer is data masking. Which
process converts data into a fixedlength
irreversible string to ensure data
integrity? Hashing, salting, digital
signatures or encryption?
Fixed length irreversible string to
ensure data integrity.
Correct answer is hashing. Which
technique adds random data to passwords
before hashing to protect against
rainbow table attacks? key stretching,
hashing, salting, or data masking.
Adds random data to passwords before
hashing to protect against rainbow table
attacks.
Correct answer is salting. Which
cryptographic method provides
authentication, integrity, and
non-repudiation for digital messages?
Hashing, salting, data masking, or
digital signatures?
Cryptograph cryptographic method
providing authentication, integrity and
non-repudiation for digital messages.
Correct answer is digital signatures.
Which cryptographic technique
strengthens weak passwords by repeatedly
hashing them? Key stretching, salting,
data masking, or digital signatures?
strengthens weak passwords by repeatedly
hashing them. Correct answer is key
stretching. Which technology maintains a
decentralized tamperresistant ledger for
transactions? Digital signatures,
certificate authorities, blockchain or
key stretching,
decentralized tamperresistant ledger.
Everyone knows this. This is 2025.
Everyone knows this is blockchain. Uh
what is an open public? Even people that
don't understand tech, even my grandma
understands blockchain because that's
the world we're living in. What is an
open public ledger used for in
blockchain technology? Storing
encryption keys securely, managing
digital signatures, encrypting passes
passwords for secure authentication or
recording transactions in a transparent
and immutable manner.
Open public ledger used for in
blockchain technology.
I feel like if you just take a look at
what open public ledger is, it gives the
answer right there. Uh recording
transactions in a transparent and
immutable manner. Open transparent
transactions ledger.
What is the function of digital
certificates in cyber security? To
encrypt passwords before transmission to
provide secure key stretching to verify
the authentic the to verify the
authenticity
that's that word of websites users or
devices to rep
it's that time of the day guys to
replace data with masked values for
security.
The function of digital certificates in
cyber security.
That one that that one was all over the
place.
Time to go to bed. Which entity which
entity is responsible for issuing and
managing digital certificates?
Certificate authority, blockchain
network, hashing algorithm or digital
signature provider.
Issuing and managing digital
certificates.
Correct answer is the certificate
authority.
What is the purpose of a certificate
revocation list CRL? To verify the to
verify the validity of a certificate in
real time. To list certificates that
have been revoked by the issuing
certificate authority, to store public
keys for encrypting data or to store
passwords for authentication. The
purpose of a certificate revocation
list. Think about what a certificate
revocation list does. every every word
in that
correct answer is to list certificates
that have been revoked by the issuing
certificate authority.
Which protocol is used to check the
status of a digital certificate in real
time? CRL, FTP, SMTP or OCSP.
Correct answer is OCSP online
certificate status protocol.
What is a self-signed certificate? A
certificate that is issued by a trusted
certificate authority. A certificate
that is not trusted by default in most
systems. A certificate generated and
signed by the certificate owner rather
than an external authority or a
certificate used for encryption purposes
only. Self-signed certificate.
Correct answer. He is a certificate
generated and signed by the certificate
owner rather than an external authority.
Selfsigned.
Which of the following is true about
thirdparty certificates? They are always
free and open source. They're issued by
trusted certificate authorities. They
are never valid for commercial use. Or
they require manual installation on the
client machine. Thirdparty certificates.
Which of the following is true?
Correct answer is they are issued by
trusted certificate authorities.
What is the root of trust in a public
key infrastructure? The root of trust
and PKI. The private key of a server,
the certificate authority that signs all
certificates, the initial certificate
that verifies the entire chain of trust
or the method of hashing certificates.
the root of trust in public key
infrastructure. I don't know why I can't
talk today, guys. I really don't.
I I talk as good as I could apparently.
Correct answer is the initial
certificate that verifies the entire
chain of trust.
What is the purpose of generating a
certificate signing request CSR? to
create a private key, to request a
certificate from a certificate
authority, to verify the authenticity of
a website, or to revoke an existing
certificate.
Certificate signing request. What is the
purpose?
Correct answer is to request a
certificate. Shocking, I know. From a
certificate authority. What is a
wildcard certificate used for? To secure
multiple subdomains under a single
domain, to encrypt email messages only,
to secure a single subdomain under a
domain, or to authenticate users on a
network,
a wildcard certificate.
Correct answer is to secure multiple
subdomains under a single domain.
First question. Which of the following
threat actors is typically backed by a
government and engages in cyber
espionage or cyber warfare? Activist,
nation, state, insider threat or shadow
IT? I'm going to give you guys a couple
seconds to think of the answer and then
we will show it.
Which of the following threat actors is
typically backed by a government and
engages in cyber espionage or cyber
warfare?
Correct answer is the nation state.
Which term describes an attacker who
lacks advanced technical skills and
primary primarily uses pre-existing
tools and scripts? Unskilled attacker,
nation state, organized crime, or
insider threat.
An attacker who lacks advanced technical
skills.
Correct answer is an unskilled attacker.
What type of threat actor is motivated
by political or ideological beliefs and
uses cyber attacks to promote their
cause? Nation state, shadow IT, activist
or unskilled attacker.
Correct answer is a hackist. Which type
of threat actor has legitimate access to
an organization's systems but poses a
security risk due to malicious intent or
negligence? Is it a activist, insider
threat, nation state, or unskilled
attacker?
Which type of threat actor has
legitimate access to an organization
systems but poses a security risk due to
malicious intent or negligence?
Correct answer is insider threat. Which
type of threat actor is typically
motivated by financial gain and operates
in structured groups with significant
resources? Activist, organized crime,
insider threat, or nation state?
Correct answer is organized crime. What
term describes IT systems or
applications that are deployed within an
organization without formal approval,
often increasing security risks? Shadow
IT, insider threat, nation state, or
organized crime.
IT systems or applications that are
deployed within an organization without
formal approval?
Correct answer is shadow IT. Which of
the following best differentiates an
internal threat actor from an external
one? External threat actors of always
operate with legal permissions. Internal
threat actors only use social
engineering attacks. Internal threat
actors have authorized access to the
organization systems or external threat
actors cannot use malware in their
attacks. Which best differentiates an
internal threat actor from an external
one?
Correct answer is internal threat actors
have authorized access to the
organization systems.
How does resource availability impact
the effectiveness of a threat actor?
More resources allow for more
sophisticated attacks and longer
campaigns. Low resources result in
higher success rates for cyber attacks.
Threat actors with fewer resources
always have government backing. Or
resource availability does not affect
attack capabilities.
How does resource availability impact
the effectiveness of a threat actor?
Correct answer is more resources allow
for more sophisticated attacks and
longer campaigns.
Which characteristic is often associated
with highly sophisticated threat actors?
They rely exclusively on social
engineering attacks. They use advanced
techniques and customdeveloped tools.
They target only small businesses with
limited security measures. or they never
collaborate with other cyber criminal
groups. Which characteristic is often
associated with highly sophisticated
threat actors?
Correct answer is they use advanced
techniques and customdeveloped tools.
Which term describes the act of stealing
sensitive information and transmitting
it outside an organization without
authorization? Service disruption,
ethical hacking, disruption chaos, or
data exfiltration.
The act of stealing sensitive
information and transmitting it outside
an organization without authorization.
Correct answer is data exfiltration.
Which motivation drives cyber criminals
or state sponsored actors to gather
confidential business or government
information for strategic advantage?
Revenge, espionage, blackmail or
disruption or chaos?
What motivation drives cyber criminals
or state sponsored actors to gather
confidential business or government
information for strategic advantage?
Correct answer is espionage.
A distributed denial of service attack
designed to overload a network and make
a service unavailable is an example of
what type of motivation? Service
disruption, financial gain, espionage,
or blackmail?
A distributed denial of service or DDoS
attack designed to overload a network
and make a service unavailable is an
example of which type of motivation?
Correct answer is service disruption.
Which type of cyber attack motivation
involves threatening to release
sensitive information unless a ransom or
demand is met? Ethical hacking,
disruption or chaos, blackmail or
service disruption?
threatening to release sensitive
information unless a ransom or demand is
met.
Correct answer is blackmail. Ransomware
attacks, where attackers demand payment
in exchange for restoring access to
encrypted data, are primarily motivated
by what? Financial gain, war,
philosophical or political beliefs, or
revenge?
Ransomware attacks where attackers
demand payment in exchange for restoring
access are motivated by what?
Correct answer is financial gain.
Activists often conduct cyber attacks to
promote or oppose certain ideologies.
What is their primary motivation?
Financial gain, revenge, philosoph
philosophical or political beliefs or
service disruption?
or is their primary motivation?
Correct answer is philosophical or
political beliefs. Which of the
following describes ethical hackers who
conduct security assessment to identify
vulnerabilities before malicious
attackers exploit them? Data
exfiltration, espionage, ethical
hacking, or service disruption.
Correct answer. They say it right in the
question. Ethical hacking. A disgruntled
employee launches. It might not be as
obvious on the actual exam. I'm just
letting you know. A disgruntled employee
launches an attack on their former
employer's network to cause damage. What
is the primary motivation? Financial
gain, revenge, war, or ethical hacking?
Correct answer is revenge. I feel like
this is the common sense part of the uh
part of the exam. Some cyber criminals
engage in attacks with no clear
financial or ideological motive, simply
aiming to create disorder. What is this
motivation called? Disruption or chaos,
espionage, blackmail, or ethical
hacking?
No clear financial or ideological motive
simply aiming to create disorder.
Correct answer is disruption or chaos.
Cyber attacks that target critical
infrastructure, communication networks,
or government systems during
geopolitical conflicts are typically
motivated by what? Financial gain,
revenge, ethical hacking, or war?
Correct answer is war. Which type of
attack is commonly delivered via fishing
emails to trick users into revealing
sensitive information? Denial of
service, email based social engineering,
brute force attack, or man-in-the-middle
attack.
Which type of attack is commonly
delivered via fishing emails to trick
users into revealing sensitive
information?
Correct answer is email-based social
engineering. What is a common security
risk associated with SMS-based fishing
or smishing attacks? exploiting software
vulnerabilities and databases, tricking
users into clicking malicious links or
availing credentials, excessive
bandwidth usage from video calls, or
using outdated cryptographic algorithms
was a common security risk associated
with SMSbased fishing or smishing
attacks?
Correct answer is tricking users into
clicking malicious links or revealing
credentials.
Which messaging platform is often
targeted by attackers using fake
profiles or malicious links to
compromise users? Instant messaging,
Bluetooth connections, web conferencing
software, or network routers.
Which messaging platform is often
targeted by attackers using fake
profiles or malicious links to
compromise users?
Correct answer is instant messaging.
Stenography is a technique commonly used
in which type of cyber attack? Image
based attacks, man-in-the-middle
attacks, denial of service attacks, or
fishing attacks.
Stenography is a technique commonly used
in which type of cyber attack?
Correct answer is image-based attacks.
Which attack vector involves
distinguishing malware within seemingly
harmless documents such as PDFs or word
files? social engineering, fishing
emails, voice call spoofing, or
file-based attacks.
Disguising malware within seemingly
harmless documents such as PDFs or word
files.
Correct answer is filebased attacks.
Caller ID spoofing is often used in
which type of attack? brute force
attack, denial of service, voice call
based fishing or fishing or SQL
injection?
Caller ID spoofing is often used in
which type of attack?
Correct answer is voice callbased
fishing or fishing. What is a major
security risk associated with using
removable storage devices? They can
spread malware or facilitate data
exfiltration. They prevent unauthorized
access to systems. They automatically
encrypt all stored data or they ensure
complete network isolation. There's a
major security risk associated with
using removable storage devices.
Correct answer is they can spread
malware or facilitate data exfiltration.
Which of the following describes a key
security concern with agentless security
solutions? They rely on external network
scanning and may miss endpoint threats.
They require constant software updates
on endpoints. They cannot be deployed in
virtualized environments or they
increase the number of software
vulnerabilities on a system. Which of
the following describes a key security
concern with agentless security
solutions?
Correct answer is they rely on external
network scanning and may miss endpoint
threats. What is a primary security risk
of using unsupported systems and
applications? They require two-factor
authentication for access. They
automatically encrypt all stored data.
They no longer receive security patches,
making them vulnerable to exploits. Or
they prevent users from accessing
web-based applications. A primary
security risk of using unsupported
systems and applications.
Correct answer is they no longer receive
security patches making them vulnerable
to exploits.
Which type of attack commonly uses
fishing emails to trick recipients into
clicking malicious links or downloading
malware? Denial of service, email based
fishing, brute force attack or SQL
injection. Which type of attack commonly
uses fishing emails to trick recipients
into clicking malicious links?
Correct answer is email-based fishing.
Which term describes a fishing attack
that is conducted via text messages?
Vishing, spoofing, whailing, or
smishing.
Correct answer is smishing. Attackers
may use instant messaging platforms to
distribute malware by doing which of the
following? Sending short malicious links
to users, forcing password resets on all
user accounts, disabling two-factor
authentication for all users, or
encrypting messages with endtoend
encryption. Attackers may use instant
messaging platforms to distribute
malware by doing which of the following?
Correct answer is sending short and
malicious links to users. What type of
cyber attack involves hiding malicious
code within an image file? SQL
injection, denial of service, image
based stenography, or cross-sight
scripting.
hiding malicious code within an image
file.
Correct answer is image-based
stenography. Which method is commonly
used to deliver malware via seemingly
harm seemingly harmless documents such
as PDFs and Microsoft Office files? DNS
poisoning, file-based attack,
cross-sight scripting, or
man-in-the-middle attack?
Feels very similar to the one we just
had. File-based attack. A social
engineering attack where an attacker
uses caller ID spoofing to impersonate a
trusted entity is known as what?
Vishing, smishing, fishing, or whailing.
Caller ID spoofing to impersonate a
trusted entity.
Correct answer is vishing.
Why are removable storage devices often
a security risk in organizations? They
increase network bandwidth usage. They
always require internet access to
function. They can introduce malware or
be used for data exfiltration or they
automatically encrypt all data stored on
them. Why are removable devices often a
security risk in organizations?
Correct answer is they can introduce
malware or be used for data
exfiltration.
What is a key security concern when
using an agentless security solution? It
requires extensive software
installations on all user devices. It
prevents systems from communicating over
the network. It automatically blocks all
incoming connections by default or it
relies on external scanning and may miss
endpoint specific threats. What is a key
security concern when using an agentless
security solution?
Correct answer is it relies on external
scanning and may miss endpoint specific
threats. What is a major security risk
of using unsupported systems in
applications? They can no longer receive
security patches making them vulnerable
to exploits. They automatically enforce
strict access control policies. They
prevent all external network
communications or they enhance system
performance by removing outdated
features. There's a major security risk
for using unsupported systems and
applications.
Correct answer is they no longer receive
security patches making them vulnerable
to exploits.
Are we I feel like we're seeing a few of
these again. Which of the following is a
common security risk associated with
unsecured wireless networks? They
prevent network devices from
communicating with each other. They
block all inbound and outbound
connections. They allow unauthorized
users to intercept and access network
traffic or they enforce mandatory
encryption on all data transmissions.
A common security risk associated with
unsecured wireless networks.
Correct answer is they allow
unauthorized users to intercept and
access network traffic. What is a
primary security risk assoc associated
with unsecure wired networks? Wireless
signals can be easily intercepted by
unauthorized users. All network traffic
is automatically encrypted and cannot be
accessed. Wired networks are inherently
immune to security risks or attackers
can physically connect to the network
and intercept traffic.
A primary security risk associated with
unsecured wired networks.
Correct answer is attackers can
physically connect to the network and
intercept traffic. Which type of attack
exploits unsecure Bluetooth connections
to eaves drop or manipulate
communications?
Blue snarfing, fishing, DNS poisoning,
or SQL injection?
Correct answer is blue snarfing. I think
there were just some extra questions in
there. Why are some why are open service
ports considered a security risk? They
automatically encrypt all incoming and
outgoing data. They prevent unauthorized
users from connecting to the network.
They can be exploited by attackers to
gain unauthorized access to a system or
they disable unnecessary services on
network devices. Why are open service
ports considered a security risk?
Correct answer is they can be exploited
by attackers to gain unauthorized access
to a system. Why should default
credentials be changed immediately after
installing a new device or system?
Default usernames and passwords are
widely known and be exploited by
attackers. They increase network
performance by optimizing authentication
processes. They prevent brute force
attacks by enforcing strong password
policies or they provide additional
security layers against unauthorized
access. Why should default credentials
be changed immediately after installing
a new device or system?
Correct answer is default usernames and
passwords are widely known and can be
exploited by attackers. Which of the
following is a primary risk associated
with thirdparty managed service
providers? They eliminate the need for
internal IT security measures. They
always provide stronger security than
in-house teams. They can introduce
security vulnerabilities through weak
security controls or they block all
external network traffic threats
automatically.
Primary risk associated with thirdparty
managed service providers.
Correct answer is they can introduce
security vulnerabilities through weak
security controls. Which of the
following best describes a security risk
posed by vendors in the supply chain?
Vendors always use the most secure
authentication methods. Vendors
eliminate the need for endpoint security
solutions. Vendors always encrypt data
before transmitting to clients. Or
vendors may have weak security controls
that expose organizations to attacks.
Best describes a security risk posed by
vendors in the supply chain.
Correct answer is vendors may have weak
security controls that expose
organizations to attacks.
Why is a supply chain security critical?
Why is supply chain security critical in
cyber security risk management?
Suppliers can introduce vulnerabilities
that affect an organization's security
posture. Supply chain partners are never
targeted by cyber criminals. Suppliers
always ensure that all thirdparty
software is secure or supply chains have
no impact on security risks.
Why is supply chain security critical in
cyber security risk management?
Correct answer is suppliers can
introduce vulnerabilities that affect an
organization's security posture. Which
type of social engineering attack
involves sending fraudulent emails that
appear to come from a trusted source to
trick users into revealing sensitive
information? Vishing, smishing, fishing,
or impersonation?
involves sending fraudulent emails that
come appear to come from a trusted
source. Correct answer is fishing. I
feel like it's also impersonation, but
what type of social engineering attack
involves using voice calls to manipulate
individuals into divulging confidential
information? fishing, fishing, smishing,
or watering hole attack.
Voice calls to manipulate individuals
into divulging confidential information.
Correct answer is fishing. A cyber
criminal sends fake text message
claiming to be from a bank urging the
recipient to verify their account
details. What type of attack is this?
Vishing, smishing, typos squatting, or
business email compromise?
Fake test me text message claiming to be
from a bank.
Correct answer is smishing. Which of the
following describes the intentional
spread of false information to
manipulate public perception?
Pretexting, watering hole attack,
misinformation or disinformation, or
brand impersonation.
Intentional spread of false information
to manipulate public perception is
misinformation or disinformation.
Witchtack involves an individual
pretending to be someone else to gain
unauthorized access to systems or
information. Impersonation, typo
squatting, smishing, or watering hole
attack.
pretending to be someone else to gain
unauthorized access to systems or
information.
Correct answer is impersonation. A CEO
receives an email that appears to be
from their CFO instructing them to
transfer money to an unfamiliar account.
What type of attack is this? Fishing,
watering hole attack, business email
compromise, or typo squatting?
email that appears to be from their CFO
instructing them to transfer money to an
unfamiliar account. Correct answer is
business email compromise. Which social
engineering technique involves an
attacker creating a fabricated scenario
to convince a victim to reveal
information? Vishing, pre-texting, brand
impersonation, or typo squatting.
Fabricated scenario to convince a victim
to reveal information.
Correct answer is pretexting.
An attacker compromises a website
frequently visited by a target audience
to spread malware. What type of attack
is this? Watering hole attack, typo
squatting, fishing, or smishing?
Compromise is a website frequently
visited by a target audience to spread
malware.
Correct answer is watering hole attack.
Cyber criminals create a fake website
that looks identical to a well-known
brand to steal user credentials. What
type of attack is this? Smishing,
pretexting, brand impersonation, or
misinformation?
A fake website that looks identical to a
well-known brand.
Correct answer is brand impersonation.
An attacker registers a domain name
similar to a legitimate website hoping
users will mistype the URL and enter
sensitive information. What is this
attack called? Fishing, watering hole
attack, business email compromise, or
typo squatting.
Correct answer is typos squatting.
What type of security vulnerability
occurs when an application improperly
handles user input leading to unintended
actions or code execution? Application
vulnerability, time of check or TOC
attack, malicious update or race
condition.
Correct answer is application
vulnerability.
Which attack technique involves
injecting malicious code into a
process's memory to execute unauthorized
commands? Time of use or TOU attack,
cross-sight scripting, memory injection,
or SQL injection.
Malicious code into a process's memory
to execute unauthorized commands.
Correct answer is memory injection. A
program fails to properly allocate
memory, allowing an attacker to
overwrite adjacent me adjacent memory
locations. What type of attack is this?
Race condition, time of use attack,
malicious update, or buffer overflow
fails to properly allocate memory,
allowing an attacker to overwrite
adjacent memory locations.
That is buffer overflow. Which type of
attack occurs when multiple processes
attempt to execute a task simultaneously
causing unpredictable behavior? Race
condition, SQL injection, memory
injection, or cross-sight scripting.
Multiple processes attempt to execute a
task simultaneously.
Correct answer is race condition.
Witchtack exploits the time gap between
checking a resource's state and using
it, allowing an attacker to modify it.
Buffer overflow, SQL uh structured query
language injection, time of check
attack, or cross-sight scripting
exploits the time gap between checking a
resource state and using it.
Correct answer is time of check attack.
An attacker modifies a file between its
initial verification and execution
leading to unauthorized actions. What
type of attack is this? Time of use
attack, memory injection, race
condition, or SQL injection.
Modifies a file between its initial
verification and execution. Correct
answer is time ofuse attack. A user
installs a software update that contains
hidden malware. What type of attack is
this? malicious update, time of check
attack, memory injection, or buffer
overflow
installs a software update that contains
hidden malware.
Correct answer is malicious update.
Which type of vulnerability primarily
targets operating system processes and
security mechanisms? Web- based attack,
memory injection attack, SQL injection,
or operating systembased attack?
What primary targets primarily targets
operating system processes and security
me uh security mechanisms that would be
an operating systembased attack? What
type of security vulnerability commonly
exploits weaknesses in web applications
to perform unauthorized actions? Time of
use attack, malicious update, web- based
attack, or buffer overflow.
Weaknesses in web applications to
perform unauthorized actions is a
web-based attack. Which tack technique
involves injecting malicious SQL
statements into a database query to
manipulate or extract data. SQL
injection, race condition, cross-sight
scripting, or memory injection?
Correct answer is SQL injection. Which
web security vulnerability allows
attackers to inject scripts into web
pages viewed by other users? Time of
check attack, malicious update, buffer
overflow, or cross-sight scripting
allows attackers to inject scripts into
web pages viewed by other users.
Correct answer is cross-sight scripting.
Which of the following is a security
risk associated with outdated firmware?
It no longer receives security updates,
making it vulnerable to exploits. It
prevents unauthorized access by default.
It automatically encrypts all network
traffic or it enhances system
performance and security over time.
Security risk associated with outdated
firmware.
Correct answer is it no longer receives
security updates making it vulnerable to
exploits. What is a major security
concern with endof life hardware? It
automatically integrates with the latest
security protocols. It enforces
multiffactor authentication by default.
It no longer receives security patches
increasing vulnerability to attacks or
it ensures that all network traffic is
encrypted.
Major security concerned with endof life
hardware.
Correct answer is it no longer receives
security patches increasing
vulnerability to attacks. Legacy systems
often pose a security risk because they
automatically patch vulnerabilities
without user intervention, may not
support modern security updates and
encryption standards, are immune to
modern cyber threats, or use the latest
cloud security technologies.
Legacy systems often pose a security
risk because
they may not support modern security
updates and encryption standards. What
is the primary security risk of a
virtual machine escape attack? An
attacker gains access to the host system
from within a virtual machine. A virtual
machine is deleted without proper
authorization. A virtual machine is
isolated from the network for security
reasons or multiple virtual machines
compete for hardware resources. The
primary security risk of a virtual
machine escape attack.
Correct answer is an attacker gains
access to the host system from within a
virtual machine.
Why is resource reuse a security concern
in virtualization? It prevents the
execution of malicious processes. It
automatically encrypts all stored data.
Residual data from previous virtual
machines can be accessed by new
instances or it ensures that all system
resources are properly allocated. Why is
resource reuse a security concern in
virtualization?
Correct answer is residual data from
previous virtual machines can be
accessed by new instances.
Which security concern is unique to
avoid
not sure why I added that extra word.
Which security concern is unique to
cloud environments? Cloud storage
eliminates the need for encryption.
Cloud services automatically block all
unauthorized access. Local security
policies do not apply to cloud
environments. or shared infrastructure
can lead to data leakage between tenants
which is unique to cloud environments.
Correct answer is shared infrastructure
can lead to data leakage between
tenants. What is a primary risk when
relying on thirdparty service providers?
A security breach in the provider system
can impact client data. The provider
enforces multiffactor authentication on
all client accounts. The provider
guarantees protection against all cyber
threats or all data stored within the
prior provider is automatically
encrypted.
Primary risk for relying on thirdparty
service providers.
Correct answer is a security breach in
the provider system can impact client
data. What is a common security risk
associated with hardware providers in
the supply chain? Hardware providers
always implement the latest security
updates. Hardware providers enforce
end-to-end encryption by default.
Hardware components may be comprised
compromised before deployment or
hardware providers eliminate the need
for firmware updates. Common security
risk associated with hardware providers
in the supply chain.
Correct answer is hardware components
may be compromised before deployment.
There was actually an instance um in a
company that I work for. I know I'm not
not supposed to be given extra
information, but in a company that I
worked for, there were chipsets that
they found on circuit boards from
overseas from China, and it was a
massive massive uh security risk, and
they changed all of their supply chain
uh supply chain rules based on that. It
was absolutely wild. It's I'm I'm not
going to say the company, but just based
on that, it's it was it was a ridiculous
a huge situation. Um why is so but it
does it absolutely does happen. Why is
software supply chain security critical?
Compromised software updates can
introduce malware into systems. Software
providers always enforce strict security
measures. Software vulnerabilities do
not impact modern security models or all
software is pre-validated against
security threats before installation.
Why is software supply chain security
critical?
Correct answer is compromised software
updates can introduce malware into
systems. Which of the following best
describes a cryptographic security risk?
Encryption prevents unauthorized access
to data. Cryptographic keys cannot be
stolen or misused. Weak encryption
algorithms can be cracked by attackers.
Or strong encryption eliminates the need
for authentication measures,
which best describes a cryptographic
security risk.
Correct answer is weak encryption
algorithms can be cracked by attackers.
Which security risk arises when a
system, application or network is not
configured properly, potentially
exposing vulnerabilities,
misconfiguration,
sideloading, zero day attack or
jailbreaking.
Correct answer is misconfiguration.
What is the security risk of sideloading
applications on a mobile device? The
device is automatically encrypted upon
installation. Sideloading ensures that
only verified apps are installed. It
prevents unauthorized applications from
being installed or the app may bypass
security controls and introduce malware.
What is a security risk of sideloading
applications on a mobile device?
Correct answer is the app may bypass
security controls and introduce malware
Android users.
I freaked you out a little bit right
there. Right there, didn't I? I know
some of you are doing it. Nah, you guys
aren't doing it. You guys know better.
Which term describes the process of
removing manufacturer restrictions on a
mobile device, potentially exposing it
to security risks? Side loading, zeroday
attack, jailbreaking, or
misconfiguration?
describes the process of removing
manufacturer restrictions on a mobile
device.
Correct answer is jailbreaking. What
type of attack exploits a previously
unknown software vulnerability before a
fix is available? Zeroday attack,
sideloading, jailbreaking, or
misconfiguration.
exploits a previously unknown software
vulnerability before a fix is available.
Correct answer is zero day attack. What
type of malware encrypts a victim's
files and demands payments to restore
access? Trojan, key logger, logic bomb,
or ransomware?
What encrypts a victim's files and
demands payments to restore access?
Correct answer is ransomware. Which type
of malware disguises itself as a
legitimate program but secretly executes
malicious activities? Trojan, virus,
bloatware, or rootkit?
Disguises itself as a legitimate program
but secretly ex executes malicious
activities?
Correct answer is a Trojan. Which type
of malware is self-replicating and
spreads without human intervention? A
logic bomb, spyw wear, a worm, or
ransomware.
This reminds me of the movie Swordfish.
Correct answer is a worm. I don't know
why randomly it reminds me of that. Uh,
which type of malware is designed to
secretly monitor a user's activity and
collect personal information? Virus,
Trojan, bloatware, or spyw wear?
secretly monitor a user's activity and
collect personal information.
Correct answer is spyw wear. What is a
common characteristic of bloatware? It
spreads by exploiting vulnerabilities in
a network. It secretly logs keystrokes
to steal credentials. It consists of
unnecessary pre-installed software that
slows down a device or it modifies
system files to gain persistent access,
a common characteristic of bloatware.
Correct answer is it consists of
unnecessary pre-installed software that
slows down a device.
Which type of malware attaches itself to
a legitimate file and requires user
execution to spread? Virus, worm,
rootkit, or spyware.
Attaches itself to a legitimate file and
requires user execution to spread.
Correct answer is a virus. What type of
malware records user keystrokes to steal
sensitive information? Logic bomb,
Trojan, key logger, or worm?
Records user keystrokes?
Correct answer is a key logger. What
type of malware is designed to execute a
malicious function when specific
condition is met? Key logger, logic
bomb, virus, or ransomware?
execute a malicious function when a
specific condition is met. Correct
answer is a logic bomb. What type of
malware is designed to hide its presence
by modifying operating system
components? Is it a rootkit, Trojan,
bloatware, or logic bomb? Hide its
presence by modifying operating system
components.
Correct answer is a rootkit. Which type
of attack systematically attempts
multiple password combinations to gain
unauthorized access? Brute force on path
attack, amplified attack, or credential
replay attack.
Multiple password combinations to gain
unauthorized access. Correct answer is a
brute force attack. Which attack
involves copying data from an RFID tag
without authorization? DNS poisoning, on
path attack, RFID cloning or wireless
jamming
involves copying data from an RFID tag
without authorization.
Correct answer is RFID cloning. Which
physical security risk is associated
with extreme heat, cold or humidity
affecting IT infrastructure? Brute force
attack, DOS attack, credential replay
attack, or environmental attack?
Correct answer is an environmental
attack. Which type of network attack
overwhelms a target system with
excessive traffic to cause service
disruption, credential replay,
distributed denial of service or DOS,
RFID cloning, or brute force, overwhelms
a target system with excessive traffic
to cause service disruption.
Correct answer is distributed denial of
service. Witchtack amplifies the amount
of traffic sent to a target by
leveraging misconfigured third-party
servers. Amplified attack, on path
attack, DNS poisoning or wireless
hijacking.
Amplifies the amount of traffic sent to
a target by leveraging misconfigured
third-party servers. Correct answer is
amplified attack. A cyber criminal sends
a request to multiple open servers which
then respond by sending large amounts of
traffic to the victim. What type of
attack is this? Brute force attack, RFID
cloning, reflected attack, or credential
replay attack
requests to multiple open servers which
then respond by sending large amounts of
traffic to the victim.
Correct answer is a reflected attack.
Which type of attack manipulates DNS
records to redirect users to malicious
websites? DNS attack, wireless
hijacking, amplified attack, or brute
force attack.
Correct answer is a DNS attack.
Surprising, right? Which network attack
targets weaknesses in wireless security
protocols to gain unauthorized access?
Credential replay attack, brute force
attack, RFID cloning, or wireless
attack?
targets weaknesses in wireless security
protocols to gain unauthorized access.
Correct answer is a wireless attack.
Which type attack involves intercepting
communication between two parties to
steal or modify data? Brute force
attack, DNS poisoning attack, on path
attack, or amplified attack.
Correct answer is an onpath attack.
Which tech involves capturing and
reusing authentication data to gain
unauthorized access to a system?
Credential replay attack, wireless
hijacking, DNS poisoning attack, or a
DOS attack.
Capturing and reusing authentication
data to gain unauthorized access to a
system.
Correct answer is a credential replay
attack. Which type of network attack
involves injecting harmful code into a
system to compromise security? brute
force attack, malicious code attack,
RFID cloning, or a reflected attack.
Injecting harmful code into a system to
compromise security? Correct answer is a
malicious code attack. Which type of
application attack involves inserting
malicious code into an application's
input fields to manipulate its
execution? Privilege escalation, buffer
overflow, injection attack, or directory
traversal.
involves inserting malicious code into
an application's input fields to
manipulate its execution.
Correct answer is an injection attack.
What type of attack occurs when an
application writes more data to a memory
buffer than it was designed to hold,
potentially allowing arbitrary code
execution? Privilege escalation, replay
attack, directory traversal, or buffer
overflow.
More data to a memory buffer than it was
designed to hold.
Correct answer is a buffer overflow.
Which tack captures and retransmits
valid authentication data to gain
unauthorized access to a system? Replay
attack, privilege escalation, buffer
overflow or injection attack.
Captures and retransmits valid
authentication data to gain unauthorized
access to a system. Is a replay attack.
Which type of attack occurs when an
attacker gains unauthorized access to
higher level privileges in a system or
application? Directory traversal, replay
attack, privilege escalation, or
injection attack.
Unauthorized access to higher level
privileges in a system or application.
Correct answer is privilege escalation.
Which application attack tricks a system
into performing an action by forging
request from a trusted user? Forgery
attack, replay attack, buffer overflow,
or privilege escalation.
Correct answer is a forgery attack. What
type of attack exploits improper input
validation to gain unauthorized access
to a to restricted directories on a web
server? Injection attack, buffer
overflow, directory traversal, or a
replay attack?
exploits improper input validation to
gain unauthorized access.
Correct answer is directory traversal.
Which cryptographic attack forces a
system to use weaker encryption protocol
making it easier to compromise?
Collision attack, replay attack,
downgrade attack, or forgery attack.
Weaker encryption protocol making it
easier to compromise. Correct answer is
a downgrade attack. Which cryptographic
attack occurs when two different inputs
produce the same hash value compromising
the integrity of the system? Downgrade
attack, buffer overflow, directory
traversal, or collision attack.
Two different inputs producing the same
hash value compromising the integrity of
the system. Correct answer is a
collision attack. Which cryptographic
attack takes advantage of the
probability that two different inputs
will produce the same hash value?
Birthday attack, brute force attack,
spraying attack, or collision attack.
Two different inputs will produce the
same hash value. Correct answer is a
birthday attack. Which password attack
attempts to gain access by testing a few
commonly used passwords across many
accounts? Brute force attack, spraying
attack, dictionary attack, or credential
stuffing?
to gain access by testing a few commonly
used passwords across many accounts.
Correct answer is a spray attack. Spray
and prey. Which password attack
systematically tries all possible
combinations until the correct one is
found? Brute force attack, spraying
attack, birthday attack, or rainbow
table attack.
Tries all possible combinations until
the correct one is found.
Correct answer is a brute force attack.
Which indicator of the password attack
involves multiple failed login attempts
resulting in the automatic disabling of
an account? Impossible travel, out of
cycle logging, account lockout, or
blocked content.
Multiple fail login attempts resulting
in automatic disabling of an account is
account lockout. Which indicator
suggests that an account is being
accessed from multiple locations at the
same time? Blocked content, resource
inaccessibility, published documented
indicators, or concurrent sess
concurrent session usage. Concurrent
session. Wow, I really cannot say that
word. Session.
Correct answer is a concurrent session
usage.
What security indicator prevents users
from accessing certain from accessing
certain web pages or online services due
to security policies, resource
inaccessibility, outofcycle logging,
blocked content, or impossible travel
certain web pages or online services due
to security policies? Correct answer is
blocked content. Which security alert
indicates that a login attempt was made
from an unusually distant location in a
short period of time? Impossible travel,
concurrent session usage, account
lockout, or resource consumption?
Correct answer is impossible travel.
Which of the following indicates an
attack that excessively uses CPU,
memory, or bandwidth to degrade system
performance? Blocked content. Impossible
travel. publish documented indicators or
resource consumption.
Correct answer is resource consumption.
Which security concern involves a user
or system being unable to access files,
networks or applications due to an
attack? Concurrent session usage,
published documented indicators,
resource inaccessibility or resource
consumption
involves a user or system being unable
to access files, networks or
applications.
Correct answer is resource
inaccessibility.
Which of the following is a sign of
potential malicious activity when users
when logs appear outside their normal
time frame? Out of cycle logging,
impossible travel, blocked content, or
resource inaccessibility.
Potential malicious activity when logs
appear outside their normal time frame.
Correct answer is out of cycle logging.
What is a common source for security
analysts to find known indicators of
compromise or IoC's? Blocked content,
published or documented indicators,
impossible travel or resource
consumption.
Common source for security analysts to
find known indicators of compromise.
Correct answer is published or
documented indicators.
Which security issue occurs when logs
that should exist for forensic analysis
are missing? Missing logs, account
lockout, blocked content, or out of
cycle logging. Do we even need Some of
these are just so obvious. Missing logs.
I feel like you don't need to really
think about that one if the answer is in
the question. Which security pract those
are called gimmies. Which security
practice involves dividing a network
into smaller isolated sections to reduce
attack surfaces? Encryption, patching,
segmentation, or application allow list.
dividing a network into smaller isolated
sections to reduce attack surfaces.
Correct answer is segmentation.
Which security mechanism defines rules
that determine which users or devices
can access specific resources? Access
control list, encryption, isolation, or
segmentation.
Rules that determine which users or
devices can access specific resources.
Correct answer is access control list.
Which security feature specifies what
actions users can perform on a system or
file? Segmentation, application allow
list, encryption or permissions.
What actions users can perform on a
system or file?
Correct answer is permissions. Which
security measure restricts software
execution to a predefined list of
approved applications? Segmentation,
application allow list, access control
list, or permissions.
Which security measure restricts
software execution to a predefined list
of approved applications?
Correct answer is an application allow
list. Which security concept involves
running applications or systems in a
contained environment to prevent threats
from spreading? Access control list
patching segmentation or isolation.
Correct answer is isolation. What
security practice involves applying
updates to software and systems to fix
vulnerabilities? Encryption,
segmentation, application allow list, or
patching?
Applying updates to software and systems
to fix vulnerabilities.
Correct answer is patching. What
security technique ensures that data is
encoded to only authorized parties can
access it? Access control list,
encryption, isolation or patching.
Only authorized parties can access it.
Correct answer is encryption. What
security practice involves continuously
observing network traffic and system
activity to detect threats, monitoring,
hardening techniques, decommissioning or
configuration enforcement,
continuously observing network traffic
and system activity to detect threats?
Correct answer is monitoring.
Which principle ensures that users and
applications only have the minimum level
of access required to perform their
tasks? decommissioning, encryption,
hardening techniques or least privilege.
The minimum level of access required to
perform their tasks?
Correct answer is least privilege. Which
security control ensures that system
configurations comply with the
established security policies and
standards? Configuration enforcement,
monitoring, least privilege or hardening
techniques.
comply with established security
policies and standards. Correct answer
is configuration enforcement. What is
the process of securely removing
outdated systems and hardware to prevent
unauthorized access to sensitive data?
Monitoring, configuration enforcement,
decommissioning or hardening techniques,
removing outdated systems and hardware
to prevent unauthorized access to
sensitive data. That would be
decommissioning.
Which security practice involves
strengthening a system by disabling
unnecessary services, removing default
accounts, and applying security updates,
monitoring, hardening techniques, lease
privilege or decommissioning,
disabling unnecessary services, removing
default accounts, and applying security
updates.
Correct answer is hardening techniques.
Which security technique ensures that
data is encoded so that only unauthor
ensures that data is encoded so that
only authorized users can access and
read it? Encryption, configuration
enforcement, hardening techniques or
least privilege.
Correct answer is encryption.
What is the primary purpose of
installing endpoint protection on a
device? to configure firewall settings
for outbound connections, to disable
unnecessary ports and protocols, to
detect and prevent malware, unauthorized
access, and other security threats, or
to enforce network segmentation.
The primary purpose of installing
endpoint protection on a device.
Correct answer is to detect and prevent
malware, unauthorized access, and other
security threats.
Which security solution is designed to
monitor and filter incoming and outgoing
traffic on an individual computer?
Endpoint protection, hostbased intrusion
prevention system or HIPS, network
firewall or hostbased firewall? Which
security solution is designed to monitor
and filter incoming and outgoing
traffic?
Correct answer is the hostbased
firewall. Which security control
actively monitors and prevents malicious
activities on an endpoint? Hostbased
intrusion prevention system or HIPS
network firewall endpoint protection or
default password enforcement
actively monitors and prevents malicious
activities on an endpoint.
Correct answer is hostbased intrusion
prevention system. Why is it important
to disable unnecessary ports and
protocols on a system? To improve
network bandwidth for high priority
services, to allow unrestricted access
to external connections, to reduce the
attack surface by limiting potential
entry points for attackers, or to
enhance encryption methods used in
network communication.
Why is it important to disable
unnecessary ports and protocols on a
system? Correct answer is to reduce the
attack surface by limiting potential
entry points for attackers.
Why should default passwords on devices
and applications be changed immediately
after installation? Default credentials
are widely known and could be exploited
by attackers. Default passwords increase
system performance. Changing default
passwords disables administrator access
or default passwords enforce stronger
authentication methods measures.
Correct answer is default credentials
are widely known and could be exploited
by attackers.
What is the security benefit of removing
unnecessary software from a system? It
enhances encryption strength on the
system. It prevents unauthorized users
from changing system configurations. It
allows software to execute with higher
privileges or it reduces the attack
surface by eliminating potential
vulnerabilities.
The security benefit to removing
unnecessary software from a system.
Correct answer is it reduces the attack
surface by eliminating potential
vulnerabilities.
First question, which of the following
is a security concern when using cloud
computing? data exposure due to shared
infrastructure and multi-tenency.
Guaranteed complete control over all
security configurations. No need for
encryption since cloud providers handle
all security. Or cloud computing
eliminates the risk of insider threats
which is a security concern when using
cloud computing.
Correct answer is data exposure due to
shared infrastructure and multi-tenency.
Question two, what is the purpose of a
responsibility matrix in cloud security?
To enforce firewall rules for network
segmentation, to manage thirdparty
vendor agreements for data processing,
to define security and operational
responsibilities between cloud providers
and customers or to track access logs
for all infrastructure components. What
is the purpose of a responsibility
matrix in cloud security?
Correct answer is to define security and
operational responsibilities between
cloud providers and customers. And if
you need some more time to think about
the answers to these questions and
figure them out, you can always pause
the video and then restart it whenever
you're ready. Which security concern is
unique to hybrid cloud environments?
Ensuring secure data transfer between
on- premises and cloud resources. Lack
of encryption support for sensitive
data. Guaranteed automatic compliance
with all regulations or hybrid clouds
prevent insider threats by design which
is security concern is unique to hybrid
cloud environments unique to hybrid
cloud.
Correct answer is ensuring secure data
transfer between on premises and cloud
resources.
What is a primary security risk
associated with third-party vendors in
an organization's infrastructure?
Third-party vendors always follow the
organization's internal security
policies. Using thirdparty vendors
eliminates the need for security audits.
Vendors cannot access any part of an in
organization's infrastructure or vendors
may have weak security practices that
expose the organization to attacks. Was
a primary security risk associated with
third-party vendors in an organization's
infrastructure.
Correct answer is vendors may have weak
security practices that expose the
organization to attacks.
Which security advantage does
infrastructure as a code provide? IA
eliminates the need for network
firewalls. IA enforces consistent
security configurations across
deployments. IA prevents unauthorized
access by default. or IA requires manual
configuration of security policies for
each deployment. Which security
advantage does infrastructure as code or
A provide?
Correct answer is IA enforces consistent
security configurations across
deployments.
Which security challenge is associated
with serverless computing? Lack of
control over the underlying
infrastructure and runtime environment.
The need for dedicated physical servers
for each application. Serverless
applications cannot be exploited by
attackers or serverless environments
eliminate the need for identity and
access management which security
challenge is associated with serverless
computing.
Correct answer is the lack of control
over the underlying infrastructure and
runtime environment. What is a key
security consideration when using
microervices architecture? Eliminating
the need for security updates since
services are isolated. Ensuring that all
microservices run in a single dedicated
server for security. Securing API
communication between services to
prevent unauthorized access or
microservices architectures are immune
to denial of service attacks. What is a
key security consideration when using
microervices
architecture?
Correct answer is securing API
communication between services to
prevent unauthorized access. Which of
the following best describes a security
concern with network infrastructure?
Network infrastructure does not require
monitoring for anomalies. A strong
password policy eliminates all network
threats. Using wired networks prevents
all cyber attacks or unauthorized access
to critical network devices can lead to
data breaches. Which of the following
best describes a security concern with
network infrastructure?
Correct answer is unauthorized access to
critical network devices can lead to
data breaches.
What is the primary security benefit of
physically isolating a system from
external networks? It reduces the risk
of remote cyber attacks and data
breaches. It eliminates the need for
firewalls and antivirus software. It
ensures that only encrypted traffic is
allowed on the network or prevents
hardware failures in critical systems.
What is the primary security benefit of
physically isolating a system from
external networks?
Correct answer is it reduces the risk of
remote cyber attacks and data breaches.
Which security measure involves
completely disconnecting a system from
external networks to prevent cyber
threats? Air gapped, logical
segmentation, softwaredefined networking
or on premises?
Which security measure involves uh
measure involves completely
disconnecting a system from external
networks to prevent cyber threats?
Correct answer is airgapped.
Logical segmentation in a network is
primarily used to physically separate
systems in a data center, prevent power
failures from affecting connected
devices, restrict access between
different departments or user groups, or
ensure that all data is stored on local
devices only. Logical segmentation in a
network is primarily used to do which of
the following?
Correct answer is restrict access
between different departments or user
groups. How does softwaredefined
networking or SDN improve network
security? It eliminates the need for
security monitoring and logging. It
centralizes network control making
security policies easier to manage. It
guarantees guarantees complete immunity
to network-based attacks or it ensures
that all physical network devices are
disconnected. How does softwaredefined
networking or SDN improve network
security?
Correct answer is it centralizes network
control making security policies easier
to manage. Which of the following is a
key security consideration for on
premises infrastructure? On-prem
infrastructure eliminates the need for
network firewalls. Cloud security
controls automatically apply to on-prem
environments. Organizations are fully
responsible for securing their hardware
and data or on-prem environments do not
require physical security controls.
Which of the following is a key security
consideration for on premises or on-prem
infrastructure?
Correct answer is organizations are
fully responsible for securing their
hardware and data. Which statement best
describes a security benefit of
centralized network management over
decentralized management? Centralized
management allows for uniform security
policies and easier monitoring.
Decentralized management completely
prevents insider threats. Centralized
management requires no authentication
for user access. where decentralized
management eliminates the need for
encryption.
Which statement best describes a
security benefit of centralized network
management over decentralized
management?
Correct answer is centralized management
allows for uniform security policies and
easier monitoring. Which security
advantage does containerization provide?
It ensures that all applications run on
the same physical server. It prevents
unauthorized physical access to data
centers. It eliminates the need for
encryption in cloud environments or it
isolates applications to limit the
impact of security breaches. Which
security advantage does containerization
provide?
Correct answer is it isolates
applications to the limit uh to limit
the impact of security breaches. Which
security risk is commonly associated
with virtualization? Virtual machine
escape where an attacker gains access to
the host system? Virtual machines
eliminate the need for security
monitoring. Virtualization prevents all
unauthorized access to systems. Or
virtual machines cannot be infected with
malware which security risk is commonly
associated with virtualization.
Correct answer is virtual machine escape
where an attacker gains access to the
host system. Which security challenge is
associated with IoT or internet of
things devices? IoT devices are always
isolated from the internet by default.
IoT devices enforce strict password
policies by default. Many IoT devices
lack strong security controls making
them vulnerable to attacks or IoT
devices cannot be remotely accessed by
attackers. Which security challenge is
associated with IoT or internet of
things devices?
Correct answer is many IoT devices lack
strong security controls making them
vulnerable to attacks. Which of the
following describes a key security
concern with industrial control systems
or ICS? ICS networks are always
airgapped and immune to attacks. ICS
systems automatically patch security
vulnerabilities in real time. ICS
environments do not require
authentication for access control or IC
systems were often designed without
built-in security making them vulnerable
to cyber threats. Which of the following
describes a key security concern with
industrial control systems?
Correct answer is ICS systems were often
designed without built-in security
making them vulnerable to cyber threats.
Supervisory control and data acquisition
or SCADA systems are commonly targeted
by cyber threats because they're always
disconnected from the internet. SCA
systems are automatically protected by
encryption. They control critical
infrastructure and are often used
outdated security protocols or they
require no authentication for access.
SCADA systems are commonly targeted by
cyber threats because
correct answer is they control critical
infrastructure and are often using
outdated security protocols. Which of
the following is a security risk
associated with real time operating
systems or RTOS? RTO RTOS systems often
prioritize performance over security
making them vulnerable to attacks. RTS
systems cannot be compromised due to
their design. RTOS automatically updates
security patches in real time or RTOS
systems do not require access controls.
Which of the following is a security
risk associated with real time operating
systems?
Correct answer is they often prioritize
performance over security making them
vulnerable to attacks. What are uh why
are embedded systems considering a
security risk? They enforce strict
multiffactor authentication by default.
They often have limited security
controls and cannot be easily
duplicated. Uh sorry up cannot be easily
updated. Embedded systems are
automatically protected from all network
threats or they are isolated from all
external connections by default. Why are
embedded systems considered a security
risk?
Correct answer is they often have
limited security controls and cannot be
easily updated.
What is the primary goal of high
availability in IT security? Ensuring
continuous system uptime and minimizing
downtime due to failures or attacks,
eliminating the need for network
security monitoring, preventing users
from accessing critical systems during
security updates, or automatically
blocking all incoming network traffic.
What is the primary goal of high
availability in IT security?
Correct answer is ensuring continuous
system uptime and minimizing downtime
due to failures or attacks. Which of the
following is a key security
consideration when implementing new
technologies in an organization?
Deploying systems without any
authentication requirements, avoiding
encryption to reduce processing
overhead, ensuring proper risk
assessment and compliance with security
policies, or prioritizing ease of use
over security controls. Which of the
following is a key security
consideration when implementing new
technologies in an organization?
Correct answer is ensuring proper risk
assessment and compliance with security
policies. Which term describes an
organization's ability to keep systems
operational and accessible during
disruptions? Availability, scalability,
ease of deployment, or responsiveness?
Which term describes an organization's
ability to keep systems operational and
accessible during disruptions?
Correct answer is availability.
What is a primary goal of resilience in
cyber security? To reduce the cost of
deploying security tools, to eliminate
all security vulnerabilities in an
organization, to prevent unauthorized
access through physical isolation, or to
ensure systems can recover quickly from
disruptions or cyber attacks with the
primary goal of resilience in cyber
security.
Correct answer is to ensure systems can
recover quickly from disruptions or
cyber attacks.
Why is cost an important factor when
implementing cyber security solutions?
Organizations must balance security
needs with budget constraints. Higher
cost always guarantees better security.
Cyber security solutions should only
implemented if they're free or spending
more on security eliminates all cyber
threats. Why is cost an important factor
when implementing cyber security
solutions? Some of these I'm sure you
realize they're making me laugh.
Correct answer is organizations must
balance security needs with budget
constraints. Could you imagine if all of
the best cyber security solutions were
free? Uh I mean some of them are some of
them there there's some good free
resources but which factor is critical
in evaluating the responsiveness of a
cyber security solution? the number of
employees trained in cyber security
awareness, the amount of data stored in
organization servers, the ability to
detect and mitigate threats in real
time, or the overall cost of
implementing a firewall. Which factor is
critical in evaluating the
responsiveness of a cyber security
solution?
Correct answer is the ability to detect
and mitigate threats in real time. What
does scalability refer to in cyber
security architecture? The ability to
expand security measures as the
organization grows, the use of
encryption to protect sensitive data,
the immediate responsiveness of an
intrusion detection system, or the ease
of deploying new security patches. What
does scalability refer to in cyber
security architecture?
Correct answer is the ability to expand
security measures as the organization
grows. Why is ease of deployment an
important consideration when
implementing security solutions? Complex
deployment pro uh complex deployment
processes ensure maximum security. The
more difficult a solution is to dis
deploy, the more secure it is. Ease of
deployment is not a concern as long as a
system is secure or security solutions
should be easy to configure and
integrate without disrupting business
operations. Why is ease of deployment an
important consideration in implementing
security solutions?
Correct answer is security solution
should be easy to configure and
integrate without disrupting business
operations.
What is an example of risk transference
in cyber security? purchasing cyber
security insurance to cover potential
data breaches, accepting all risks
without taking preventive measures,
eliminating all risks by shutting down
the system, or ignoring vulnerabilities
due to budget constraints. What is an
example of risk transference in cyber
security?
Correct answer is purchasing cyber
security insurance to cover potential
data breaches. Which factor is crucial
for ensuring ease of recovery after a
cyber security incident? Relying on
outdated software to prevent
compatibility issues, keeping all
network devices connected from each
other, disconnected from each other,
maintaining regular backups and a tested
disaster recovery plan or disabling
encryption to speed up system
performance. Which factor is crucial for
ensuring ease of recovery after a cyber
security incident?
Correct answer is maintaining regular
backups and a tested disaster recovery
plan. Why is patch availability
important in cyber security? It ensures
that known vulnerabilities are fixed
before attackers can employ them uh
exploit them. It eliminates the need for
network firewalls. It prevents the need
for authentication on secure systems or
it removes the need for intrusion
detection systems. Why is patch
availability important in cyber
security?
Correct answer is it ensures that known
vulnerabilities are fixed before
attackers can exploit them. What is a
major security risk of an inability to
patch a system? The system becomes
immune to malware and cyber attacks. It
increases the processing power of
network devices. The system remains
vulnerable to known exploits and attacks
or it eliminates the need for monitoring
and logging. What is a major security
risk of an inability to patch a system?
Some of these are easier than others. So
the answer is the system remains
vulnerable to known exploits and
attacks. Why is power availability a
critical consideration for IT security?
Uninterrupted power supply increases the
risk of cyber attacks. Power failures
can lead to downtime, data corruption,
and security vulnerabilities. Systems
with stable power do not require
additional security controls or cyber
threats only target systems with backup
power sources.
Correct answer is power failures lead to
downtime, data corruption and security
vulnerabilities.
What is a security concern related to
compute resources in an organization?
Insufficient compute power can hinder
security tools like encryption and
monitoring. More compute power uh
eliminates the need for security
updates. Compute power has no impact on
security posture or or increased compute
power reduces the risk of fishing
attacks. What is a security concern
related to compute resources in an
organization?
Correct answer is insufficient compute
power can hinder security tools like
encryption and monitoring.
Why is proper device placement important
in network security? To increase network
latency for improved security, to
prevent users from accessing security
controls, to eliminate the need for
encryption and transit or to ensure
security critical security devices are
positioned for maximum protection. Why
is proper device placement important in
network security?
Correct answer is to ensure critical
security devices are positioned for
maximum protection.
What is the purpose of security zones in
network architecture? To eliminate the
need for firewalls and intrusion
detection systems. To segment the
network into different trust levels for
better security control. To ensure all
devices communicate over a single
unprotected network or to allow
unrestricted access between internal and
external systems with the purpose of
security zones in network architecture.
Correct answer is to segment the network
into different trust levels for better
security control.
Which of the following best best
describes an attack surface? The total
number of vulnerabilities and entry
points that can be exploited, the number
of security personnel in an
organization, a firewall rule that
blocks all network traffic, or the
physical space occupied by security
devices in a data center. Which of the
following best describes an attack
surface?
Correct answer is the total number of
vulnerabilities and entry points that
can be exploited. How does connectivity
impact network security? More
connections reduce the need for
encryption. More connections increase
potential entry points for attackers.
Increased connectivity eliminates the
need for network segmentation. or
connectivity has no impact on security
risks. How does connectivity impact
network security?
Correct answer is more connections
increase potential entry points for
attackers.
What is the primary characteristic of a
fail open security control? It
completely shuts down access when a
failure occurs. It restricts users from
accessing public resources. It allows
access when a system fails prioritizing
availability over security or it
encrypts all network traffic before
shutting down with the primary
characteristic of a fail open security
control.
Correct answer is it allows access when
a system fails prioritizing availability
over security. What happens when a
security system is configured to fail
closed? It blocks access to maintain
security when a failure occurs. It
allows unrestricted access in case of
failure. It redirects traffic to
untrusted networks or it disables all
security features permanently. What
happens when a security system is
configured to fail closed?
Correct answer is it blocks access to
maintain security when a failure occurs.
The exact opposite of the last one. What
is a key difference between active and
passive security devices? Passive
devices actively prevent attacks while
active devices only generate alerts.
Active devices take immediate action to
block threats while passive devices only
monitor and log activity. Active devices
rely on user intervention while passive
devices operate independently or passive
devices do not require network
connectivity while active devices do is
the key difference between active and
passive security devices.
Correct answer is active devices take
immediate action to block threats while
passive devices only monitor and log
activity.
What is a key characteristic of an
inline security device compared to a tap
monitor device? An inline device
actively analyzes and blocks traffic in
real time while a tap monitor device
only observes traffic. A tap monitor
device blocks unauthorized network
connections. Inline devices are used
exclusively for physical security
measures or tap monitor devices require
user intervention to function. A key
characteristic of an inline security
device compared to a tap monitor device.
Correct answer is an inline device
actively analyzing black blocks traffic
in real time while a tap monitor device
only observes traffic. What is the
primary function of a jump server in
network security? It provides a secure
intermediary system for accessing
critical resources. It balances traffic
between multiple servers to improve
performance. It filters web traffic to
enforce security policies or it monitors
network activity but does not intervene
in attacks. What is the primary function
of a jump server in network security?
Correct answer is it provides a secure
intermediary system for accessing
critical resources.
How does a proxy server enhance network
security? It balances network traffic
across multiple servers. It detects and
prevents intrusion attempts in real
time. It physically isolates sensitive
systems from external networks or it
acts as an intermediary between users
and web resources to filter and monitor
traffic. How does a proxy server enhance
network security?
Correct answer is it acts as an
intermediary between users and web
resources to filter and monitor traffic.
What is the primary function of an
intrusion prevention system IPS? To
passively log network traffic for
security analysis to route network
traffic between multiple VLANs to act to
actively detect and block malicious
network activity in real time or to
encrypt data before transmission across
the network. What is the primary
function of an intrusion prevention
system or IPS?
Correct answer is to actively detect and
block malicious network activity in real
time. What is the key difference between
an intrusion detection system or IDS and
an intrusion prevention system or IPS?
An IDS monitors and alerts on suspicious
activity while an IPS actively blocks
threats. An IDS blocks unauthorized
access to applications while an IPS does
not. An IDS performs encryption while an
IPS only detects malware. Or an IPS
passively observes traffic while an IDS
actively mitigates attacks. Whereas the
key difference between an IDS or
intrusion detection system and an IPS or
intrusion prevention system.
Correct answer is an IDS monitors and
alerts on suspicious activity. IDS
intrusion detection system and an IPS or
intrusion prevention system actively
blocks threats. How does a load balancer
improve network security and
performance? It acts as an intermediary
between users and web servers to filter
content. It distributes traffic across
multiple servers to prevent overload and
mitigate DOS attacks. It passively
monitors network traffic without
intervention. or it prevents
unauthorized remote access to critical
systems. How does a load balancer
improve network security and
performance?
Correct answer is it distributes traffic
across multiple servers to prevent
overload and mitigate DOS attacks.
What is the function of sensors in
network security? They collect and
analyze data to detect potential threats
in real time. They enforce security
policies by blocking all incoming
connections. They provide physical
security by controlling access to server
rooms or they eliminate the need for
encryption in data transmission. What is
the function of sensors in network
security?
Correct answer is they collect and
analyze data to detect potential threats
in real time. was the primary function
of 8021X in network security to encrypt
network traffic between different VLANs
to block unauthorized USB devices from
connecting to a network to provide
port-based network access control using
authentication mechanisms or to enable
remote access to secure networks without
authentication with the primary function
of 8021X in network security.
Correct answer is to provide port-based
network access control using
authentication mechanisms.
Which authentication framework is used
to support multiple authentication
methods including uh including smart
cards and biometrics extensible
authentication protocol or EAP 802.1x
layer 7 firewall or web application
firewall or WF?
Which authentication framework is used
to support multiple authentication
methods including smart cards and
biometrics?
Correct answer is extensible
authentication protocol. Which type of
firewall is specifically designed to
protect web applications from threats
like SQL injection and cross-sight
scripting? Next generation firewall, web
application firewall, unified threat
management or layer 4 firewall.
Which type of firewall is specifically
designed to protect web applications
from threats like SQL injection and
cross-sight scripting?
Correct answer is web application
firewall. Which type of security
appliance combines multiple security
functions such as firewall, intrusion
prevention, and antivirus in a single
solution? Next generation firewall, web
application firewall, unified threat
management, or 802.1x,
which security appliance combines
multiple security functions such as
firewall, intrusion prevention, and
antivirus.
Security appliance.
Correct answer is unified threat
management. What is a key advantage of a
next generation firewall compared to
traditional firewalls and next
generation firewall NGFW?
NGFW is only used for physical security
purposes. NGFW blocks uh blocks all
network traffic by default without
customization. NGFW replaces the need
for encryption in network communications
or NGFW includes deep packet inspection
and advanced threat detection beyond
simple port filtering. There's a key
advantage of next generation firewall or
NGFW compared to traditional firewalls.
Correct answer is NGFW or next
generation firewall includes deep packet
inspection and advanced threat detection
beyond simple port filtering. Which type
of firewall operates at both layer 4 and
layer 7 of the OSI model for advanced
traffic filtering? Web application
firewall 802.1x
layer 4 layer 7 firewall or extensible
extensible authentication protocol.
This this one should be a gimme. Correct
answer is layer four layer 7 firewall
was the primary function of a virtual
private I'm sorry I didn't give you
enough time on that to see the two
numbers are exactly the same what is the
primary function of a virtual private
network or VPN in secure communications
to encrypt data traffic over public and
private networks for secure remote
access to physically isolate devices
from external threats to authenticate
users without encryption or to eliminate
the need for firewalls in enterprise
environments ments. What is the primary
function of a virtual private network or
VPN in secure communications?
Correct answer is to encrypt data
traffic over public and private networks
for secure remote access.
Which security mechanism allows users to
securely connect to a private network
from an external location?
Softwaredefined WAN or SDWAN? Remote
access internet protocol security or
IPSSE or secure access server edge or
SASSE which security mechanism allows
users to securely connect to a private
network from an external location.
Correct answer is remote access.
What is the primary purpose of tunneling
in network security? To block all
traffic from external networks, to
disable encryption for faster
communication, to allow direct access to
internal resources without
authentication, or to encapsulate data
for secure transmission over untrusted
networks with the primary purpose of
tunneling in network security.
Correct answer is to encapsulate data
for secure transmission over untrusted
networks. And I actually should have
given you guys another couple seconds to
figure out the layer four, layer 7, cuz
you never know. Some of these some of
these questions, they could throw some
curveballs at you where it's like it
looks like it's the obvious answer, but
it really winds up not being the obvious
one. So, I I apologize for kind of
jumping the gun on there. I shouldn't
have done that. Uh, which protocol is
commonly used to encrypt web traffic and
establish secure communication over the
internet? Transport layer security,
internet protocol security, secure
access server edge, service edge or
softwaredefined WAN. Which protocol is
commonly used to encrypt web traffic and
establish secure communication over the
internet?
Correct answer is transport layer
security. Which security protocol is
used to establish encrypted tunnels for
secure data transmission between
networks? Transport layer security,
internet protocol security, virtual
private network or softwaredefined WAN
or SDWAN?
Which security protocol is used to
establish encrypted tunnels for secure
data transmission between networks?
Correct answer is internet protocol
security. How does softwaredefined wide
area network or SDWAN improve network
security? By encrypting all endpoint
communications automatically by
replacing all traditional security
applications with a single firewall? By
dynamically routing traffic over
multiple secure connections and
enforcing security policies or by
physically isolating devices from
network threats. How does
softwaredefined wide area network or
SDWAN improve network security?
Correct answer is by dynamically routing
traffic over multiple secure connections
and enforcing security policies.
What is a key security benefit of secure
access service edge or SASS? It
integrates cloud delivery uh it
integrates cloud delivered security
services with wide area networking. It
replaces traditional firewalls with
endpoint security software. It
eliminates the need for virtual private
networks or prevents all insider threats
by default. What is a key security
benefit of secure access service edge?
Correct answer is it integrates cloud
delivered security services with wide
area networking. What is the most
important factor when selecting
effective security controls for an
organization? Choosing the most
expensive security tools available.
implementing security measures that do
not require user authentication,
disabling security features to improve
system performance, or ensuring controls
align with business needs and risk
management strategies. What is the most
important factor when selecting
effective security controls for an
organization?
I mean, it's obviously choosing the most
expensive one, right? It is ensuring
controls align with business needs and
risk management strategies. You would
think that if you're in the industry,
they have the opposite uh idea because
they seem to they seem to just pick
whatever is expensive and assume that it
works. Uh which type of data is subject
I mean it's usually a good solution
anyway, but that's uh besides the point.
Which type of data is subject to uh is
subject to government or industry
regulations such as GDPR or HIPPA?
Regulated data, trade secret,
intellectual property, or human readable
data. Which type of data is subject to
government or industry regulations s
such as GDPR or HIPPA?
Correct answer is regulated data. Which
type of data includes proprietary
formulas, process or business strategies
that provide a competitive uh sorry
proprietary formulas, processes or
business strategies that provide a
competitive advantage. Financial
information, trade secret, regulated
data or legal information. proprietary
formulas, processes or business
strategies that provide a competitive
advantage.
Correct answer is trade secret. Which
term refers to legally protected
creations such as patents, trademarks,
and copyrights? Regulated data, trade
secret, intellectual property, or
financial information?
Correct answer is intellectual property.
Which type of data includes contracts,
agreements, and other documents that
have legal significance, trade secret,
intellectual property, non-human
readable data, or legal information?
Correct answer is legal information.
Which of the following best describes
financial information in the context of
security? Any public information found
in open- source intelligence or OSINT?
Only cryptocurrency transactions and
blockchain records. data that includes
banking details, credit card numbers,
and financial statements or data related
to intellectual property such as patents
and copyrights. Which of the following
best describes financial information in
the context of security?
Correct answer is data that includes
banking details, credit card numbers,
and financial statements.
Which of the following is an example of
nonhuman readable data? Encrypted binary
code used for system authentication.
legal contracts written in plain text, a
trade secret document stored as a PDF,
or a company's financial statement in a
spreadsheet. Which of the following is a
example of nonhuman readable data?
Correct answer is encrypted binary code
used for system authentication.
What is the purpose of data
classification in cyber security? To
categorize data based on sensitivity and
required security measures. to
automatically encrypt all data stored on
a network to ensure that all data is
accessible to the public or to remove
outdated data from an organization's
system. What is the purpose of data
classification in cyber security?
The correct answer is to categorize data
based on sensitivity and required
security measures.
Which type of data classification
applies to information that could cause
harm if disclosed but is not highly
sensitive? public, critical, restricted
or sensitive
cause harm if disclosed but is not
highly sensitive.
Correct answer is sensitive data. I know
it seems maybe like it shouldn't have
been that but not highly sensitive. Uh,
which classification label is typically
uh applied to data that should only be
accessed by authorized personnel due to
its importance? Public, restricted,
confidential or private. Data that
should only be accessed by authorized
personnel due to its importance.
Correct answer is confidential.
Which classification applies to data
that is intended for general
distribution and does not require
security controls? Public, sensitive,
confidential or critical?
Correct answer is public. Which type of
data classification is used for
information that requires strict access
control and should not be widely shared?
Public, restricted, confidential or
private?
Strict access control and should not be
widely shared.
Correct answer is restricted.
Which type of data classification
applies to personally identifiable
information such as social security
numbers and medical records? Private,
public, confidential or restricted
personally identifiable information such
as social security numbers and medical
records.
Correct answer is private. Which
classification is assigned to data that
if lost or compromised would have a
severe impact on business operations?
Severe impact, confidential, critical,
public or sensitive.
Severe impact.
Correct answer is critical. Which of the
following is a key consideration when
handling data securely? Ensuring proper
encryption and access controls are
applied based on data sensitivity.
allowing unrestricted access to all data
for ease of use, avoiding data backups
to reduce storage costs, or disabling
authentication requirements for faster
data retrieval is a key consideration
when handling data securely.
Correct answer is ensuring proper
encryption and access controls are
applied based on data sensitivity.
What are three primary states of data in
cyber security? Data at risk, data
encrypted and data processed, data in
motion, data in cloud and data on
premises, data at rest, data in transit
and data in use. Or data backed up, data
stored and data archived. The three
primary states of data in cyber
security.
Correct answer is data at rest, data in
transit, and data in use.
What term best describes data that is
stored on a device such as a hard drive
or database and not actively being
transmitted? Data in transit, data in
use, geoloccation data, or data at rest.
Data stored on a device such as a hard
drive or database and not actively being
transmitted.
Correct answer is data at rest. Which
security measure is most important for
protecting data in transit? Encrypting
data using protocols like TLS or IPSC,
storing data in a secure on premises
database, ensuring physical security of
network infrastructure, or destroying
old storage devices. Which security
measure is most important for protecting
data in transit?
Correct answer is encrypting data using
protocols like TLS or IPSC.
Which of the following best describes
data in use? Data stored in encryption
database for later access. Uh data
transferred securely over a network,
data actively being processed by
applications, memory or CPUs, or data
saved on external media and not
currently accessed, which best describes
data in use.
Correct answer is data actively being
processed by applications, memory or
CPUs.
What does data sovereignty refer to in
cyber security? The concept that data is
subject to the laws and regulations of
the country where it was collected or
stored, the ability to freely transfer
data between global cloud providers, the
encryption standards used to secure all
sensitive data, or the classification of
data based on its security level. What
does data sovereignty sorry what does
data sovereignty refer to in cyber
security?
Correct answer is the concept that data
is subject to the laws and regulations
of the country where it was collected or
stored.
Which security feature allows
organizations to track and enforce
policies based on a devices's physical
location? data sovereignty, data in use
encryption, firewall rules, or
geoloccation.
Which security feature allows
organizations to track and enforce
policies based on a devices's physical
location?
Correct answer is geoloccation.
Which of the following is a common
method to secure data? allowing
unrestricted access to all users, using
encryption access controls and data
masking, storing data in plain text for
easy retrieval, or disabling
authentication for efficiency. Which of
the following is a common method to
secure data?
Correct answer is using encryption,
access controls, and data masking. What
is the purpose of geographic
restrictions in cyber security? To limit
access to data based on physical
location and jurisdiction, to prevent
data from being stored on cloud
services, to allow access to data from
any location without restrictions, or to
encrypt data for secure transmission.
What is the purpose of geographic
restrictions in cyber security?
Correct answer is to limit access to
data based on physical location and
jurisdiction.
Which security measure converts data
into an unreadable format to prevent it
from unauthorized access? Masking,
obfiscation, encryption or segmentation.
Converts data into an unreadable format
to protect it from unauthorized access.
Correct answer is encryption. What is
the purpose of hashing in data security?
to create a unique fixed length
representation of data for integrity
verification to replace sensitive data
with random characters to encrypt data
for secure storage and transmission or
to segment network traffic for security
purposes.
Is the purpose of hashing in data
security?
Correct answer is to create a unique
fixed length representation of data for
integrity ve verification.
Which method is used to hide part of
data uh part of a data value to protect
sensitive information? Hashing,
encryption, masking, or tokenization?
Hide part of a data value to protect
sensitive information?
Correct answer is masking.
Which data protection technique replaces
sensitive information with a
nonsensitive equivalent? Tokenization,
encryption, masking or segmentation.
Replaces sensitive information with a
nonsensitive equivalent.
Correct answer is tokenization.
What is the primary goal of obfiscation
in cyber security? To completely remove
sensitive information from a system, to
make data or code difficult to
understand while maintaining
functionality. to segment network
traffic based on security needs or to
apply geographic restrictions to data
access. The primary goal of of
obfiscation in cyber security.
Correct answer is to make data or code
difficult to understand while
maintaining functionality.
How does segmentation enhance security
in a network? By dividing the network
into isolated sections to limit
unauthorized access. by replacing
sensitive data with non-sensitive
equivalents, by making data difficult to
interpret for unauthorized users, or by
encrypting network traffic during
transmission.
How does segmentation enhance security
in a network?
Correct answer is by dividing the
network into isolated sections to limit
unauthorized access. was the purpose of
permission restrictions in data
security. To encrypt all stored data by
default, to segment network traffic for
improved performance, to allow
unrestricted access to sensitive data
for efficiency, or to enforce access
controls based on user roles and
responsibilities. What is the purpose of
permission restrictions in data
security?
Correct answer is to enforce access
controls based on user roles and
responsibilities.
What is a key difference between load
balancing and clustering in high
availability architecture? Clustering
improves network performance while load
balancing only handles database
operations. Load balancing encrypts all
data in transit whereas clustering does
not. Load balancing distributes traffic
across multiple servers while clustering
ensures failover redundancy or
clustering is used for external network
traffic while load balancing is only for
internal systems. There's a key
difference between load balancing and
clustering in high availability
architecture.
Correct answer is load balancing
distributes traffic across multiple
servers while clustering ensures
failover redundancy.
Which type of disaster recovery site is
fully operational and can take over
immediately in the event of a failure?
Cold site, hot site, warm site, or
geographically dispersed site.
Fully operational and can take over
immediately in the event of a failure.
Correct answer is a hot site. Which
disaster disaster recovery site requires
the most time and effort to become
operational after a failure? Hot site,
warm site, cold site, or geographically
dispersed site?
Correct answer is a cold site. Which
type of disaster recovery site has some
preconfigured infrastructure but
requires additional setup before full
operation? Cold site, hot site,
geographically dispersed site or warm
site.
Correct answer is a warm site. What is
the primary benefit of geographic
dispersion in disaster recovery
planning? It reduces the impact of
localized disasters by distributing
resources across multiple locations. It
eliminates the need for backup and
recovery procedures. It ensures that all
data remains in a single secure location
or prevents all network outages by using
a single failover site. What is the
primary benefit of geographic dispersion
in disaster recovery planning?
Correct answer. It reduces the impact of
localized disasters by distributing
resources across multiple locations.
What is a security benefit of platform
diversity in an organization's IT
environment? It ensures that all devices
run in the same operating system for
easier management. It reduces the risk
of widespread compromise by limiting
resilient uh reliance on a single
system. It eliminates the need for
regular software updates and patches or
it guarantees that no system will ever
be vulnerable to attacks. What is a
security benefit of platform diversity
in an organization's IT environment?
Correct answer is it reduces the risk of
widespread compromise by limiting
reliance on a single system. What is a
primary advantage of using a multicloud
system? It enhances redundancy and
reduces dependency on a single cloud
provider. It eliminates the need for on
premises security controls. It ensures
that all data is automatically encrypted
without additional configuration or
prevents all types of cyber attacks by
default
whereas a primary advantage of
multicloud system.
Correct answer is it enhances redundancy
and reduces dependency on a single cloud
provider.
Which of the following best describes
continuity of operations planning?
Eliminating the need for backup systems
and redundancy, using a single cloud
provider to store all company data,
ensuring critical business functions can
continue during and after a disaster or
disruption, or preventing unauthorized
employees from accessing public
resources.
What best describes continuity of
operations planning?
Correct answer is ensuring critical
business functions can continue during
and after a disaster or disruption.
Why is capacity planning important for
IT security? It ensures that resources
are available to support current and
future security needs. It eliminates the
need for intrusion detection systems. It
guarantees that all security incidents
can be prevented or it allows
organizations to bypass compliance
regulations. Why is capacity planning
important for IT security?
Correct answer is it ensures that
resources are available to support
current and future security needs. How
does capacity planning impact personnel
in an organization? It eliminates the
need for IT security staff by automating
all processes. It focuses only on the
hardware upgrades and does not impact
personnel. It reduces the importance of
user awareness training or it ensures
that the organization has enough trained
staff to manage security operations
effectively. How does capacity planning
impact personnel in an organization?
Correct answer is it ensures the
organization has enough trained staff to
manage security operations effectively.
Which factor should be considered when
planning technology capacity for cyber
security? Eliminating redundant security
controls to cut costs, scalability of
security infrastructure to handle
increasing workloads, limiting access to
security updates to reduce bandwidth
usage, or using older hardware to
maintain legacy compatibility. Which
factor should be considered when
planning technology capacity for cyber
security?
Correct answer is scalability of
security infrastructure to handle
increasing workloads.
Why is infrastructure an important
component of capacity planning? It
prevents the need for cloud computing
and security architecture. It eliminates
the necessity for data encryption. It
ensures that network storage and compute
resources can support security
requirements or it reduces the reliance
on firewalls and intrusion detection
systems. Why is infrastructure an
important component of capacity
planning?
Correct answer is it ensures that
network storage and compute resources
can support security requirements.
What is the primary purpose of a
tabletop exercise in cyber security
testing? To conduct a discussion-based
walkthrough of incident response
procedures, to simulate a live attack on
the organization's network, to
physically test disaster recovery
systems in real time, or to perform a
full failover to backup infrastructure.
The primary purpose of a tabletop
exercise in cyber security testing.
Correct answer is to conduct a
discussion-based walkthrough of incident
response procedures. What does a
failover test evaluate in an IT
environment? the security of data stored
on external devices, the effectiveness
of user authentication policies, the
encryption strength of data in transit,
or the ability of a system to switch to
a backup or redundant system during a
failure. What does a failover test
evaluate in an IT environment?
Correct answer is the ability of a
system to switch to a backup or
redundant system during a failure. What
is the main goal of a cyber security
simulation exercise? To create a
controlled environment for testing
security incident responses, to
completely disable all network security
controls for assessment, to train
employees on general IT usage policies,
or to ensure all systems are permanently
locked down, which is the main goal of a
cyber security simulation exercise.
Correct answer is to create a controlled
environment for testing security
incident responses.
How does parallel processing support
cyber security testing? By replacing
traditional encryption with
multi-threaded computation, by running a
secondary system alongside the primary
one to validate functionality before
full deployment, by shutting down
unnecessary security services for
performance testing, or by removing the
need for redundancy in system
operations.
How does parallel processing support
cyber security testing?
Correct answer is by running a secondary
system alongside the primary one to
validate functionality before full
deployment.
What is a key security benefit of
maintaining both on-site and off-site
backups? It eliminates the need for
encryption in backup storage. It reduces
the importance of access controls for
critical data. It ensures that is
protected but from local disasters while
rec while allowing fast recovery when
needed or it guarantees that all backups
are immune to ransomware attacks. Key
security benefit of maintaining both
on-site and off-site backups.
Correct answer is it ensures data is
protected from local disasters while
allowing fast recovery when needed.
Why is backup frequency an important
consideration in data protection? More
frequent backups reduce potential data
loss in case of a system failure.
Frequent backups eliminate the need for
disaster recovery planning. A single
backup is always sufficient for
long-term data security. Or frequent
backups slow down the system and should
be avoided. Why is backup frequency an
important consideration in data
protection?
Correct answer is more frequent backups
reduce potential data loss in case of a
system failure. Why should backups be
encrypted? To prevent system
administrators from accessing backup
files to improve the speed of the backup
process to protect store data from
unauthorized access or theft or reduce
the to reduce the size of backup files.
Why should backups be encrypted?
Correct answer is to protect stored data
from unauthorized access or theft. What
is a snapshot in the context of data
backups? A point in time copy of a
system or data used for quick recovery,
a long-term archival backup stored
offsite for disaster recovery, a log
file that records all system changes for
compliance tracking, or a real-time
monitoring tool for detecting
unauthorized access. What is a snapshot
in the context of data backups?
Correct answer is a point in time copy
of a system or data used for quick
recovery.
What is the primary goal of a recovery
plan in cyber security? To permanently
shut down affected systems to prevent
further attacks, to restore systems and
data to a functional state after an
incident. to encrypt all data to prevent
unauthorized access or to remove all
backups to ensure no data leakage
occurs. What is the primary goal of a
recovery plan in cyber security?
Correct answer is to restore systems and
data to a functional state after an
incident. Which of the following best
describes data replication in disaster
recovery? The process of copying data to
another system in real time or scheduled
intervals for redundancy. the encryption
of backup data for secure storage, the
complete deletion of old data to prevent
unauthorized access, or a method for
restricting user access to sensitive
files. Which of the following best
describes data replication in disaster
recovery?
Correct answer is the process of copying
data to another system in real time or
scheduled intervals for redundancy.
What is the purpose of journaling in
data security? To restrict access to
specific files using RO based
permissions to create a physical backup
copy of all data at the end of each day
to keep a continuous log of changes to
data for recovery and integrity
verification or to store encryption keys
for secure data access. The purpose of
journaling in data security.
Correct answer is to keep a continuous
log of changes to data for recovery and
integrity verification.
Why is power a critical consideration in
cyber security and disaster recovery
planning? Power fluctuations eliminate
the need for backup systems. Unstable
power sources improve system efficiency.
Power outages have no impact on IT
security controls or power failures can
cause downtime, data loss, and security
vulnerabilities. Why is power a critical
consideration in cyber security and
disaster recovery planning?
Correct answer is power failures can
cause downtime, data loss and security
vulnerabilities.
What is the role of generators in
disaster recovery planning? To encrypt
all system data before a power outage
occurs, to provide backup power in case
of a primary power failure, to
permanently shut down non-essential
systems during business hours, or to
reduce the need for regular power supply
maintenance. Is the role of generators
in disaster recovery planning?
Correct answer is to provide backup
power in case of a primary power
failure. What is the primary function of
an interruptible power supply or UPS in
cyber security? To provide temporary
backup power to critical systems in case
of an outage to permanently replace main
power sources for all network devices.
to eliminate the need for data backups
by securing power supply or to provide
long-term power solutions without
requiring additional resources. The
primary function of an uninterruptible
power supply or UPS in cyber security.
Correct answer is to provide temporary
backup power to critical systems in case
of an outage.
Question one, what is the primary
purpose of establishing a secure
baseline in cyber security? To ensure
that all systems operate without any
security controls, to remove access
restrictions for easier system
management. To define the minimum
required s security settings for all
systems or to disable encryption to
improve system performance. The primary
purpose of establishing a secure
baseline in cyber security.
Correct answer is to define the minimum
required security settings for all
systems. What is an important step when
deploying a secure baseline? Removing
all security updates to speed up
deployment. Allowing unrestricted
administrative access to systems.
Disabling monitoring tools to prevent
false alerts. or ensuring system
settings match security policies before
deployment. An important step when
deploying a secure baseline.
Correct answer is ensuring system
settings match security policies before
deployment.
Why is it important to maintain a secure
baseline over time? to keep systems
protected through regular updates and
patches, to eliminate the need for
security audits and assessments, to
allow systems to operate without
encryption for faster performance, or to
prevent security configurations from
being changed under any circumstances.
Why is it important to maintain a secure
baseline over time?
Correct answer is to keep systems
protected through regular updates and
patches. Which of the following is an
effective method for hardening mobile
devices? Disabling automatic updates to
prevent system changes, allowing
unrestricted installation of thirdparty
apps, using strong authentication and
remote wipe, or disabling encryption to
improve performance. Which of the
following is an effective method for
hardening mobile devices?
Correct answer is using strong
authentication and remote wipe.
What is a key security measure for
hardening workstations? Applying patches
and disabling unneeded services,
allowing unrestricted administrator
access for all users, disabling
firewalls to increase network speed, or
enabling guest accounts for convenience.
What is a key security measure for
hardening workstations?
Correct answer is applying patches and
disabling unneeded services. What is a
recommended practice for securing
network switches, allowing open access
to all VLANs, disable unused ports and
use MAC filtering, configuring all ports
to operate in promiscuous mode, or
disabling logging to improve
performance? What is a recommended
practice for securing network switches?
Correct answer is disabling unused ports
and using MAC filtering. Which of the
following is an essential security
measure for hardening routers? Using
default manufacturer settings for quick
setup, changing default credentials and
disabling unnecessary services,
disabling encryption to improve network
speed, or allowing remote administration
from any IP address. Which of the
following is an essential security
measure for hardening routers?
Correct answer is changing default
credentials and disabling unnecessary
services.
What is an important security
consideration for cloud infrastructure?
implementing strong identity and access
management controls, allowing
unrestricted access to all cloud
services, disabling encryption to reduce
processing overhead, or allowing all
applications to run with administrative
privileges. What is an important
security consideration for cloud
infrastructure?
Correct answer is implementing strong
identity and access management controls.
Which security control is essential for
hardening servers? Enabling all ports
for unrestricted connectivity, using
default administrator credentials for
all accounts, enforcing lease privilege
and disabling unnecessary services, or
disabling logging to improve server
performance.
Which security control is essential for
hardening servers?
Correct answer is enforcing lease
privilege and disabling unnecessary
services.
What is a major security risk associated
with industrial control systems and
SCADA? ICS and SCADA often lack built-in
security making them vulnerable. They're
always isolated from the internet and
cannot be accessed remotely. SCADA
systems automatically update their
security patches or ICS networks do not
require authentication for remote
access. What is a major security risk
associated with industrial control
systems and SCADA?
Correct answer is ICS and SCADA often
lack built-in security making them
vulnerable.
How can embedded systems be hardened
against security threats? By allowing
all devices to communicate without
authentication. By keeping default
settings to simplify maintenance. by
storing encryption keys in unprotected
locations or disable unnecessary
functions and apply firmware updates.
How can embedded systems be hardened
against security threats?
Correct answer is disabling unnecessary
functions and applying firmware updates.
Which of the following is a security
challenge associated with real-time
operating systems? RTOS. RTOS often
prioritizes performance over security,
increasing vulnerability. RTOS systems
are immune to malware due to their
specialized design. RTOS systems
automatically apply security patches in
real time or RTOS does not require
authentication for access control. Which
of the following is a security challenge
associated with real time operating
systems?
Correct answer is RTOS often prioritizes
performance over security increasing
vulnerability.
Which of the following best describes a
major security risk associated with IoT
devices? IoT devices cannot be accessed
remotely making them inherently secure.
IoT devices automatically update
firmware with the latest security
patches. Many IoT devices lacks strong
security and are vulnerable to attacks.
or IoT devices do not require encryption
for secure communication.
Which of the following best describes a
major security risk associated with IoT
devices?
Correct answer is many IoT devices lack
strong security and are vulnerable to
attacks. What is a key security
consideration when configuring wireless
devices? Enabling WPA3 encryption to
protect data in transit. Using open
networks to allow easy access for all
users, disabling mech address filtering
for better compatibility, or keeping
default SSIDs to simplify network
identification.
What is a key security consideration
when configuring wireless devices?
Correct answer is enabling WPA3
encryption to protect data in transit.
Why is it important to consider security
during the installation of network
devices? To allow unrestricted access
for easy troubleshooting, to disable
logging features to improve device
performance, to keep factory default
credentials for faster setup, or to
ensure devices are configured with
encryption and access controls. Why is
it important to consider security during
the installation of networking devices?
Correct answer is ensure devices are
configured with encryption and access
controls. What is the purpose of a
wireless site survey? To block all
unauthorized connections by default to
analyze signal strength interference and
coverage for optimal deployment to
increase the transmission power of
wireless access points beyond legal
limits or to disable all encryption
settings to enhance performance. What is
the purpose of a wireless site survey?
Correct answer is to analyze signal
strength, interference, and coverage for
optimal deployment.
What does a heat map represent in a
wireless network assessment? a visual
representation of wireless signal
strength and coverage areas, a list of
all devices connected to a wireless
network, a graphical display of network
security logs, or a real-time encryption
key tracking system. What is a heat map
represent in a wireless network
assessment?
Correct answer is a visual
representation of wireless signal
strength and coverage areas. What is the
primary function of mobile device
management or MDM in an enterprise
environment? To disable all network
access and Bluetooth configurations on
mobile devices. To prevent employees
from using company-owned devices to
enforce security policies and remotely
manage mobile devices or to
automatically encrypt all mobile device
applications.
What is the primary function of mobile
device management or MDM in an
enterprise environment?
Correct answer is to enforce security
policies and remotely manage mobile
devices.
Which of the following best describes
the bring your own device or BYOD
deployment model? Employees use personal
devices for work under security
policies. Only corporateowned devices
are allowed on the network. Employees
must use company provided devices with
no personal use allowed or organizations
do not allow mobile devices to connect
to their network. Which of the following
best describes the bring your own device
deployment model?
Correct answer is employees use personal
devices for work under security
policies.
How does the corporateowned personally
enabled or cope deployment model differ
from BYOD? Employees bring their own
devices without company management.
Employees have complete control over all
security settings. devices are strictly
limited to corporate use with no
personal functionality or company-owned
devices with limited personal use are
allowed. How does the corporateowned
personally enabled or cope deployment
model differ from BYOD?
Correct answer is company owned devices
with limited personal use allowed. Which
mobile device deployment model allows
employees to select from a list of
company approved devices? Choose your
own device or CYOD, bring your own
device or BYOD, corporate owned,
personally enabled or cope, or mobile
device management or MDM. Which mobile
device deployment model allows employees
to select from a list of company
approved devices?
Correct answer is choose your own device
or C YOD.
Which mobile connection method provides
the most secure and reliable remote
network access? Public Wi-Fi,
unencrypted Bluetooth, cellular, or open
wireless hotspots?
Which mobile connection method provides
the most secure and reliable remote
network access?
Correct answer is cellular.
What is a common security risk when
connecting to public Wi-Fi networks?
Stronger encryption than cellular
networks, man-in-the-middle attacks that
intercept data, guaranteed protection
against unauthorized access, or
automatic enforcement of corporate
security policies. What is a common
security risk when connecting to public
Wi-Fi networks?
Correct answer is man-in-the-middle or
MITM attacks that intercept data. Which
of the following is a security concern
when using Bluetooth connections?
Bluetooth signals are immune to
eavesdropping. Bluetooth connections
automatically use end-to-end encryption.
Devices can be vulnerable to
unauthorized pairing and interception or
Bluetooth devices do not require
authentication for pairing. which the
following is a security concern when
using Bluetooth connections.
Correct answer is devices can be
vulnerable to unauthorized pairing and
interception.
What is a key security improvement in
Wi-Fi protected access 3 or WPA3 over
WPA2? WPA3 uses stronger encryption with
simultaneous authentication of equals.
WPA3 eliminates the need for
authentication in wireless networks.
WPA3 increases network speed by
disabling encryption. Or WPA3 only works
on wired networks and does not support
wireless encryption.
Was a key security improvement in Wi-Fi
protected access 3 over WPA2.
Correct answer is WPA3 uses stronger
encryption with simultaneous
simultaneous authentication of equals.
What is the primary function of AAA
authentication, authorization, and
accounting in remote access security? To
force users to sign in using either
authentication, authorization or an
accounting method. To disable encryption
for faster authentication to allow
anonymous users to authenticate without
credentials or to enforce identity uh
identity verification, permissions and
activity tracking. What is the primary
function of AAA authentication,
authorization and accounting in remote
access security?
Correct answer is to enforce identity
verification, permissions and activity
tracking.
Which of the following best describes
the role of the Radius protocol?
Provides centralized authentication and
authorization for remote users. It
encrypts all network traffic
automatically using wafer encryption
technology. It is used for securing web
applications against attacks or prevents
wireless devices from connecting to
networks. Which of the following best
describes the role of the radius
protocol?
Correct answer is it provides
centralized authentication and
authorization for remote users.
Which cryptographic protocol is commonly
used to secure web communications?
Secure file transfer protocol or SFTP,
simple network management protocol or
SNMP, transport layer security or TLS or
internet protocol security or IPSC?
Which cryptographic protocol is commonly
used to secure web communications?
Correct answer is transport layer
security.
Which of the following is a widely used
authentication protocol for network
access control? File transfer protocol
or FTP, dynamic host configuration
protocol or DHCP, hypertext transfer
protocol secure or HTTPS
or extensible authentication protocol or
EAP. Which of the following is a widely
used authentication protocol for network
access control?
Correct answer is extensible
authentication protocol or EAP.
Why is input validation important for
application security? It disables
encryption to speed up data processing.
It prevents injection attacks by
validating input data. It allows users
to execute arbitrary code on the server
or it ensures that all data is stored in
plain text for better performance. Why
is input validation important for
application security?
Correct answer is it prevents injection
attacks by validating input data. What
is the purpose of secure cookies in web
application security? prevent
unauthorized access with encrypted
cookies and proper attributes to store
passwords in plain text for quick
authentication to allow users to modify
session data freely or to enable
cross-sight scripting or XSS attacks for
better user experience. What is the
purpose of secure cookies in web
application security?
Correct answer is to prevent
unauthorized access with encrypted
cookies and proper attributes.
How does static code analysis improve
application security? By testing
applications in a live production
environment without restrictions, by
allowing developers to bypass security
policies for testing purposes, by
identifying vulnerabilities in source
code before execution, or by modifying
application logic dynamically at
runtime. How does static code analysis
improve application security?
Correct answer is by identifying
vulnerabilities in source code before
execution.
What is the main purpose of code signing
in in software security? to verify
software authentic authenticity and
integrity with digital signatures to
encrypt source code before execution to
allow any user to modify the application
code or to remove security controls from
the software to improve performance.
What is the main purpose of code signing
in software security?
Correct answer is to verify software
authent authenticity and integrity with
digital signatures. What is the primary
function of sandboxing in cyber
security? To allow unrestricted access
to system resources for testing
purposes. To execute untrusted code
directly on production servers. to
isolate untrusted applications in a
controlled environment to prevent
threats or to disable all security
features in an application for
debugging. Whereas the primary function
of sandboxing in cyber security.
Correct answer is to isolate untrusted
applications in a controlled environment
to prevent threats.
Why is continuous monitoring important
in cyber security? It eliminates the
need for firewalls and intrusion
detection systems. It allows all users
to access system logs without
restrictions.
It ensures that security vulnerabilities
are only addressed after an attack
occurs or it helps detect and respond to
security threats in real time. Why is
continuous monitoring important in cyber
security?
Correct answer is it helps detect and
respond to security threats in real
time.
What is a key security consideration in
the acquisition and procurement process?
Purchasing the cheapest solution without
assessing security impact. Evaluating
vendors for security compliance and
potential risks. Avoiding software
updates to prevent system changes or
granting full administrative privileges
to all new software installations.
What is a key security consideration at
the acquisition and procurement process?
Correct answer is evaluating vendors for
security compliance and potential risks.
Why is asset ownership important in
cyber security? It assigns
responsibility to the protection of for
the protection and management of an
asset. It ensures that all employees
have unrestricted access to critical
data. It allows assets to be shared
freely without tracking usage or it
eliminates the need for access control
policies. Why is asset ownership
important in cyber security?
Correct answer is it assigns
responsibility for the protection and
management of an asset. What is the
purpose of data classification in an
organization? To delete all outdated
data regardless of content to prevent
security monitoring tools from analyzing
data. to categorize data based on
sensitivity and access requirements or
to ensure that all data is stored in
plain text for easy access. What is the
purpose of data classification in
organization?
Correct answer is to categorize data
based on sensitivity and access
requirements.
Why is asset inventory management
important in cyber security? It helps
track and manage IT resources to
identify unauthorized devices. It allows
unrestricted connection of personal
devices to the corporate network. It
ensures that all software licenses
remain unused or it eliminates the need
for security controls on older assets.
Why is asset inventory management
important in cyber security?
Correct answer is it helps track and
manage IT resources to identify
unauthorized devices. What is the
primary function of asset enumeration in
cyber security? To delete all inactive
network devices automatically to
identify and catalog devices, services
and configurations on a network. To
encrypt all network traffic without user
intervention or to prevent IT teams from
tracking hardware usage is the primary
function of asset enumeration in cyber
security.
Correct answer is to identify and
catalog devices, services and
configurations on a network. What is the
purpose of sanitation in the disposal
and decommissioning process? To allow
unrestricted access to all data on a
device to convert data into a format
that can be easily accessed by
unauthorized users. To ensure that all
sensitive data is removed from a device
before disposal or reuse or to keep data
stored on an obsolete hardware for
future use is the purpose of sanitation
in the disposal and decommissioning
process.
Correct answer is to ensure that all
sensitive data is removed from a device
before disposal or reuse. Which method
ensures that a storage device is
permanently destroyed and cannot be
recovered? physical destruction like
shredding or crushing, encrypting the
device to prevent unauthorized access,
reformatting the device to erase data,
or storing the device in a secure
facility indefinitely. Which method
ensures that a storage device is
permanently destroyed and cannot be
recovered?
Correct answer is physical destruction
like shredding or crushing. What is the
purpose of certification in the context
of data disposal? To verify that data
was properly sanitized or destroyed per
security standards to ensure that device
is returned to its original manufacturer
for resale. To guarantee that the data
is accessible for future audits or to
provide a backup of the data for
recovery purposes. What is the purpose
of certification in the context of data
disposal?
Correct answer is to verify that the
data was properly sanitized or destroyed
per security standards.
Why is data retention an important
consideration in the disposal process?
It allows data to be stored indefinitely
for future use. It enables unrestricted
access to all data regardless of its
age. It speeds up the disposal process
by ignoring legal legal requirements or
it ensures data is kept for required
compliance periods before secure
disposal. Why is data retention an
important consideration in the disposal
process?
Correct answer is ensure data is kept
for required compliance periods before
secure disposal. What is the primary
function of a vulnerability scan in
cyber security? To monitor network
traffic for potential data exfiltration
to ident identify and access uh and to
identify and assess potential weaknesses
in a system or network. To verify that
encryption standards are being met or to
block all incoming traffic from
untrusted sources. What is the primary
function of a vulnerability scan in
cyber security?
Correct answer is to identify and assess
potential weaknesses in a system or
network.
What is the primary goal of static
analysis in application security? To
test the application in a live
environment to identify vulnerabilities
during runtime to monitor network
traffic generated by the application for
malicious behavior. to analyze the
application source code without
execution to identify vulnerabilities or
to analyze the application's performance
under heavy load conditions. What is the
primary goal of static analysis in
application security?
Correct answer is to analyze the
application source code without
execution to identify vulnerabilities.
How does dynamic analysis help improve
application security? By analyzing the
application during execution to detect
real-time vulnerabilities, by verifying
that the application's code is compliant
with industry standards, by creating a
backup of the application's source code
for disaster recovery, or by encrypting
the application's data to ensure
privacy. How does dynamic analysis help
improve application security?
Correct answer is by analyzing the
application during execution to detect
real-time vulnerabilities.
What is the purpose of package
monitoring in application security? to
monitor user login activity for
potential brute force attacks, to
control access to specific network
services based on security policies, to
test the application's response to
simulated security breaches, or to track
and analyze thirdparty dependencies for
vulnerabilities. What is the purpose of
package monitoring in application
security?
Correct answer is to track and analyze
thirdparty dependencies for
vulnerabilities.
What is a threat feed in cyber security?
A list of security policies and
guidelines for employees, the stream of
updates on current and emerging cyber
security threats, a network device that
blocks potential threats in real time,
or a tool used to encrypt and protect
sensitive data during transmission.
Whereas a threat feed in cyber security.
Correct answer is a stream of updates on
current and emerging cyber security
threats.
What does an open-source intelligence or
OSINT involve in cyber security?
Collecting public info from open sources
to identify potential threats?
Encrypting public data to ensure privacy
in the open web. Monitoring only
proprietary sources of information or
threats or blocking all open source
platforms from being accessed by
attackers.
What does open- source intelligence or
OSINT involve in cyber security?
Correct answer is collecting public info
from open sources to identify potential
threats.
What is the primary concern when using
proprietary versus thirdparty software
in a security environment? Third party
software is always more secure than
proprietary software. Proprietary
software requires fewer security patches
than third party software. Proprietary
offers more control. third party may
introduce external risks or thirdparty
software does not need to undergo
security assessments. What is the
primary concern when using proprietary
versus thirdparty software in a security
environment?
Correct answer is proprietary offers
more control. Third party may introduce
external risks.
What is the purpose of an information
sharing organization in cyber security?
To enable organizations to share threat
intel and security best practices to
store sensitive data for organizations
without encryption. To prevent
organizations from sharing any security
related information or to distribute
malware and exploit vulnerabilities in
organizations.
What is the purpose of an information
sharing organization in cyber security?
Correct answer is to enable
organizations to share threat intel and
security best practices. What is a
common risk associated when accessing
information on the dark web? Guaranteed
protection from all types of cyber
attacks. Exposure to illegal content,
cyber crime and harmful software.
Complete anonymity for the organization
accessing the dark web or immediate
access to fully encrypted safe
information. or is a common risk
associated when accessing information on
the dark web?
Correct answer is exposure to illegal
content, cyber crime, and harmful
software. What is the primary goal of
penetration testing or pentesting in
cyber security? To identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in a
system by simulating attacks, to
completely shut down a network for
maintenance purposes. to encrypt all
data on a system to prevent access or to
allow unlimited access to an
organization's internal systems. What is
the primary goal of penetration testing
in cyber security?
Correct answer is to identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in a
system by simulating attacks. What is
the purpose of a responsible disclosure
program in cyber security? to encourage
hackers to exploit vulnerabilities for
personal gain, to prevent any
third-party reports from being
considered by organizations, to let
researchers report vulnerabilities
ethically and in a controlled way, or to
eliminate the need for vulnerability
scanning and monitoring. What is the
purpose of a responsible disclosure
program in cyber security?
Correct answer is to let researchers
report vulnerabilities ethically and in
a controlled way. What is a bug bounty
program? A program where organizations
reward reports for security
vulnerabilities. A service that
automatically patches vulnerabilities
without user input. A certification for
companies with the best cyber security
practices or a mechanism for rewarding
employees for non-cyberc tasks. What is
a bug bounty program?
Correct answer is a program where
organizations reward reports of security
vulnerabilities.
What is the goal of a system or process
audit in cyber security? To increase
system performance by disabling security
measures. To monitor employee
productivity and access to nonsensitive
systems. to remove all outdated security
logs from the system or to evaluate
security controls, find vulnerabilities
and ensure compliance.
What is the goal of a system or process
audit in cyber security?
Correct answer is to evaluate security
controls, find vulnerabilities and
ensure compliance.
What is the purpose of analysis in
vulnerability management? To assess and
understand the severity, impact, and
risk of identified vulnerabilities. To
identify vulnerabilities in a system
without considering their potential
impact. To remove all vulnerabilities
immediately regardless of priority. Or
to ignore low-risk vulnerabilities and
focus only on high-risk ones. What is
the purpose of analysis in vulnerability
management?
Correct answer is to assess and
understand the severity, impact, and
risk of identified vulnerabilities.
What does confirmation mean in the
context of vulnerability management?
Ignoring vulnerabilities until they're
reported by an external source.
Automatically patching vulnerabilities
without verifying their existence.
Verifying the existence of a
vulnerability and determining its true
impact or declaring all detected
vulnerabilities as false positives.
What does confirmation mean in the
context of vulnerability management?
Correct answer is verifying the
existence of a vulnerability and
determining its true impact.
What is a false positive in
vulnerability scanning? When a
vulnerability is identified correctly
but is ignored. When a vulnerability is
incorrectly identified as present when
it is not. When a system is reported as
secure but it's actually vulnerable. Or
when a vulnerability is correctly
identified but is not fixed in time.
What is a false positive in
vulnerability scanning?
Correct answer is when a vulnerability
is incorrectly identified as present
when it is not.
What does a false negative refer to in
vulnerability scanning? When a
vulnerability is missed or incorrectly
marked as not present? When a
vulnerability is falsely detected as
being present. When a scan detects the
wrong vulnerability on a system or when
a system is incorrectly marked as fully
secure was a false negative referred to
in vulnerability scanning.
Correct answer is when a vulnerability
is missed or incorrectly marked as not
present. What is the purpose of
prioritizing vulnerabilities in a
security environment? To address every
vulnerability equally regardless of
severity. To focus on critical
vulnerabilities first based on potential
impact. To ignore low severity
vulnerabilities until higher severity
vulnerabilities are addressed or to
patch only the vulnerabilities that are
identified by the security team.
What is the purpose of prioritizing
vulnerabilities in a security
environment?
Correct answer is to focus on critical
vulnerabilities first based on potential
impact.
What does the common vulnerability
scoring system provide? CVS,
a list of all known vulnerabilities with
corresponding fixes, a list of industry
best practices for vulnerability
management, a tool for scanning systems
for vulnerabilities in real time, or a
standardized method for rating the
severity of vulnerabilities.
What is the common vulnerability scoring
system provide?
Correct answer is a standardized method
for rating the severity of
vulnerabilities.
What is the common vulnerability
enumeration or CVE?
A database assigning unique IDs to known
cyber security vulnerabilities.
A list of organizations offering
vulnerability scanning services.
A method for tracking unpatched
vulnerabilities across all systems or
tool for scanning systems for
vulnerabilities in real time. What is
the common vulnerability enumeration or
CVE?
Correct answer is a database assigning
unique IDs to known cyber security
vulnerabilities.
What is vulnerability classification?
A method for patching vulnerabilities in
real time. The process of ignoring
vulnerabilities that do not have
immediate solutions. a way of sorting
vulnerabilities by their appearance in
reports or categorizing vulnerabilities
by type, severity, and impact. What is
vulnerability classification?
Correct answer is categorizing
vulnerabilities by type, severity, and
impact.
What does the exposure factor measure in
risk management? the number of potential
threats to an asset, the likelihood of a
vulnerability being exploited,
percentage of asset loss from a specific
threat, or the severity of an attack on
a system or network. What is the
exposure factor measure in risk
management?
Correct answer is percentage of asset
loss from a specific threat.
What are environmental variables in the
context of vulner vulnerability
management? Physical factors like
environment, climate, and location
affecting risk, the number of users
accessing a system and their level of
access.
These specific security policies applied
to a network or the amount of traffic in
the network and its impact on system
performance.
What are environmental variables in the
context of vulnerability management?
Correct answer is physical factors like
environment, climate and location
affecting risk.
What does industry or organizational
impact refer to in risk management? The
number of vulnerabilities detected
within an organization,
the cost of replacing vulnerable systems
or devices,
the time it takes to patch a
vulnerability in the system, or
potential consequences a vulnerability
may have on the business or industry.
What does industry or organizational
impact refer to in risk management?
Correct answer is the potential
consequences. a vulnerability may have
on the business or industry.
What is meant by risk tolerance in cyber
security? Level of risk an organization
is willing to accept to meet goals. The
time it takes for an organization to
recover from a cyber attack. The cost of
mitigating vulnerabilities across the
entire organization or the likelihood
that a vulnerability will be detected in
a timely manner. What is meant by risk
tolerance in cyber security?
Correct answer is the level of risk an
organization is willing to accept to
meet goals.
What is the primary goal of
vulnerability response and remediation?
To delay remediation actions until
security experts can conduct further
analysis to ignore vulnerabilities that
do not have an immediate impact on the
system. To identify, prioritize, and fix
vulnerabilities to reduce risk exposure.
or to document vulnerabilities without
taking any corrective action. What is
the primary goal of vulnerability
response and remediation?
Correct answer is to identify,
prioritize and fix vulnerabilities to
reduce risk exposure.
What is the purpose of patching in
vulnerability management? To apply
updates and fixes to address known
software or hardware vulnerabilities.
to monitor all system and network
activity for potential vulnerabilities
to permanently disable security controls
and access management for better
performance or to incorporate quality of
life improvements to streamline workflow
optimization for users.
What is the purpose of patching in
vulnerability management?
Correct answer is to apply updates and
fixes to address known software or
hardware vulnerabilities.
How does insurance relate to
vulnerability management? It eliminates
the need for other security measures
such as patching and network
segmentation. It helps reduce financial
loss from attacks but doesn't replace
risk management. It ensures that all
security systems are automatically
updated and patched or is used to secure
only physical assets not digital
systems. How does insurance relate to
vulnerability management?
Correct answer is it helps reduce
financial loss from attacks but doesn't
replace risk management.
What is the purpose of network
segmentation in cyber security? To
create a single flat network that is
easier to manage and maintain. to allow
unrestricted access between all network
devices for faster communication between
them to divide a network into smaller
segments to reduce the impact of a
potential breach or to prevent all
external devices from connecting to the
network. What is the purpose of network
segmentation in cyber security?
Correct answer is to divide a network
into smaller segments to reduce the
impact of a potential breach.
What are compensating controls in
security?
Alternative security measures
implemented when the primary control
cannot be applied.
Controls that are automatically
implemented by security software without
configuration.
Controls that eliminate the need for
other security measures altogether or
controls that are only applicable to
external systems and networks. What are
compensating controls in security?
Correct answer is alternative security
measures implemented when the primary
control cannot be applied.
What is the difference between
exceptions and exemptions in
vulnerability management? Exemptions
allow temporary deviations from security
policies while exceptions remove
policies entirely. Exceptions are
applied to minor vulnerabilities while
exemptions are applied to major
vulnerabilities. There is no difference.
the terms are interchangeable
or exceptions allow temporary deviations
from security policies while exemptions
remove policies entirely. What is the
difference between exceptions and
exemptions in vulnerability management?
Correct answer is exceptions allow
temporary deviations from security
policies while exemptions remove
policies entirely.
What is the purpose of validating
remediation efforts in cyber security?
To ensure the fix addresses the
vulnerability without adding new risks
to record the number of vulnerabilities
that have been patched to assess the
financial cost of applying patches and
security measures or to eliminate the
need for further security testing after
patching. was the purpose of validating
remediation efforts in cyber security.
Correct answer is to ensure that the fix
addresses the vulnerability without
adding new risks.
What does rescanning involve in
vulnerability management? Scanning only
a specific portion of the network for
vulnerabilities. Scanning a system
before patching to identify potential
vulnerabilities.
Scanning after immediation to confirm
issues are resolved or scanning external
networks for unauthorized access. What
does rescanning involve in vulnerability
management?
Correct answer is scanning after
immediation to confirm issues are
resolved.
Why is an audit important in
vulnerability management? to make sure
that all network devices are
disconnected during security checks, to
verify the effectiveness of security
controls, compliance, and remediation
actions, to ensure that no security
measures are applied and operations run
more efficiently, or to prevent users
from accessing the system until audit
processes are complete. Why is an audit
important in vulnerability management?
Correct answer is to verify the
effectiveness of security controls,
compliance and remediation actions.
What is the purpose of verification in
vulnerability management? To confirm
vulnerabilities are remediated and
security measures work. To check whether
the vulnerability scanning tools are
working correctly. to verify the
financial cost of remediation efforts or
to make sure all users are informed
about security updates. What is the
purpose of verification in vulnerability
management?
Correct answer is to confirm
vulnerabilities are reme are remediated
and security measures work.
What is the primary purpose of reporting
in vulnerability management? To track
the number of system outages caused by
vulnerabilities,
to ensure that all users are informed
about their personal vulnerabilities,
to prevent external vendors from
accessing sensitive data, or to
communicate vulnerability status,
remediation, and impact to stakeholders.
Where is the primary purpose of
reporting in vulnerability management?
Correct answer is to communicate
vulnerability status, remediation and
impact to stakeholders.
What is the main purpose of monitoring
computing resources in an organization?
To track and manage system health,
performance and security to ensure that
no systems are being used for
unauthorized activities to reduce
network traffic by limiting data storage
or to monitor the power consumption of
devices in the organization.
What is the main purpose of monitoring
computing resources in an organization?
Correct answer is to track and manage
system health, performance, and
security. What is the goal of monitoring
applications in a network? to ensure
that all applications are running in
offline mode for better security. To
detect vulnerabilities, errors and
performance issues within the
application, to prevent users from
accessing any installed applications, or
to configure all applications to
automatically disable logging. What is
the goal of monitoring applications in a
network?
Correct answer is to detect
vulnerabilities, errors and performance
issues within the application.
Why is monitoring infrastructure
important in cyber security? To ensure
that the network and devices are
functioning securely to remove all
unnecessary infrastructure to improve
speed to eliminate any redundant network
devices and increase connectivity or to
ensure no infrastructure is connected to
external networks. Why is monitoring
infrastructure important in cyber
security?
Correct answer is to ensure that the
network and devices are functioning
securely.
What is log aggregation in the context
of monitoring activities? The automatic
deletion of outdated logs to improve
storage capacity. The process of
monitoring user activity across all
systems. The process of collecting
system logs into a central repository
for analysis or the isolation of logs
from critical systems to prevent
unauthorized access.
What is log aggregation in the context
of monitoring activities?
Correct answer is the process of
collecting system logs into a central
repository for analysis.
What is the purpose of alerting in
security monitoring? To notify admins of
potential security effects, events
needing attention. To silence all
notifications to avoid unnecessary
disturbances,
to automatically apply security patches
without user consent or to display
irrelevant information to confuse
attackers.
What is the purpose of alerting in
security monitoring?
Correct answer is to notify admins of
potential security events needing
attention.
Why is scanning important in
vulnerability management? To scan
external networks for unauthorized
access to limit network traffic by
blocking unnecessary devices. To
identify system and application
vulnerabilities needing remediation or
to ensure all systems are running on the
latest version of the operating system.
Why is scanning important in
vulnerability management?
Correct answer is to identify system and
application vulnerabilities needing
remediation.
What is the main purpose of reporting in
security monitoring? To monitor user
productivity and application usage in
real time to encrypt all network traffic
and ensure that data cannot be accessed.
to automatically generate security
patches for identified issues or to
provide detailed analysis of incidents,
vulnerabilities and performance to
stakeholders. What is the main purpose
of reporting in security monitoring?
Correct answer is to provide detailed
analysis of incidents, vulnerabilities
and performance to stakeholders.
Why is archiving logs important in
security operations? To store historical
data for compliance, audits, and future
analysis. To remove all logs older than
one week to save space. To prevent
access to logs for non-administrative
users or to ensure logs are deleted
automatically after a specific time
period. Why is archiving logs important
in security operations?
Correct answer is to store historical
data for compliance audits and future
analysis.
What is the primary purpose of
quarantine in alert response and
remediation? To permanently delete files
that are flagged as suspicious to
isolate potentially malicious files or
devices to prevent further damage to
automatically patch vulnerabilities
without user intervention or to encrypt
files and make them unreadable to
attackers. What is the primary purpose
of quarantine in alert response and
remediation?
Correct answer is to isolate potentially
malicious files or devices to prevent
further damage.
What is alert tuning in the context of
security operations? The use of alert
thresholds to reduce false positives and
highlight relevant alerts. The act of
rerouting all security alerts to network
centers to minimize minor threats and
forward major threats to audit logs. The
automatic categorization of all alerts
as high priority threats or the use of
encryption to secure all alerts before
transmission. What is alert tuning in
the context of security operations?
The correct answer is the use of alert
thresholds to reduce false positives and
highlight relevant alerts.
What is the purpose of the security
content automation protocol or SCAP?
To monitor network traffic for
unauthorized access attempts to manually
configure security controls on devices
to standardize security info format and
automate compliance management or to
provide automatic detection of
vulnerabilities in external networks.
What is the purpose of the security
content automation protocol or SCAP?
Correct answer is to standardize
security in info format and automate
compliance management.
How do security benchmarks help improve
an organization security posture? They
offer best practices for securing
systems and networks. They are used to
ignore all security vulnerabilities in a
system. They automatically patch
vulnerabilities and deploy fixes or they
measure the financial costs associated
with security incidents. How do security
benchmarks help improve an organization
security posture?
Correct answer is they offer best
practices for securing systems and
networks. What is the difference between
agent-based and agentless security
monitoring? Agentless monitoring is more
secure than agent-based monitoring.
Agent-based monitoring is always less
effective than agentless monitoring.
Agent-based monitoring is only used for
external networks while agentless is
used internally. Or agentbased needs
software on the system. Agent list does
not. What is the difference between
agent-based and agentless security
monitoring?
Correct answer is agent-based need
software on the systems. Agentless does
not. What is the role of security
information and event management or SIM
systems to monitor the physical security
of facilities and control access to
sensitive areas to collect correlate and
analyze security data to identify
threats to automatically encrypt all
data in real time to ensure
confidentiality or to block all incoming
network traffic from untrusted sources.
was the role of security information and
event management or SIM systems.
Correct answer is to collect, correlate
and analyze security data to identify
threats. What is the main function of a
security information and event
management or SIM system? To encrypt all
network traffic to ensure secure
communications, to limit access to
sensitive data by restricting user login
attempts, to collect and analyze event
data to detect and respond to threats,
or to block all incoming network traffic
from untrusted sources. What is the main
function of a security information and
event management or SIM system?
Correct answer is to collect and analyze
event data to detect and respond to
threats. What is the primary role of
antivirus software in cyber security? to
detect, block and remove malware like
viruses, worms, and Trojans. To encrypt
sensitive files in the system to prevent
unauthorized access to monitor network
traffic for suspicious activity, or to
manage access control lists or ACL on
firewalls.
Where's the primary role of antivirus
software in cyber security?
Correct answer is to detect, block and
remove malware like viruses, worms and
Trojans.
How does data loss prevention or DLP
help protect sensitive data? By
restricting sensitive data movement
inside and outside the network, by
providing automatic backups of all
system files, by encrypting all data in
transit between devices, or by blocking
access to non-essential systems during
business hours. How does data loss
prevention or DLP help protect sensitive
data?
Correct answer is by restricting
sensitive data movement inside and
outside the network.
What is the purpose of simple network
management protocol or SNMP traps? to
encrypt SNMP communication for secure
management of devices to detect and
prevent unauthorized access to network
devices to block all non-essential
network traffic in real time or to send
alerts to management systems about
network device events or issues. What is
the purpose of simple network management
protocol or SNMP traps?
Correct answer is to send alerts to
management systems about network device
events or issues. What is net flow used
for in network security? To monitor and
analyze traffic to detect unusual
patterns or threats to encrypt network
traffic to prevent unauthorized
interception. To manage and prioritize
network bandwidth for better performance
or to block all traffic that originates
from unknown IP addresses. What is net
flow used for in network security?
Correct answer is to monitor and analyze
traffic to detect unusual patterns or
threats. What is the main purpose of
vulnerability scanners in cyber
security? To encrypt files to protect
against unauthorized access to identify
and assess vulnerabilities so they can
be remediated. to automatically patch
all identified vulnerabilities in real
time or to restrict network access based
on user authentication levels. What is
the main purpose of vulnerability
scanners in cyber security?
Correct answer is to identify and assess
vulnerabilities so that they can be
remediated.
What is the purpose of firewall rules in
network security? to eliminate all
external traffic to prevent network
access, to automatically assign IP
addresses to connected devices, to
define allowed network traffic based on
specific conditions, or to encrypt all
traffic passing through the firewall.
What is the purpose of firewall rules in
network security?
Correct answer is to define allowed
network traffic based on specific
conditions. What is the role of access
control lists or ACL's in firewall
configuration? To define rules or allow
to allow or deny traffic by IPs, subnets
and protocols to automatically update
firewall rules every time a security
breach occurs. to detect unauthorized
access attempts and block them or to
encrypt all incoming and outgoing data
packets. What is the role of access
control lists or ACL's in firewall
configuration?
Correct answer is to define rules to
allow or deny traffic by IPs, subnets
and protocols.
How are ports and protocols used in
firewall configuration? To determine the
encryption standards applied to network
communications, to control traffic based
on port numbers and communication
protocols, to restrict physical access
to network hardware, or to allow all
network traffic by default without any
filtering. How are ports and protocols
used in firewall configuration?
Correct answer is to control traffic
based on port numbers and communication
protocols. What is the purpose of a
screen subnet in network security? To
isolate internal networks from the
internet using an intermediate firewall.
To connect internal networks directly to
external networks without any filtering
to allow unrestricted access to all
devices on the network or to block all
incoming traffic from trusted external
sources. What is the purpose of a screen
subnet in network security?
Correct answer is to isolate internal
networks from the internet using an
intermediate firewall.
What is a trend in intrusion detection
systems or IDS and intrusion prevention
systems or IPS? The shift away from
automated responses to manual review of
all security incidents. The increasing
use of machine learning and AI to detect
and respond to network threats. the move
to allow all types of network traffic
without inspection or the removal of
signaturebased detection methods in
favor of heristic analysis. What is a
trend in intrusion detection systems and
intrusion prevention systems?
Correct answer is the increasing use of
machine learning and AI to detect and
respond to network threats. What is the
role of signatures in IDS or IPS
systems? To automatically patch
vulnerabilities as soon as they're
detected to encrypt all incoming network
traffic for confidentiality
to match known attack patterns to detect
malicious traffic or to prevent access
to un to all unauthorized devices on the
network. What is the role of signatures
in IDS and IPS systems?
Correct answer is to match known attack
patterns to detect malicious traffic.
What is the primary function of
agent-based web filtering? To install
agents on devices to monitor and
restrict web traffic locally to filter
web traffic based on centralized
policies applied across the network to
block all inbound traffic from external
sources or to analyze only encrypted web
traffic for potential threats. What is
the primary function of agent-based web
filtering?
Correct answer is to install agents on
devices to monitor and restrict web
traffic locally. What is the role of a
centralized proxy in web filtering? To
store encrypted content locally for
faster access to block all internal
traffic network traffic for security
reasons. to reduce the need for
firewalls by intercepting all network
traffic or to act as an intermediary to
enforce security policies between users
and web services. What is the role of a
centralized proxy in web filtering?
Correct answer is to act as an
intermediary to enforce security
policies between users and web services.
What is the purpose of URL scanning in
web filtering? to monitor and record all
visited websites for future reference,
to encrypt URLs to prevent exposure of
web browsing activity, to examine URLs
for malicious content, fishing or
inappropriate material before access, or
to block URLs that are part of an
organization's internet. What is the
purpose of URL scanning in web
filtering?
Correct answer is to examine URLs for
malicious content, fishing or
inappropriate material before access.
How does content categorization enhance
web filtering? By classifying web
content into categories to apply
specific access rules. By analyzing the
size of content to determine if it
should be accessed or blocked. By
applying a universal rule that blocks
all external content regardless of
category. or by limiting web access to
internal company resources only. How
does content categorization enhance web
filtering?
Correct answer is by classifying web
content into categories to apply
specific access rules.
What are block rules in web filtering?
Rules that enable unrestricted access to
all websites and web content. Rules that
can automatically update filtering
policies without user intervention.
Rules that only monitor and log web
traffic without taking any action or
rules that prevent access to specific
sites, content or categories per
security policies.
What are block rules in web filtering?
Correct answer is rules that prevent
access to specific sites, content, or
categories per security policies.
How does reputation-based web filtering
work? It scans websites for content that
meets a predefined reputation score. It
blocks websites only from specific
geographic locations based on
reputation. It evaluates website
reputation using history, feedback, and
security issues. or it grants access to
websites with a history of high traffic
and low security concerns. How does
reputation-based web filtering work?
Correct answer is it evaluates website
reputation using history feedback and
security issues. What is the primary
function of operating system security?
to protect the operating system from
unauthorized access and attacks, to
monitor the hardware performance of the
system, to manage network traffic and
optimize speed, or to ensure that the
operating system always runs at full
capacity. What is the primary function
of operating system security?
Correct answer is to protect the
operating system from unauthorized
access and attacks. How does group
policy contribute to the operating
system security? By allowing users to
run certain groups of software types
without restrictions. By enforcing
security settings and configurations
across network systems, by disabling all
network communications between systems
or by preventing unauthorized access to
physical hardware only. How does group
policy contribute to operating system
security?
Correct answer is by enforcing security
settings and configurations across
network systems. What does SE Linux
provide in terms of operating system
security? Encryption tool that protects
system data in transit and at rest. A
firewall that filters incoming network
traffic based on predefined rules. a
mandatory access control system that
restricts process and user interactions
with resources or an antivirus feature
to detect and remove malware. What does
SE Linux provide in terms of operating
system security?
Correct answer is a mandatory access
control system that restricts process
and user interactions with resources.
Why is the implementation of secure
protocols essential in network security?
To ensure secure confidential data
transmission across the network to
reduce the number of network devices in
use to improve network speed by removing
encryption overhead or to prevent the
use of outdated software on network
devices. Why is the implementation of
secure protocols essential in network
security?
Correct answer is to ensure secure
confidential data transmission across
the network. Which factor should be
considered when selecting a network
protocol? The age of the protocol and
its popularity among users, the security
level, including encryption and
authentication,
the number of devices that support the
protocol in the network, or the
protocol's ability to bypass firewalls
and network filters. Which factor should
be considered when selecting a network
protocol?
Correct answer is the security level
including encryption and authentication.
What is an important consideration when
selecting a port for network
communication? The port security and
whether or not it is commonly targeted
by attackers.
The physical location of the server to
which the port is connected. the amount
of data the port can transmit per second
or the color of the network cables used
with the port. What is an important
consideration when selecting a port for
network communication?
Correct answer is the port security and
whether it is commonly targeted by
attackers.
Why is transport method selection
crucial in secure communications? It
ensures that data is never encrypted
during transmission. It improves the
speed of the network connections by
ignoring encryption. It restricts the
types of devices that can access the
network or it determines secure data
transmission method and prevents
unauthorized access. Why is transport
method selection crucial in secure
communications?
Correct answer is it determines secure
data transmission method and prevents
unauthorized access. What is the main
function of DNS filtering in network
security? To prevent email fishing
attempts by blocking suspicious domains
to speed up the resolution of DNS
queries for all internal users to block
access to malicious websites by
filtering DNS requests or to redirect
DNS queries to external servers for
performance monitoring. What is the main
function of DNS filtering in network
security?
Correct answer is to block access to
malicious websites by filtering DNS
requests.
Why is email security important in
protecting organizations from cyber
threats? To prevent fishing, malware,
and other malicious activities delivered
through email. To encrypt email contents
and make sure they're not readable by
anyone. to reduce the number of users
who are allowed to send emails from the
organization or to monitor the time
taken by employees to read emails. Why
is email security important in
protecting organizations from cyber
threats?
Correct answer is to prevent fishing,
malware and other malicious activities
delivered through email.
What is the purpose of domainbased
message authentication, reporting and
conformance or demark?
To ensure that email messages are
encrypted before transmission to
authenticate and report emails to
prevent spoofing and fishing to block
all incoming email traffic from
unauthorized sources from unknown
sources or to automatically remove all
email attachments from incoming emails.
was the purpose of domainbased message
authentication reporting and conformance
or demark.
Correct answer is to authenticate and
report emails to prevent spoofing and
fishing.
What does domain keys identified mail or
DKIM provide for email security? It
encrypts email content and attachments
for confidentiality.
It blocks fishing emails by detecting
and removing malicious links in email
messages. It adds a digital signature to
verify sender identity and message
integrity. Or it creates temporary email
addresses to prevent spam. What does
domain keys identified mail or DKIM
provide for email security?
Correct answer is it adds a digital
signature to verify sender identity and
message integrity.
What is the function of sender policy
framework or SPF in email security? To
define authorized mail servers to
prevent domain spoofing to filter and
delete emails based on their content
type to prevent email attachments from
being delivered to external recipients
or to analyze email metadata and flag
suspicious senders. was the function of
sender policy framework or SPF in email
security.
Correct answer is to define authorized
mail servers to prevent domain spoofing.
What is a gateway in the context of
network security? A server that stores
all incoming and outgoing emails for
backup purposes. A device or software
that connects to networks and filters
traffic. A tool that encrypts all data
being transmitted over the network or a
firewall that blocks all incoming
traffic from untrusted networks. What is
a gateway in the context of network
security?
Correct answer is a device or software
that connects two networks and filters
traffic.
What is the primary purpose of file
integrity monitoring or FIM in cyber
security? to detect unauthorized changes
to files and directories, to prevent
unauthorized users from accessing files
in real time, to encrypt files before
they're stored on disk, or to
automatically delete sensitive files
after a certain period of time. What is
the primary purpose of file integrity
monitoring or FIM in cyber security?
Correct answer is to detect unauthorized
changes to files and directories.
How does data loss prevention or DLP
help protect sensitive information? By
automatically deleting files that
contain sensitive data by encrypting
data in transit without user
interaction? By creating backup copies
of sensitive data to prevent loss or by
blocking unauthorized transfer or
sharing of sensitive data. How does data
loss prevention or DLP help protect
sensitive information?
Correct answer is by blocking
unauthorized transfer or sharing of
sensitive data. What is the main purpose
of network access control or NAC in
cyber security? To enforce security
policies and control device access to
the network to monitor network traffic
for suspicious behavior to protect the
network from DOS attacks by filtering
incoming traffic or to enable seamless
connection between different network
segments. What is the main purpose of
network access control or NAC in cyber
security?
Correct answer is to enforce security
policies and control device access to
the network.
What is the main difference between
endpoint detection and response or EDR
and extended detection and response or
XDR? EDR is focused on cloud security
while XDR is focused on local device
protection. XDR provides only real-time
thread detection while EDR provides
long-term analysis and reporting. XDR
integrates data from multiple security
layers. EDR focuses on endpoints only or
EDR is used primarily for threat hunting
while XDR is used only for preventing
malware infections.
What is the main difference between
endpoint detection and response or EDR
and extended detection response or XDR?
Correct answer is XDR integrates data
from multiple security layers. EDR
focuses on endpoints only. How do user
behavior analytics or UBA enhance cyber
security? By analyzing user behavior to
detect activities that may indicate a
security breach, by blocking
unauthorized users from accessing the
network based on their login attempts,
by monitoring system performance to
identify areas for optimization, or by
encrypting user data before it's
transmitted over the network. How do
user behavior analytics or UBA enhance
cyber security?
Correct answer is by analyzing user
behavior to detect activities that may
indicate a security breach.
What is the purpose of provisioning and
deprovisioning user accounts in an
organization? To grant all users
unrestricted access to all systems at
all times. to automatically delete user
accounts after a set period of
inactivity to encrypt all user data for
protection without considering access
controls or to ensure users have proper
access when joining or leaving the
organization. What is the purpose of
provisioning and deprovisioning user
accounts in an organization?
Correct answer is to ensure users have
proper access when joining or leaving
the organization.
What is the impact of incorrect
permission assignments in an
organization? It ensures that no user
can have can access sensitive data
without proper authorization. It allows
for better tracking of system
performance. It can lead to unauthorized
access data breaches and compromised
systems or it limits users to only
accessing public information.
What is the impact of incorrect
permission assignments in an
organization?
Correct answer is it can lead to
unauthorized access, data breaches and
compromised systems.
What is the purpose of identity proofing
in the context of cyber security? To
verify that a user is who they claim to
be before granting access to a system to
track the number of unsuccessful login
attempts for auditing purposes. to
ensure that users have access to all
applications without requiring
credentials or to limit the number of
devices that can access the network at
one time. What is the purpose of
identity proofing in the context of
cyber security?
Correct answer is to verify that a user
is who they claim to be before granting
access to a system. What federation is?
What is federation in identity
management? The process of creating
multiple user accounts for each
organization to separate data access.
The act of merging multiple databases
into a single unified system. The use of
a single au authentication method for
all internal and external users or the
process of linking and sharing user
identity information across systems or
organizations.
What is federation in identity
management?
Correct answer is the process of linking
and sharing user identity information
across systems or organizations.
What is the advantage of single sign on
or SSO in an organization security
system? It forces users to authenticate
every time they access any application
for increased security. It stores all
user passwords in one location for
easier access management. It allows
users to authenticate once to access
multiple applications without repeated
login or it eliminates the need for
network segmentation or firewalls in the
organization.
Where's the advantage of single sign on
or SSO in an organization security
system?
Correct answer is it allows users to
authenticate once to access multiple
applications without repeated login.
What is the role of lightweight
directory access protocol or LDAP in
identity management? It is used to query
and modify directory services to store
user and authentication information. It
is a security protocol used to encrypt
user data during transmission. It is a
method for storing passwords in a
centralized location or it defines the
rules for granting users access to
network resources based on their
location. What is the role of
lightweight directory access protocol or
LDAP in identity management?
Correct answer is it is used to query
and modify directory services to store
user and authentication information.
What does open authorization or OOTH
provide in access management? It stores
encrypted user credentials for secure
access to applications. It lets
thirdparty applications access user
resources without sharing passwords. It
authenticates users using multiffactor
authentication for increased security or
encrypts email messages to ensure
confidentiality during transmission.
What does open authorization or OOTH
provide in access management?
Correct answer is it lets thirdparty
applications access user resources
without sharing passwords.
What is the role of security assertions
markup language or SAML in single sign
on or SSO? It stores encrypted passwords
to prevent unauthorized access. It
automatically generates user roles and
permissions for SSO applications. It
enables exchange of authentication and
authorization data between identity and
service providers or it provides a
secure way to connect all applications
within a closed network. What is the
role of security assertions markup
language or SAML in single signon or
SSO?
Correct answer is it enables exchange of
authentication and authorization data
between identity and service providers.
What does interoperability in cyber
security refer to? The ability of
systems, devices or apps to work
together and exchange info securely. The
process of isolating systems to prevent
them from interacting with external
networks. The process of creating
backups to ensure data availability
across different systems or the use of
proprietary software to ensure security
access security across all devices in an
organization.
What does interoperability in cyber
security refer to?
Correct answer is the ability of
systems, devices or apps to work
together and exchange information
securely.
What is the purpose of attestation in
security? To enforce encryption policies
for user data during transmission. To
verify system integrity to ensure it
hasn't been altered or tampered with. to
monitor and restrict access based on
user authentication level or to store
audit logs for all security incidents
for analysis. What is the purpose of
attestation in security?
Correct answer is to verify system
integrity to ensure it hasn't been
altered or tampered with. What is the
primary goal of mandatory access control
or MAC? To allow users to decide their
access rights based on their needs to
assign permissions dynamically based on
the user's role in the organization to
enforce access restrictions via system
policies that users can't override or to
provide access based on the time of day
and specific user activities. What is
the primary goal of mandatory access
control or MAC?
Correct answer is to enforce access
restrictions via system policies that
users can't override.
What is the key the key characteristic
of discretionary access control or DAC?
It enforces strict security policies
that can't be altered by the user. It
assigns access based on the user's role
in the organization.
It provides access only at certain times
of day or it allows owners of resources
to decide who has access to their
resources. What is the key
characteristic of discretionary access
control or DAC?
Correct answer is it allows owners of
resources to decide who has access to
their resources.
What does role-based access control or
arbback or RBAC rely on for assigning
permissions? It assigns permissions
based on a user's role in the
organization.
It allows users to freely assign
permissions to other users. It grants
access based on time of day and user
activity. Or it assigns permissions
randomly to avoid overprivileging users.
What does RO based access control or
RBAC rely on for assigning permissions?
Correct answer. It assigns permissions
based on a user's role in the
organization.
What is rule-based access control or
RBAC?
It allows users to define their own
access rules based on individual
preferences.
It provides unrestricted access to users
during specific time intervals. It
enforces access based on predefined
rules and policies, not users or roles,
or it dynamically adjusts permissions
based on user location within the
network. What is rule-based access
control?
Correct answer is it enforces access
based on predefined rules and policies,
not users or roles.
What does attribute-based access control
or ABAC use to determine access? It uses
attributes like user traits, environment
or resources to determine access. It
uses only the user's role in the
organization to assign access
permissions. It grants access based on
users time of day and location. or it
uses preconfigured static policies to
restrict access at all times. What does
attribute-based access control use to
determine access?
Correct answer. It uses attributes like
user traits, environment, and resources
to determine access.
What is the function of time of day
restrictions in access control? To allow
unrestricted access during business
hours and block access at all other
times. To limit access to systems or
resources based on the time of day or
specific hours. To grant temporary
access to external users based on the
devices timestamp. Or to prevent system
access during maintenance periods
regardless of the user's role. What is
the function of time of day restrictions
in access control?
Correct answer is to limit access to
systems or resources based on the time
of day or specific hours.
What does the principle of least
privilege ensure in access control? It
grants users full access to all systems
to increase productivity. It allows
users to modify access permissions for
other users.
It ensures users only get the minimum
access needed to do their tasks or it
limits access based on user roles
regardless of necessity.
What is the principle of least privilege
ensure in access control?
Correct answer is it ensures users get
only the minimum access needed to do
their tasks.
What is the main purpose of multiffactor
authentication or MFA? To require two or
more verification methods to enhance
security, to allow users to access
systems with a single password, to track
user activity for auditing purposes or
to automatically change passwords
periodically for all users. Where is the
main purpose of multiffactor
authentication or MFA?
Correct answer is it requires two or
more verification methods to enhance
security. What is an example of an
implementation of multiffactor
authentication? Allowing users to access
a system using only a password requiring
an employee badge for physical access
control requiring both a password and a
fingerprint scan to log in or allowing
access based on solely a username and IP
address. What is an example of
implementation of multiffactor
authentication or MFA?
Correct answer is requiring both a
password and a fingerprint scan to log
in. What is the primary advantage of
using biometrics for authentication?
Biometrics provide a unique
hardto-relicate verification using
physical traits. Biometrics are easy to
implement and can be used to monitor
employee productivity. Biometric data
can be reset with ease if compromised or
biometrics require no training for users
to operate. What is the primary
advantage of using biometrics for
authentication?
Correct answer is biometrics provide a
unique hard torelicate verification
using physical traits. What is the
difference between hard and soft
authentication tokens? Soft tokens
require a physical device while hard
tokens are software applications.
Hard tokens are physical devices. Soft
tokens are softwarebased applications
for authentication.
Hard tokens are used for password
recovery while soft tokens manage
encryption keys or there is no
difference between hard and soft tokens
in terms of functionality.
What is the difference between hard and
soft authentication tokens?
Correct answer is hard tokens are
physical devices. Soft tokens are
softwarebased applications for
authentication.
What is the primary function of security
keys in authentication?
Security keys store encrypted passwords
for easy retrieval during login.
Security keys enable encrypted email
communication without authentication.
Security keys allow users to bypass
security policies for testing purposes
or security keys are a physical device
used to verify identity often in
two-factor authentication or 2FA.
What is the primary function of security
keys in authentication?
Correct answer is security keys are a
physical device used to verify identity
often in two-factor authentication.
Which of the following is an example of
something you know in authentication?
A fingerprint scan that uniquely
identifies you, a physical card or token
used to generate login codes, a password
or pin that you must input during login,
or your current geographical location
used to verify access.
Which of the following is the example of
something you know in authentication?
Correct answer is a password or pin that
you must input during login.
What is an example of something you have
as a factor in authentication? a
smartphone that generates authentication
codes for login, a password that you
type into a login form, a voice pattern
used to authenticate your identity, or a
retina scan that identifies you based on
your eye characteristics.
What is an example of something you have
as a factor in authentication?
Correct answer is a smartphone that
generates authentication codes for
login. Which of the following is an
example of something you are as a factor
in authentication? A smart card that you
carry for authentication purposes, a
password that only you know, a
fingerprint scan that is unique to you,
or a code sent to your phone that you
enter during login.
Which of the following is an example of
something you are as a factor in
authentication?
Correct answer is a fingerprint scan
that is unique to you. What is the
purpose of somewhere you are as an
authentication factor? To authenticate a
user based on their physical location,
often using GPS or IP address to
validate the user based on their known
login name to verify the user based on a
secret password that is used at specific
locations or to authenticate based on
the user's biometric features. What is
the purpose of somewhere you are as an
authentication factor?
Correct answer is to authenticate a user
based on their physical location often
using GPS or IP address.
Why is password length important in
securing accounts? Shorter passwords are
easier to remember for users. Longer
passwords are harder to crack through
brute force. Short passwords reduce the
complexity of password storage or
password length has no impact on
security. Why is password length
important in securing accounts?
Correct answer is longer passwords are
harder to crack through brute force.
Which of the following is a password
best practice for ensuring security?
Using a combination of upper and
lowercase letters, numbers, and special
characters. Using a long word from the
dictionary that is easy to remember
without writing it down. Maintaining the
same password across applications to
ensure consistency and reliability. Or
only writing your password down on your
physical device, not storing it
digitally. Which of the following is a
password best practice for ensuring
security?
Correct answer is using a combination of
upper and lowerase letters, numbers, and
special characters.
What is the recommended password length
for maximum security? 6 to 8 characters,
only eight characters, any length as
long as it's memorable, or at least 12
characters.
The recommended password length for
maximum security.
Correct answer is at least 12
characters.
What does password complexity refer to
in security? Making passwords 30 plus
characters and using a third party
passwords saving application to recall
them. Using the same password across
multiple systems for consistency and
reliability.
Using a mix of characters, uppercase and
lowercase letters, numbers, and symbols
or avoiding the use of special
characters in passwords to reduce
complexity.
What does password complexity refer to
in security?
Correct answer is using a mix of
characters, uppercase and lowercase
letters, numbers, and symbols.
Why is reusing passwords a security
risk? Reusing passwords can threaten
additional systems if one password is
compromised. Reusing passwords improves
access ease across multiple systems.
Reusing passwords is a method for
reducing the number of passwords you
need to remember or reduce reusing
passwords allows faster account
recovery. Why is reusing passwords a
security risk?
Correct answer is reusing passwords can
threaten additional systems if one
password is compromised.
What is the recommended practice for
password expiration? Passwords should
never expire as this increases
convenience for users. Passwords should
expire only after 5 years.
Passwords should expire after 10 years
for minimal management. Or passwords
should be changed periodically to reduce
risk. What is the recommended practice
for password expiration?
Correct answer is passwords should be
changed periodically to reduce risk.
What is the main reason to track
password age in an organization?
to enforce stronger passwords over time,
to make it easier for users to recall
their passwords over extended periods,
to ensure passwords are periodically
updated to reduce risk of being
compromised, or to allow passwords to
remain unchanged for as long as
possible. What is the main reason to
track password age in an organization?
Correct answer is to ensure passwords
are periodically updated to reduce risk
of being compromised. What is the
primary function of a password manager?
To securely store and manage passwords
for various accounts to generate random
passwords for new accounts to enforce
password complexity rules on all
accounts and systems or to automatically
change passwords for users periodically.
What is the primary function of a
password manager?
Correct answer is to securely store and
manage passwords for various accounts.
What is passwordless authentication?
An authentication method that requires
only a username to log in and no
password. An authentication method that
replaces passwords with INTP tokens for
increased security. An authentication
method without traditional passwords
using biometrics or tokens instead. or
an authentication method where login
credentials are randomized hourly for
maximum security. What is passwordless
authentication?
Correct answer is an authentication
method without traditional passwords
using biometrics or tokens instead. What
is the purpose of privileged access
management or PAM tools? To provide
encryption services for privileged user
passwords, to control and monitor access
to critical systems and data by
privileged users, to automatically
assign permissions based on the users's
department, or to create backup accounts
for system administrators in case of
password loss. What is the purpose of
privileged access management tools?
Correct answer is to control and monitor
access to critical systems and data by
privileged users.
What are just in time permissions?
Permissions granted to all users
permanently without restrictions,
permissions granted based on a user's
role in the organization or a recurring
cycle, permissions granted for users
based on a pre-approved schedule, or
permissions granted to users only when
necessary, often with expirations.
What are just in time permissions?
Correct answer is permissions granted to
users only when necessary often with
expirations.
What is the primary function of password
vaulting? To securely store and manage
passwords in encrypted repository to
automatically generate passwords for
user accounts to allow users to retrieve
lost passwords via email or to monitor
user activities related to password
changes. What is the primary function of
password vaultting?
Correct answer is to securely store and
manage passwords in encrypted
repository.
What are ephemeral credentials used for?
To store passwords in a way that cannot
be accessed or modified. To generate
long-term credentials for access to
critical systems. To provide temporary
access to systems often within
expiration time. or to provide permanent
access to systems and networks without
expiration. What are ephemeral
credentials used for?
Correct answer is to provide temporary
access to systems often with an
expiration time. What is the primary use
case for automation and scripting in
security operations? To manually
configure network settings for every
user to automate repetitive security
tasks. to store sensitive data in plain
text for easy access or to monitor user
behavior across multiple systems
manually.
What is the primary use case of
automation and scripting in security
operations?
Correct answer is to automate repetitive
security tasks.
What is the goal of user provisioning in
an organization?
To assign appropriate access rights and
permissions to users based on their
roles, to create backup accounts for
employees in case they forget their
credentials, to monitor users behavior
and generate security reports, or to
remove all permissions for users when
they leave the organization. What is the
goal of user provisioning in an
organization?
Correct answer is to assign appropriate
access rights and permissions to users
based on their roles. What is the
purpose of resource provisioning in IT
security? To monitor the health of
system hardware components to remove
unused resources from systems to
allocate and manage resources like
storage and servers or to create backups
of critical resources automatically.
What is the purpose of resource
provisioning in IT security?
Correct answer is to allocate and manage
resources like storage and servers. What
are the guard rails in the context of
security operations? Physical barriers
designed to protect the organization's
hardware from external threats,
temporary settings applied to control
user behavior, controls that block all
external traffic to the network, or
predefined policies that prevent harmful
actions while allowing flexibility.
What are guardrails in the context of
security operations?
Correct answer is predefined policies
that prevent harmful actions while
allowing flexibility.
What is the purpose of security groups
in identity management? to group users
with similar security needs to simplify
management, to monitor and track user
activities across systems, to assign
individual permissions to each user
manually, or to enforce encryption
standards for each group individually
based on business needs. What is the
purpose of security groups in identity
management?
Correct answer is to group users with
similar security needs to simplify
management.
What is the role of ticket creation in a
security incident management process? To
automatically patch vulnerabilities in a
system, to grant unauthorized access to
network resources for troubleshooting,
to document and track security issues
for resolution and auditing, or to
delete sensitive data from a system for
protection. What is the role of ticket
creation in a security incident
management process?
Correct answer is to document and track
security issues for resolution and
auditing.
What is the purpose of escalation in
incident response to escalate incidents
to authorities or specialized teams when
necessary? to assign lower priority
tasks to non-technical staff members to
resolve incidents without involving the
IT department or to delay incident
resolution until further investigation
is completed. What is the purpose of
escalation in incident response?
Correct answer is to escalate incidents
to authorities or specialized teams when
necessary.
What does enabling or disabling services
and access and access mean in security
operations? The manual process of
resetting user passwords for all
employees. The use of encryption to
protect access to sensitive information.
The process of granting or revoking
access to services based on policies and
roles or the blocking of all external
network connections to improve security
and access. What does enabling or
disabling services and access mean in
security operations?
Correct answer is the process of
granting or revoking access to services
based on policies and roles. What is the
purpose of continuous integration and
testing in security operations? To
detect security vulnerabilities early
through automated testing during
development to perform manual security
checks on completed applications.
to reduce the need for encryption in
software applications or to prevent
unauthorized access to development
environments by external parties. What
is the purpose of continuous integration
and testing in security operations?
Correct answer is to detect security
vulnerabilities early through automated
testing during development.
How do integrations in application
programming interfaces or APIs
contribute to security operations? They
store sensitive user credentials for
secure access to applications. They
enable security tools to communicate and
share data. They block on block
unauthorized access to web services and
applications or they encrypt all
communication between systems to prevent
data leaks. How do integrations in
application programming interfaces
contribute to security operations?
Correct answer is they enable security
tools to communicate and share data.
What is a key benefit of automation in
security operations? It increases
efficiency by reducing manual
operations. It makes security management
more complex and timeconuming. It
completely removes the need for security
personnel or it decreases the importance
of monitoring network traffic. What is a
key benefit of automation in security
operations?
Correct answer. It increases efficiency
by reducing manual operations.
How does automation contribute to time
savings in security operations? By
eliminating by eliminating the need for
security audits. By increasing the
number of alerts that need to be
manually reviewed. By streamlining
repetitive tasks such as patch
management and log analysis or by
decreasing system performance to allow
more time for security tasks. How does
automation contribute to time savings in
security operations?
Correct answer is by streamlining
repetitive tasks such as patch
management and log analysis.
Why is enforcing baselines important in
security operations? It makes it easier
to grant unrestricted access to
sensitive data. It ensures that system
performance is maximized by removing
unnecessary security controls. It allows
users to easily bypass security controls
when needed or it ensures secure
consistent system and network
configurations organizationwide.
Why is enforcing baselines important in
security operations?
Correct answer is it ensures secure
consistent system and network
configurations organizationwide.
How do standard infrastructure
configurations improve security? By
increasing the number of devices
connected to the network for better
security by allowing for unregulated
access to critical systems by enabling
random security configurations across
the network or by ensuring uniform
system configurations to simplify
security management. How do standard
infrastructure configurations improve
security?
Correct answer is it ensures uniform
system configurations to simplify
security management.
What is a secure way to scale an
organization's infrastructure by rapidly
increasing system size without
considering security? By restricting
security updates and patches to save
time and resources. by planning and
applying security measures as the system
grows or by allowing unvetted devices
and software to be added to the network.
What is a secure way to scale an
organization's infrastructure?
Correct answer is by planning and
applying security measures as the system
grows. What role does employee retention
play in cyber security? Employee
retention is to help ensure secure
knowledge and expertise are retained.
Employee retention has no impact on
secure operations.
Employee turnover increases the
likelihood of security breaches or
employees should be replaced regularly
to reduce security liabilities.
What role does employee retention play
in cyber security?
Correct answer is employee retention is
to help ensure security knowledge and
expertise are retained.
Why is a fast reaction time important in
security incident management? A quick
response helps to mitigate the impact of
security incidents. A fast reaction time
can lead to incorrect decisions and
larger breaches. A delayed reaction time
increases the cost of security tools or
a rapid response is unnecessary if the
incident is not immediately affecting
the system. Why is a fast reaction time
important in security incident
management?
Correct answer is a quick response helps
to mitigate the impact of security
incidents.
What is a workforce multiplier in the
context of security operations?
Increasing the number of security staff
to handle security tasks manually.
Deploying a larger number of
non-technical personnel to manage
security tools, using tools in
automation to extend the abilities of a
limited security team or allowing
employees to perform security related
tasks without training. What is a
workforce multiplier in the context of
security operations?
Correct answer is using tools and
automation to extend the abilities of a
limited security team.
Why is complexity an important
consideration in security operations?
Complexity makes it easier to predict
and automate system behaviors. Greater
complexity makes systems harder to
manage and more vulnerable. Complex
systems are typically more secure due to
their size and infrastructure. Or
complexity improves the speed of
incident response.
Why is complexity an important
consideration in security operations?
Correct answer is greater complexity
makes systems harder to manage and more
vulnerable.
What is a critical factor to consider
when evaluating the cost of a security
solution? Balance security benefits with
implementation and maintenance costs
only the initial setup cost of the
solution ignoring long-term expenses.
the size of the security team needed to
monitor the solution after
implementation or the geographic
location of the vendor providing the
security solution. What is a critical
factor to consider when evaluating the
cost of a security solution?
Correct answer is balance security
benefits with implementation and
maintenance costs.
What is the risk of having a single
point of failure in a network or system?
Single points of failure are easier to
secure because there's only one
component to manage. A single point of
failure increases the redundancy of
critical systems. Failure of a single
component can disrupt service affecting
security and availability. Or single
points of failure are only a concern for
physical hardware, not digital systems.
What is the risk of having a single
point of failure in a network or system?
Correct answer is failure of a single
component can disrupt service affecting
security and availability.
What is technical debt in the context of
security? The investment made in
training staff to handle advanced
security technologies.
The process of adopting new technologies
without thoroughly vetting their
security implications. the cost of
buying thirdparty security tools for
immediate use in the organization or the
accumulated cost of delaying updates and
improvements increasing future
challenges. What is technical debt in
the context of security?
Correct answer is the accumulated cost
of delaying updates or improvements
increasing future challenges.
Why is ongoing supportability important
in the context of security systems?
Ongoing support ensures that security
systems are updated and maintained to
handle emerging threats. It reduces the
need for compliance audits and
regulations.
Supportability allows the organization
to completely automate its security
processes without human oversight or
ongoing support ensures that all
employees are trained in the latest
security technologies.
Why is ongoing supportability important
in the context of security systems?
Correct answer is ongoing support
ensures that security systems are
updated and maintained to handle
emerging threats. was the primary goal
of the preparation phase in incident
response. To identify and detect
security threats, to develop and test
incident response plans, to recover data
after an attack, or to contain and
eradicate security incidents,
which is the primary goal of the
preparation phase in incident response.
Correct answer is to develop and test
incident response plans.
Which action is typically performed
during the detection phase of an
incident response? Identify the root
cause of the incident. Analyze system
logs and alerts. Contain the spread of
the incident or restore systems to their
normal state. Which action is typically
performed during the detection phase of
an incident response?
Correct answer is analyze system logs
and alerts. What is the main objective
of the analysis phase in incident
response? To understand the impact and
scope of the incident, to prevent
similar incidents in the future, to
restore services to their normal state
after an incident occurs, or to recover
lost data and systems. What is the main
objective of the analysis phase in
incident response?
Correct answer is to understand the
impact and scope of the incident.
During the containment phase of an
incident response, which action is
performed? Analyze logs for evidence of
an attack, isolate affected systems to
prevent further damage, restore backup
systems and data, or develop a plan for
incident recovery during the containment
phase of an incident response. Which
action is performed?
Correct answer is isolate affected
systems to prevent further damage.
was the goal of the eradication phase in
an incident response. To recover
critical business operations, to remove
any malicious code and vulnerabilities,
to document lessons learned, or to
restore affected systems to normal
operations.
What is the goal of the eradication
phase in incident response?
Correct answer is to remove any
malicious code and vulnerabilities.
Which of the following is a key action
in the recovery phase of an incident
response? Isolate affected systems from
the network. Analyze the attack to
determine its scope. Restore systems and
services to normal or remove malicious
actors from the network. Which of the
following is a key action in the
recovery phase of incident response?
Correct answer is restore systems and
services to normal was the main purpose
of the lessons learned phase in incident
response to involve all management
groups and develop new security policies
and procedures to improve the
organization's ability to detect and
respond to future incidents to remove
all traces of the attack from systems
further reducing the risk from future
incidents or to ensure business
continuity during an incident. was the
main purpose of the lessons learned
phase in incident response.
Correct answer is to improve the
organization's ability to detect and
respond to future incidents.
What is the primary purpose of training
in security operations? to test the
effectiveness of security policies,
to ensure employees understand their
role in security, to create new security
technologies, or to improve response
time during an incident. What is the
primary purpose of training in security
operations?
Correct answer is to ensure employees
understand their role in security.
Which activity is performed during
testing in security operations?
creating incident response plans,
real-time simulations of breaches,
designing security policies, or
analyzing historical security data.
Which activity is performed during
testing in security operations?
Correct answer is real-time simulations
of breaches. What is the primary goal of
tabletop exercise in security testing?
to conduct real-time security breach
simulations to develop new security
tools to identify weaknesses in physical
security systems or to evaluate the
response plan's effectiveness. What is
the primary goal of a tabletop exercise
in security testing?
Correct answer is to evaluate the
response plan's effectiveness.
Which of the following best describes a
simulation in security operations
testing? A theoretical discussion about
handling a cyber attack, a live exercise
to test security systems against
attacks, a review of past incidents to
improve response procedures, or a
written test to assess individual
security knowledge. Which of the
following best describes a simulation in
security operations testing?
Correct answer is a live exercise to
test security systems against attacks.
What is the purpose of root cause
analysis in incident response? To
identify the source of a security
incident, to conduct real-time security
testing, to analyze the consequences of
a cyber attack, or to recover lost or
damaged data. The purpose of a root
cause analysis in incident response
Correct answer is to identify the source
of a security incident. Which of the
following best describes threat hunting?
Monitoring systems for known security
vulnerabilities from external sources,
the proactive search for potential
threats and security breaches,
performing vulnerability assessments on
networks, or a process of patching
vulnerabilities as they arise. Which of
the following best describes threat
hunting?
Correct answer is the process uh the
proactive search for potential threats
and security breaches.
What is the purpose of a legal hold in
digital forensics to identify the legal
process for acquiring digital evidence?
To secure evidence in a digital storage
facility, to review evidence before
presenting it in court, or to prever
preserve evidence by presenting to
preserve evidence by preventing data
deletion or alteration.
What is the purpose of a legal hold in
digital forensics?
Correct answer is to preserve evidence
by preventing data deletion or
alteration.
What does the chain of custody refer to
in digital forensics? The process of
collecting evidence from multiple
sources, the chronological documentation
of the possession of evidence, the
process of securely transporting
evidence to court or the technical tools
used to analyze the evidence. What is
the chain of custody referred to in
digital forensics?
Correct answer is the chronological
documentation of the possession of
evidence. Which activity is performed
during the acquisition phase of digital
forensics? Collecting all evidence into
a central location, ensuring evidence is
stored securely for future use,
preserving digital evidence for
analysis, or reporting findings to legal
authorities. Which activity is performed
during the acquisition phase of digital
forensics?
Correct answer is preserving digital
evidence for analysis.
What is the main purpose of reporting in
digital forensics? To detail how
evidence was acquired and analyzed, to
present the evidence in a court of law,
to prevent evidence tampering during
investigations, or to summarize the
legal hold process? What is the main
purpose of reporting in digital
forensics?
Correct answer is to detail how evidence
was acquired and analyzed.
What does preservation of digital
evidence ensure in digital forensics?
The destruction and of s the destruction
of sensitive data during investigations,
the integrity and authenticity of
evidence over time, the transfer of
evidence to an external party, or the
reporting of evidence to law
enforcement. What does preservation of
digital evidence ensure in digital
forensics?
Correct answer is the integrity and
authenticity of evidence over time. What
is the focus of eiscocovery in digital
forensics? The search and retrieval of
relevant digital evidence for legal
cases. The preservation of digital of
digital evidence during an
investigation. the identification of
data breaches in enterprise systems or
the creation of new security policies
based on forensic findings. What is the
focus of eiscocovery in digital
forensics?
Correct answer is the search and
retrieval of relevant digital evidence
for legal cases.
What is the primary purpose of log data
in security operations?
To track user behavior for marketing
purposes, to monitor network traffic for
performance optimization,
to record evidence uh to record events
and activities for security monitoring
and analysis, or to provide user
specific data for application
performance analysis. What is the
primary purpose of log data in security
operations?
Correct answer is to record events and
activities for security monitoring and
analysis.
Which of the following is most commonly
found in firewall logs? User login
details, traffic blocked or allowed
based on security rules, file transfers
and email metadata, or network
vulnerabilities detected during scans.
Which of the following is most commonly
found in firewall logs?
Correct answer is traffic blocked or
allowed based on security rules. What
type of information is typically
captured in application logs? Network
traffic and connection details, system
errors and user access attempts, user
activities and application performance
issues or firewall rule application and
exceptions.
What type of information is typically
captured in application logs?
Correct answer is user activities and
application performance issues. What is
the primary function of endpoint logs in
a security context? to monitor
application performance, to track user
interactions with the operating system,
to record activities and events on user
devices, or to capture network traffic
across an entire organization. Whereas
the primary function of endpoint logs in
a security context.
Correct answer is to record activities
and events on user devices.
Which type of logs are specifically
tailored to the security features of an
operating system? Application program
interface logs, OS specific security
logs, network topology logs, or IPS or
IDS logs.
Which type of logs are specifically
tailored to the security features of an
operating system?
Correct answer is OS specific security
logs. What is the purpose of IPS and IDS
logs? To record malicious or spec
suspicious activities detected to
capture information about system
performance and uptime to monitor access
attempts and file integrity or to
provide audit trails of user
authentication events. What is the
purpose of IPS and IDS logs?
Correct answer is to record malicious or
suspicious activities detected. Which of
the following is typically recorded in
network logs? Malicious code detected by
antivirus software, user login and
password attempts segmented by security
group, details of connections,
protocols, and IP addresses or file
modifications and access times. Which of
the following is typically recorded in
network logs?
Correct answer is details of
connections, protocols, and IP
addresses.
What does metadata in security logs
provide information about? The contents
of the data being accessed, the who,
what, where, and when of data
interaction, the data backup frequency
and status, or the error rates of
security tools and software? What does
metadata in security logs provide
information about?
Correct answer is the who, what, where,
and when of data interaction.
What is the primary purpose of
vulnerability scans in security
operations? To monitor system
performance in real time? To analyze
user behavior for potential threats, to
assess the integrity of security
patches, or to identify security
weaknesses and vulnerabilities?
What is the primary purpose of
vulnerability scans in security
operations?
Correct answer is to identify security
weaknesses and vulnerabilities.
What is an advantage of using automated
reports in security monitoring? They
provide real-time user behavior
analysis. They help automate incident
response actions for an organization.
They generate consistent timely analysis
of security data. or they reduce the
need for network vulnerability scans.
What is an advantage of using automated
reports in security monitoring?
Correct answer is they generate
consistent timely analysis of security
data. What is the role of dashboards in
security operations? To store and backup
security data for future recovery to
provide a visual interface for
monitoring security metrics. to directly
control firewalls and intrusion
detection systems or to generate user
access reports for compliance auditing.
What is the role of dashboards in
security operations?
Correct answer is to provide a visual
interface for monitoring security
metrics.
What type of information is captured in
packet captures? real-time user activity
logs, captured network traffic like
headers and payloads, system
configuration and software vulnerability
details, or application performance
metrics and error reports. What type of
information is captured in packet
captures?
Correct answer is captured network
traffic like headers and payloads.
What is the main purpose of guidelines
in a security program? To define the
mandatory security controls for
compliance, to monitor and enforce the
security policies of an organization. To
provide best practices and
recommendations for security
implementation or to outline the legal
consequences of security violations.
What is the main purpose of guidelines
in a security program?
Correct answer is to provide best
practices and recommendations for
security implementation.
Which of the following best describes a
policy in a security program? A set of
recommended actions for enhancing
security posture. A highle statement of
principles guiding security decisions.
detailed instructions on the specific
tools to be used in a system or a daily
log of security incidents and responses.
What best describes a policy in a
security program?
Correct answer is a highle statement of
principles guiding security decisions.
What does an acceptable use policy
define? The permissions and access
controls for employees accessing
corporate networks and systems remotely.
The detailed procedures for incident
detection, analysis, containment, and
response activities, the appropriate and
inappropriate uses of an organization's
technology resources or the
comprehensive methods and criteria for
classifying and handling sensitive
company data. What does an acceptable
use policy define?
Correct answer is the appropriate and
inappropriate uses of an organization's
technology resources.
What is the focus of information
security policies? to provide technical
specifications for implementing secure
network architectures and system
configurations. To define standardized
procedures for conducting security
awareness training sessions for all
employees to create detailed incident
response workflows and escalation
procedures for cyber security events or
to establish comprehensive governance
frameworks for protecting organizational
information assets and systems. What is
the focus of information security
policies?
Correct answer is to establish
comprehensive governance frameworks for
protecting organizational information
assets and systems. Which of the
following is the main goal of business
continuity planning? To ensure the
continuous availability of critical
services and operations during and after
a disruption. To rapidly recover and
restore essential business data and
applications following a cyber security
incident. To assess and quantify the
financial and operational impact of
security breaches on business operations
or to maintain reliable IT
infrastructure availability and system
uptime for all stakeholders and
customers.
What is the main goal of business
continuity planning?
Correct answer is to ensure the
continuous availability of critical
services and operations during and after
a disruption.
What is the primary focus of disaster
recovery planning to minimize the
effects of natural disasters on business
operations? to identify potential
threats to business assets, to restore
IT systems and operations following a
disruptive event, or to prevent security
breaches through advanced encryption.
The primary focus of disaster recovery
planning.
Correct answer is to restore IT systems
and operations following a disruptive
event. What is the purpose of incident
response in security program? To
proactively prevent security incidents
before they occur to detect, manage and
recover from security incidents or
breaches to monitor financial accounts
for fraudulent activity or to develop
security policies and procedures. What
is the purpose of incident response in
security program?
Correct answer is to detect, manage and
recover from security incidents or
breaches.
What phase of the software development
life cycle focuses on identifying and
resolving security vulnerabilities?
Design phase, implementation phase,
testing phase or maintenance phase.
What phase of the software development
life cycle focuses on identifying and
resolving security vulnerabilities?
Correct answer is the testing phase.
What is the goal of a change management
in a security program? To ensure that
changes to systems and processes are
implemented in a controlled and secure
manner. To monitor and evaluate the
operational performance and
effectiveness of deployed security
devices and controls. To process and
manage user access requests, permissions
and privileged accounts provisioning
workflows across systems. Or to
continuously analyze network traffic
patterns, security logs and system data
for threat detection purposes. What is
the goal of change management in a
security program?
Correct answer is to ensure that changes
to systems and processes are implemented
in a controlled and secure manner. What
is the purpose of security standards in
an organization? To standardize approved
hardware and software configurations
across departments, to implement access
controls and restrict unauthorized
network resource access, to establish
application control policies and prevent
unauthorized software installations, or
to define the expected level of
performance and security practices.
What is the purpose of security
standards in an organization?
Correct answer is to define the expected
level of performance and security
practices.
What is the primary reason for using
strong passwords in security management?
To improve user authentication
reliability and minimize lockouts to
reduce the risk of unauthorized access
to systems and data. to streamline
password management processes and reduce
administrative overhead burdens or to
satisfy regulatory compliance
requirements and organizational security
policy mandates. What is the primary
reason for using strong passwords in
security management?
Correct answer is to reduce the risk of
unauthorized access to systems and data.
What does access control help achieve in
a security program? It prevents
unauthorized access to information and
resources. It optimizes authentication
workflows and improves user login
efficiency. It streamlines data backup
processes and enhances recovery
capabilities. or it reduces security
infrastructure costs and minimizes
operational expenses.
What does access control help achieve in
a security program?
Correct answer is it prevents
unauthorized access to information and
resources.
Which of the following is an example of
physical security? Implementing data
encryption for secure communications and
information protection. Configuring
network firewalls to block unauthorized
traffic and access attempts. Securing
the entrance of a building with access
badges and surveillance. Or establishing
multiffactor authentication systems for
enhanced user verification processes.
Which of the following is an example of
physical security?
Correct answer is securing the entrance
of a building with access badges and
surveillance.
What is the main goal of encryption in
security? To optimize data transfer
speeds and enhance system performance
capabilities. To convert sensitive data
into a secure format that is unreadable
without the key. to monitor and track
user activities across systems for
compliance purposes or to ensure
automated data backup processes and
maintain information availability.
What is the main goal of encryption in
security?
Correct answer is to convert sensitive
data into a secure format that is
unreadable without the key.
What is the purpose of having documented
procedures in a security program? To
guide employees on how to handle
sensitive data and security incidents to
outline the roles and responsibilities
of managers in the security team to
define the tools and technologies used
for system monitoring or to set the
budget for security related activities.
What is the purpose of having documented
procedures in a security program?
Correct answer is to guide employees on
how to handle sensitive data and
security incidents.
Which of the following best describes
the purpose of change management in
security? To automate system upgrades
and patches across all infrastructure
without manual intervention. to
establish regular schedules for updating
organizational security policies and
compliance documentation
to track and control changes to IT
systems and infrastructure to minimize
security risks or to enable streamline
user workflows by allowing rapid system
modifications without approval
processes.
What best describes the purpose of
change management in security?
Correct answer is to track and control
changes to IT systems and infrastructure
to minimize security risks.
What is a primary goal of onboarding and
offboarding procedures in an
organization? To ensure employees
receive comprehensive training on
organizational cyber security tools
during their tenure. To manage the
secure access of employees to
organizational resources during their
employment and after their departure. To
guide new employees in configuring
secure network protocols and maintaining
access controls or to monitor employee
adherence to security policies and
procedures throughout their
organizational tenure. What is a primary
goal of onboarding and offboarding
procedures in an organization?
Correct answer is to manage the secure
access of employees to organizational
resources during their employment and
after their departure.
What is the purpose of a playbook in a
security program? To outline employee
conduct policies for maintaining
compliance with organizational security
standards. to catalog and monitor
security hardware assets used within the
organization's infrastructure to
schedule and oversee regular system
backups for ensuring data recovery
processes or to document detailed
incident response procedures to follow
in case of a security breach. Where's
the purpose of a playbook in a security
program?
Correct answer is to document detailed
incident incident response procedures to
follow in case of a security breach.
Which of the following best describes
external considerations in security
program management? Internal processes
for securing systems and managing
employee access controls effectively?
Designing network security policies to
protect internal organizational data
assets. favors such as vendor risks,
thirdparty service providers, and
regulatory requirements, or implementing
employee training programs to enhance
organizational cyber security awareness.
Which of the following best describes
external considerations in security
program management?
Correct answer is factors such as vendor
risks, thirdparty service providers and
regulatory requirements.
What is the main focus of regulatory
requirements in security management? To
ensure that security operations are
compliant with laws and standards set by
governing bodies to optimize network
data transfer speeds while maintaining
organizational cyber security protocols
and standards. to evaluate performance
metrics in of security appliances to
ensure effective threat detection
capabilities or to enforce employee
compliance with internal security
training and awareness programs
organizationwide.
What is the main focus of regulatory
requirements in security management?
Correct answer is to ensure that
security operations are compliant with
laws and standards set by governing
bodies.
How do legal considerations impact
security program management? By
permitting employees to access sensitive
data with minimal restrictions for
operational efficiency by establishing
procedures for conducting regular system
performance audits to ensure operational
security. by guiding decisions on
updating systems with the latest
software patches for enhanced security
or by requiring that data be stored in
specific formats and locations to comply
with laws. How do legal considerations
impact security program management?
Correct answer is by requiring that data
be stored in specific formats and
locations to comply with laws.
What does industry specific regulation
ensure in a security program? It ensures
a security program is aligned with these
specific needs of a particular industry.
It establishes mandatory schedules for
software updates to maintain
organizational cyber security
compliance. It sets requirements for
employee training to enhance cyber
security awareness organizationwide
or it determines the IT department
structure to support organizational
cyber security operations.
What does industry specific regulation
ensure in a security program?
Correct answer is it ensures a security
program is aligned with the specific
needs of a particular industry. What
does local or regional security
compliance involve? It focuses on global
strategies for securing network
infrastructure and data assets. It
ensures that security practices comply
with laws and regulations that vary by
region. It dictates the design of
website security to protect
organizational online assets or it
requires adherence to international
standards for data protection across all
regions. What does local or regional
security compliance involve?
Correct answer is it ensures that
security practices comply with laws and
regulations that vary by region. What is
the role of national considerations in
security management? To monitor
compliance with national laws such as
data protection and privacy regulations
across the country to ensure to ensure
security operations aligned with local
network infrastructure standards within
specific organizational regions. to
limit data access to employees trained
in national cyber security protocols for
organizational security or to enforce
employee adherence to international
cyber security standards for consistent
organizational security practices. What
is the role of national considerations
in security management?
Correct answer is to monitor compliance
with national laws such as data
protection and privacy regulations
across the country.
What is the main concern when managing
global security operations? Ensuring
compliance with country specific laws
and regulations, optimizing local
network traffic for efficiency,
streamlining employee onboarding for
cyber security training, or restricting
access to company financial records.
What is the main concern when managing
global security operations?
Correct answer is ensuring compliance
with country specific laws and
regulations.
Why is monitoring and revision important
in a security program? To optimize
systems for maximum operational speed.
to continuously improve security
measures and ensure compliance to
minimize costs of security tools
deployment or to evaluate employee
performance on security tasks. Why is
monitoring and revision important in a
security program?
Correct answer is to continuously
improve security measures and ensure
compliance.
Which of the following is a
characteristic of a decentralized
governance structure? Centralized
decision-making for all organizational
security policies, unified control over
all organizational system resources, no
local branch involvement in security
management, or local offices or
departments have autonomy in security
decision-m.
Which of the following is a
characteristic of a decentralized
governance structure?
Correct answer is local offices or
departments have autonomy in security
decision-making.
What is the primary role of boards in
security governance? to oversee and
provide strategic direction for security
policies and procedures. To manage
execution of daily cyber security tasks
and incident response activities to
monitor technical performance metrics of
IT systems for cyber security
optimization or to develop and implement
employee training programs for cyber
security awareness. What is the primary
role of boards in security governance?
Correct answer is to oversee and provide
strategic direction for security
policies and procedures.
What function do committees serve in
security governance? To oversee employee
adherence to security procedures and
guidelines to collaborate on creating
and reviewing security policies and
initiatives. to provide recommendations
on handling security incidents and
responses or to assist in evaluating new
technologies and organizational security
needs. What function do committees serve
in security governance?
Correct answer is to collaborate on
creating and reviewing security policies
and initiatives.
Which government entities are
responsible for regulating security
compliance? Commercial enterprises that
develop and market security
technologies, industry associations that
publish frameworks and best practices,
private organizations that manage online
platforms and digital content, or
government agencies that enforce data
protection and privacy laws. Which
government entities are responsible for
regulating security compliance?
Correct answer is government agencies
that enforce data protection and privacy
laws. What is a key difference between
centralized and decentralized security
models? Centralized models allow
departments some input but not full
control over policies. Decentralized
models distribute security
responsibilities across multiple
business units. Centralized models have
a single unified approach for managing
security across all departments or
decentralized models permit greater
flexibility in how different groups
manage security. What is a key
difference between centralized and
decentralized security models?
Correct answer is centralized models
have a single unified approach for
managing security across all
departments. Which of the following
describes the role of owners in a
security program? Individuals who
oversee the technical operation,
maintenance, and daily management of
organizational systems. External parties
who conduct independent assessments and
provide detailed reports on security
practices. Individuals who implement and
enforce routine access controls for
systems and organizational resources. or
individuals responsible for setting the
overall direction and protection of
assets and data.
What describes the role of owners in a
security program?
Correct answer is individuals
responsible for setting the overall
direction and protection of assets and
data. What is the responsibility of
controllers in a security program? They
determine how data can be accessed and
who can access it. They are responsible
for ensuring that data is securely
stored and transmitted. They conduct
incident response activities after a
breach or they make decisions regarding
the installation of security patches.
The responsibility of controllers in a
security program.
Correct answer is they determine how
data can be accessed and who can access
it. What is the primary role of
processors in managing data security?
They're responsible for determining the
storage requirements of sensitive data.
They handle the processing of personal
data on behalf of the owner. They create
encryption standards for data protection
or they manage the distribution of data
among multiple servers. The primary role
of processors in managing data security.
Correct answer is they handle the
processing of personal data on behalf of
the owner.
What is the role of custodians or
stewards in data security? They're
responsible for providing legal
oversight of data use. They define
policies for data access control. They
manage incident response and remediation
actions for data breaches. Or they
manage the day-to-day operations of data
storage and security. The role of
custodians or stewards in data security.
Correct answer is they manage the
day-to-day operations of data storage
and security.
What is the purpose of risk
identification in security management?
To uncover and document potential risks
to the organization's assets and
operations. To analyze and assess the
potential consequences of risks once
they've been identified. to design and
implement strategies that reduce the
overall exposure to security risks or to
estimate the probability of frequenc
probability or frequency with which a
particular risk might occur. The purpose
of risk identification in security
management.
Correct answer is to uncover and
document potential risks to the
organization's assets and operations.
What is the primary objective of risk
assessment in security management? To
quantify the potential damages from each
identified risk to determine the root
causes of security incidents. To
evaluate the probability and impact of
identified risks or to allocate
resources to address low priority risks.
The primary objective of risk assessment
in security management.
Correct answer is to evaluate the
probability and impact of identified
risks. Which of the following best
describes ad hoc risk management? A
structured and systematic framework
applied consistently to manage risks
over extended periods. risk management
carried out in response to immediate
unplanned needs or unexpected
situations, an ongoing process of
assessing and reviewing risks that
occurs on a daily basis, or a predefined
series of documents and steps designed
to address recurring risks within the
organization.
Ad hoc risk management.
Correct answer is risk management
carried out in response to immediate
unplanned needs or unexpected
situations.
What is the main characteristic of
recurring riskmanagement activities?
They're performed only once during the
overall life cycle of a project
initiative. They are initiated primarily
in reaction to urgent or unexpected
security incidents. They are focused
mainly on the development of long-term
strategic risk management plans or they
are conducted at regular predefined
intervals to manage ongoing risks
effectively.
The main characteristic of recurring
risk management activities.
Correct answer is they are conducted at
regular predefined intervals to manage
ongoing risks effectively.
Which of the following is a
characteristic of one-time
riskmanagement activities? They are
performed on a continuous basis
throughout the project. They're
conducted once to address a specific
risk or issue. They focus on analyzing
the long-term performance of the
organization or they're scheduled to
occur regularly at predetermined
intervals. a characteristic of one-time
riskmanagement activities.
Correct answer is they are conducted
once to address a specific risk or
issue. What is the purpose of continuous
risk management? To address risks as a
single event by providing short-term
analysis and recommendations. To
evaluate organizational risks only after
significant or disruptive incidents have
already occurred. to emphasize ongoing
improvements in the efficiency of
existing risk mitigation strategies over
time or to ensure that risk management
is always active and risks are
continually monitored and mitigated.
The purpose of continuous risk
management.
Correct answer is to ensure that risk
management is always active and risks
are continually monitored and mitigated.
What is risk analysis primarily
concerned with in security management?
Determining how long it will take to
respond to a risk, assessing the
effectiveness of risk response
strategies, evaluating the nature,
impact, and likelihood of identified
risks, or assigning specific
responsibility for managing identified
risks.
What is risk analysis primarily
concerned with in security management?
Correct answer is evaluating the nature,
impact and likelihood of identified
risks.
What is the primary characteristic of
qualitative risk analysis? It uses
numerical data and statistical methods
to quantify risk. It uses subjective
judgment and non-numerical data to
assess risk. It calculates the financial
impass impact of risk events or it
measures the probability of a risk
occurring.
The primary characteristic of
qualitative risk analysis.
Correct answer is it uses subjective
judgment and non-numerical data to
assess risk. Which of the following is
the focus of quantitative risk analysis?
It uses numerical data and measures
variables to assess risk. It focuses on
subjective assessments of risk based on
experience. It provides a general
overview of risk exposure or evaluates
potential risk events based on their
likelihood.
The focus of a quantitative risk
analysis.
Correct answer is it uses numerical data
and measurable variables to assess risk.
What does single loss expectancy or SLE
measure in risk management? The
potential financial loss resulting from
a single occurrence of a risk event, the
annual cost of protecting against a
specific risk, the expected probability
of a risk event happening over one year,
or the likelihood that a specific risk
will occur in a given time period.
Single loss expectancy in risk
management.
Correct answer is the likelihood that a
specific risk will occur in a given time
period.
What is annualized loss expectancy or AL
used to calculate the probability of a
risk event occurring in a year? The
total financial loss over a year due to
a specific risk. the total number of
times a risk event could occur annually
or the number of security incidents in a
year. Annualized loss expectancy, what
is it used to calculate?
Correct answer is the total financial
loss over a year due to a specific risk.
What does annualized rate of occurrence
or ARRO represent in risk analysis? The
projected financial loss an organization
expects to face each year from a risk.
The likelihood that a specific risk
event will occur within a single
calendar year. The number of times a
specific risk event is expected to take
place annually or the total estimated
duration that a risk event is
anticipated to persist during one year.
What does annualized rate of occurrence
or ARRO represent in risk analysis?
Correct answer is the number of times a
specific risk event is expected to take
place annually.
Which of the following best describes
probability in risk management? the
total financial loss expected from a
risk event, the monetary value of a risk
event, the mitigation cost of a risk
event, or the likelihood that a specific
risk event will occur. What describes
probability in risk management?
Correct answer is the likelihood that a
specific risk event will occur.
What is the term for the likelihood that
a risk event will happen? Exposure
factor, likelihood, risk analysis or
vulnerability.
The likelihood that a risk event will
happen.
Correct answer is likelihood.
What does exposure factor represent in
risk management? The percentage of loss
an asset is expected to incur due to a
specific risk. The estimated financial
expenditure required for implementing
appropriate security controls, the total
recorded number of successful security
breaches within a defined period of time
or the projected frequency with which a
particular risk event is likely to occur
annually. What is exposure factor
represent in risk management?
Correct answer is the percentage of loss
an asset is expected to incur due to a
specific risk.
What does impact refer to in risk
management? The estimated likelihood or
probability that a specific risk event
may actually occur. The projected
financial expenditure associated with
deploying required security controls and
safeguards. the potential consequences
or severity of a risk event on the
organization as a whole or the
anticipated length of time required to
fully recover from a security breach.
What does impact refer to in risk
management?
Correct answer is the potential
consequences or severity of a risk event
on the organization as a whole. What is
the purpose of a risk register? To
provide a comprehensive record of
organizational security policies,
standards, and documented procedures. To
document identified risks, their
potential impact on operations and the
plan mitigation strategies.
to maintain detailed records that track
the performance and effectiveness of
implemented security controls or to
record ongoing results measuring the
effectiveness of employee security
awareness initiatives.
What is the purpose of a risk register?
Correct answer is to document identified
risks, their potential impact on
operations and the planned mitigation
strategies.
What are key risk indicators or KRIS
used for? To evaluate and measure the
overall success of organizational
security awareness training programs to
track and report on the ongoing progress
of established risk mitigation
initiatives.
to provide early warning indicators of
potential risks by monitoring specific
measurable metrics or to calculate and
quantify the potential financial impact
associated with identified security
risks. What are key risk indicators or
KRIS used for?
Correct answer is to provide early
warning indicators of potential risks by
monitoring specific measurable metrics.
What is the role of a risk owner? To
oversee the organization's compliance
with data protection regulations
to be responsible for managing and
mitigation mitigating specific risks
assigned to them to ensure that security
policies are followed across the
organization or to design the
organization's overall risk management
framework. was the role of a risk owner.
Correct answer is to be responsible for
managing and mitigating specific risks
assigned to them. What does risk
threshold refer to in risk management?
The maximum level of risk an
organization is willing to accept before
taking action. The frequency at which
new risks are identified, documented,
and formally reported. The estimated
amount of time required to properly
assess and mitigate identified risks or
the structured process of calculating
the potential financial loss from a
particular risk event.
What does risk threshold refer to in
risk management?
Correct answer is the maximum level of
risk an organization is willing to
accept before taking action.
What is meant by risk tolerance? The
structured process of calculating and
evaluating the potential financial
impact of a risk event. The estimated
number of specific mitigation activities
required to sufficiently reduce a
particular risk. the maximum period of
time considered acceptable for
responding to an identified risk event
or the level of risk an organization is
willing to accept without requiring any
corrective intervention. What is meant
by risk tolerance?
Correct answer is the level of risk an
organization is willing to accept
without requiring any corrective
intervention.
What does risk appetite refer to in an
organization's security program? The
maximum level the maximum level of
organizational risk that leadership is
determined to completely avoid or
eliminate.
The organization's willingness to accept
and take on risk in pursuit of business
objectives. The specific threshold
beyond which identified risks are no
longer considered tolerable or
acceptable. Or the total financial and
operational resources allocated towards
organizational risk management
activities.
What does risk appetite refer to in an
organization's security program?
Correct answer is the organization's
willingness to accept and take on risk
in pursuit of business objectives.
What is the focus of an expansionary
riskmanagement approach? It focuses on
reducing risk by maintaining the status
quo and avoiding changes. It aims to
completely eliminate all risks to the
organization. It involves actively
taking on more risks to drive business
growth or innovation or it looks to
transfer risks to external parties. What
is the focus of an expansionary
riskmanagement approach?
Correct answer is it involves actively
taking on more risks to drive business
growth or innovation.
What does a conservative approach to
risk management prioritize?
Maximizing exposure to new risks for
business growth. Transferring all risks
to third parties to avoid internal risk
management. accepting higher levels of
risk to gain a competitive advantage or
minimi minimizing risk exposure and
focusing on risk avoidance. What is a
conservative approach to risk
management? Prioritize.
Correct answer is minimizing risk
exposure and focusing on risk avoidance.
What is a neutral riskmanagement
strategy? It balances both risk
avoidance and taking calculated risks.
It focuses on transferring all risks to
external parties. It completely
eliminates any form of risk within the
organization or it focuses on expanding
the organization's exposure to risks.
What is a neutral riskmanagement
strategy?
Correct answer is it balances both risk
avoidance and taking calculated risks.
Which of the following is a
riskmanagement strategy? Increasing the
number of stakeholders involved in
decision-m
modifying security policies without
following a structured approach.
Mitigating, transferring, accepting or
avoiding risks, or decreasing the
frequency of risk assessments.
Which of the following is a
riskmanagement strategy?
Correct answer is mitigating,
transferring, accepting or avoiding
risks.
What does risk transfer involve in risk
management? Sharing portions of the
identified risk with another party
without fully shifting responsibility.
formally accepting the identified risk
and choosing not to take mitigation
actions, moving the responsibility for
risk to a third party such as through
insurance or outsourcing or disregarding
the potential risk altogether and
continuing with business with business
operations as usual. What does risk
transfer involve in risk management?
Correct answer is moving the
responsibility for a risk to a third
party such as through insurance or
outsourcing.
What does risk acceptance mean in a
security program? Deliberately choosing
to acknowledge the risk while deciding
not to implement preventative measures.
Allowing a certain level of risk because
the cost of mitigation is too high or
the impact is low. shifting
responsibility for the identified risk
to an outside party such as a vendor or
insurer or excluding the identified risk
from any form of documented management
oversight or formal control process.
What does risk acceptance mean in a
security program?
Correct answer is allowing a certain
level of risk because the cost of
mitigation is too high or the impact is
low.
What is an exemption in risk management?
The formal process of shifting the
responsibility for a risk to an external
service provider or insurer. The inter
the intentional removal or complete
elimination of a specific risk from the
organization's overall risk profile. the
exclusion of a particular risk or
requirement from being addressed due to
a specific circumstances or conditions
or an organizational policy that allows
all identified risks to be accepted
without any additional management
action.
What is an exemption in risk management?
Correct answer is the exclusion of a
particular risk or requirement from
being addressed due to specific
circumstances or conditions.
What does a risk exception refer to in a
security program? A special situation
where a risk specific risk is formally
not addressed according to standard
procedures or controls. The complete
elimination and removal of all
identified risks from the organization's
operating environment. the mitigation of
an identified risk by formally
transferring responsibility to an
external vendor or partner or an
established process that allows the
organization to fully accept all
identified risks without further
mitigation.
What does a risk exception refer to in a
security program?
Correct answer is a special situation
where a specific risk is formally not
addressed according to standard
procedures or controls.
What does it mean to avoid a risk in
risk management? Taking steps to reduce
the impact of the risk, choosing not to
engage in activities that could
introduce the risk, transferring the
risk to another party, or accepting the
risk because the cost of mitigation is
too high. What does it mean to avoid a
risk in risk management?
Correct answer is choosing not to engage
in activities that could introduce the
risk. What is the goal of mitigating a
risk? To eliminate the risk entirely, to
ignore the risk and focus on other
priorities, to transfer the risk to an
external party, or to make the potential
impact of the risk less severe? What is
the goal of mitigating a risk?
Correct answer is to make the pot
potential impact of the risk less
severe.
What is the primary purpose of risk
reporting? To track and document all
identified risks along with their
potential impacts and plan mitigation
strategies to evaluate and measure the
overall performance and effectiveness of
deployed security technologies. to
generate detailed reports that monitor
employee compliance with established
security rules and policies or to
analyze and interpret organizational
financial data related to security costs
and investments. was the primary purpose
of risk reporting.
Correct answer is to track and document
all identified risks along with their
potential impacts and planned mitigation
strategies.
What is the primary focus of a business
impact analysis or BIA? to evaluate and
measure the overall financial
performance and efficiency of
organizational security programs. To
identify and assess the potential
effects that disruptions may have on
business operations and processes.
to track and analyze the effectiveness
of documented disaster recovery and
continuity planning activities or to
perform a structured costbenefit
analysis when considering potential
investments in security safeguards.
Who is the primary focus of a business
impact analysis or BIA?
The correct answer is to identify and
assess the potential effects that
disruptions may have on business
operations and processes.
What does the recovery time objective or
RTO refer to in disaster recovery
planning? The maximum allowable time
before data is lost during a disaster,
the total time it takes to restore IT
systems after an outage. the maximum
allowable downtime for critical systems
and services or the time required to
fully recover from a disaster and resume
operations.
What is the recovery time objective or
RTO refer to in disaster recovery
planning?
Correct answer is the time required to
fully recover from a disaster and resume
operations.
What is the recovery point objective or
RPO in disaster recovery? The time it
takes to recover business operations
after a disaster, the minimum time
required to restore systems from backup.
The maximum amount of data loss an
organization can tolerate during an
outage or the total downtime that can be
tolerated by non-critical systems. What
is the recovery point objective or RPO
in disaster recovery?
Correct answer is the maximum amount of
data loss an organization can tolerate
during an outage.
What does mean time to repair or MTTR
measure in system recovery? The average
time it takes to detect a failure and
initiate recovery efforts. The average
time it takes to fully restore a system
after a failure. the average time
between system failures or the total
downtime caused by system failures. What
does mean time to repair or MTR measure
in system recovery?
Correct answer is the average time it
takes to fully restore a system after a
failure. What is meanantime between
failures or MTBF?
The average time it takes to repair a
system after a failure, the total time
it takes to recover from system
failures, the total downtime caused by
recurring system failures, or the
average time between system failures
before a repair is needed. What is
meanantime between failures or MTBF?
Correct answer is the average time
between system failures before a repair
is needed.
What is the primary purpose of a vendor
assessment in security management? To
evaluate a vendor's financial stability,
to assess a vendor's ability to meet
contractual obligations, to evaluate the
security posture and risk mitigation
measures of a vendor, or to ensure that
a vendor meets environmental compliance
standards. What is the primary purpose
of a vendor assessment in security
management?
Correct answer is to evaluate the
security posture and risk mitigation
measures of a vendor.
What is the primary goal of penetration
testing in security? To evaluate the
effectiveness and thoroughess of the
organization's vulnerability management
processes and controls.
to assess how well the organization's
established security policies and
procedures are being properly
implemented. To identify and actively
exploit vulnerabilities in systems in
order to evaluate security weaknesses or
to review and measure the effectiveness
of organizational security awareness and
training programs for employees. What is
the primary goal of penetration testing
in security?
Correct answer is to identify and
actively exploit vulnerabilities in
systems to or in order to evaluate
security weaknesses.
What is the purpose of including a right
to audit clause in a contract to provide
the vendor with authority to formally
audit the organization's financial
statements and accounting records? To
ensure the company can perform audits on
the vendor's compliance with agreed
security standards and requirements,
to enable independent third parties to
conduct periodic audits of internal
company policies and operating
procedures, or to grant employees
organizational access to the results of
external or internal audit findings and
reports with the purpose of including a
right to audit clause in a contract.
Correct answer is to ensure the company
can perform audits on the vendor's
compliance with agreed security
standards and requirements.
What type of documentation serves as
evidence of internal audits? Audit logs
and records of audit findings, system
performance reports, customer service
feedback surveys, or vendor contracts
and agreements? What type of
documentation serves as evidence of
internal audits?
Correct answer is audit logs and records
of audit findings.
What is an independent assessment in
security management? A security
assessment conducted by the internal IT
department. An internal evaluation by
the organization security team. A
penetration test performed by the vendor
security team or security review
performed by an external thirdparty
auditor.
What is an independent assessment in
security management?
Correct answer is a security review
performed by an external third party
auditor.
What is the purpose of supply chain
analysis in security management? To
evaluate the overall financial stability
and long-term reliability of
organizational suppliers and
contractors. To assess risks introduced
by suppliers and their vendors
throughout the security supply chain
environment. To ensure compliance with
applicable environmental and regulatory
requirements across all levels of the
supply chain or to identify and document
potential cost-saving opportunities in
the procurement and distribution supply
chain process. What is the purpose of
supply chain analysis in security
management?
Correct answer is to assess risks
introduced by suppliers and their
vendors throughout the security supply
chain environment.
Which factor is most important when
selecting a vendor in a security
context? The vendor's ability to
consistently provide the lowest possible
price for services or products. the
vendor's physical proximity and
convenient location relative to the
organization's headquarters office, the
vendors demonstrated compliance with
established security standards and
formal risk management practices, or the
vendor's internal employee benefits
package, including healthcare leave
policies and retirement programs. Which
factor is most important when selecting
a vendor in security context?
Correct answer is the vendor's
demonstrated compliance with established
security standards and formal risk
management practices.
What is the goal of due diligence in
vendor management? To ensure that the
vendor's employees have sufficient
security certifications to assess the
vendor's financial health and
operational cap capabilities to evaluate
the vendor's historical performance in
delivering services or to identify and
assess potential risks before entering
into a contract. What is the goal of due
diligence in vendor management?
Correct answer is to identify and assess
potential risks before entering into a
contract.
What is a conflict of interest in vendor
relationships? A situation where a
vendor receives direct financial gain as
a result of security breach. A situation
where a vendor has personal interest
that could improperly influence their
decisions or actions. A situation where
a vendor provides contracted services
that fall outside their proven expert
area of expertise. or situation where a
vendor deliberately refuses to comply
with established organizational security
requirements. Was a conflict of interest
in vendor relationships?
Correct answer is a situation where a
vendor has a personal interest that
could improperly influence their
decisions or actions.
Why is vendor monitoring important in a
security program? To regularly assess
and review the overall financial
performance and stability of contracted
vendors. To track and measure the
quantity of products or services
delivered by each vendor. To ensure that
vendors are consistently complying with
agreed upon organizational security
practices and standards or to evaluate
and analyze the effectiveness of vendor
advertising campaigns and marketing
strategies.
Why is vendor monitoring important in a
security program?
Correct answer is to ensure that vendors
are consistently complying with agreed
upon organizational security practices
and standards.
What is the purpose of questionnaires in
vendor management? To collect and
analyze feedback from customers
regarding the overall quality of a
vendor services. to assess the vendor
security posture, regulatory compliance,
and documented risk management
practices. To evaluate and review the
vendor's logistics, supply chain
processes, and distribution
capabilities, or to determine and
compare the pricing structures of
services and products offered by the
vendor. What is the purpose of
questionnaires in vendor management?
Correct answer is to assess the vendor
security posture, regulatory compliance,
and documented riskmanagement practices.
What do rules of engagement define in a
penetration test? The document
procedures used for negotiating
contracts and agreements with thirdparty
service vendors. The established
guidelines that ensure all penetration
testing activities maintain compliance
with applicable laws. the defined scope,
limitations, and expectations agreed
upon by both the tester and the
organization or the planned schedule,
milestones, and deadlines established
for completing the overall security
testing process. What do rules of
engagement define in a penetration test?
Correct answer is the defined scope,
limitations, and expectations agreed
upon by both a tester and the
organization.
What is the purpose of an agreement type
in a security program? To formally
define the terms and conditions agreed
upon between parties engaged in a
transaction or collaboration.
To clearly outline and document the
assigned duties and responsibilities of
each organizational employee. to provide
a detailed listing of the mandatory
security controls required for
regulatory compliance or to specify the
recurring timelines, schedules and
deadlines associated with formal formal
organizational security audits. What is
the purpose of an agreement type in a
security program?
Correct answer is to formally define the
terms and conditions agreed upon between
parties engaged in a transaction or
collaboration.
What is a service level agreement or SLA
used for? To formally define the roles,
responsibilities, and obligations of
business partners in a relationship. To
outline the specific service performance
metrics, quality levels and expectations
agreed upon by both parties. to
guarantee the confidentiality and proper
handling of sensitive or proprietary
business information or to provide a
documented framework for resolving
disputes that arise between employees
and organizational management. What is a
service level agreement or SLA used for?
Correct answer is to outline these
specific service performance metrics,
quality levels, and expectations agreed
upon by both parties.
What does a memorandum of agreement or
MOA typically document? The detailed
technical specifications and
requirements associated with the design
or delivery of a project. The measurable
performance metrics and quality
standards expected from a contracted
service provider. The general
understanding and terms agreed upon by
two parties collaborating towards a
specific goal or project or the
documented ownership rights and
responsibilities regarding intellectual
property shared between two
organizations.
What does a memorandum of agreement or
MOA typically document?
Correct answer is the general
understanding and terms agreed upon by
two parties collaborating towards a
specific goal or project.
How does a memorandum of understanding
orou differ from an MOA? Anouou is a
legally binding document while MOA is
not. Anou is less formal than an MOA and
does not involve legal obligations. Anou
includes detailed technical
specifications while an MOA does not. Or
anou spec specifies performance
expectations while an MOA focuses on
confidentiality clauses. How does a
memorandum of understanding orou differ
from an MOA?
Correct answer is anou is less formal
than an MOA and does not involve legal
obligations.
What is the purpose of a master service
agreement or MSA? To establish general
terms and conditions for a long-term
relationship later governed by specific
agreements to provide detailed
guidelines and requirements that govern
the delivery of particular contracted
services. to formally outline
organizational procedures and
responsibilities for responding to
identified security incidents or to
guarantee minimum levels of performance
and availability required from a service
provider to its client. What is the
purpose of a master service agreement or
MSA?
Correct answer is to establish general
terms and conditions for a long-term
relationship later governed by specific
agreements.
What is a work order or statement of
work typically describe? The agreed
terms and contractual conditions that
govern services delivered under a
broader master agreement. The detailed
pricing structure and payment schedules
established for long-term contractual
service arrangements.
the general guidelines and procedures
that define how contracted services will
be independently audited or the specific
work or services to be performed
including timelines, responsibilities
and measurable deliverables. What does a
work order or statement of work
typically describe?
Correct answer is these specific work or
services to be performed including
timelines, responsibilities, and
measurable deliverables.
What is the primary purpose of a
non-disclosure agreement or an NDA?
to formalize the legal relationships
between vendors, to prevent the
disclosure of confidential information
between parties, to outline the security
measures required to protect
intellectual property, or to define the
expectations for customer service
performance.
What is the primary purpose of a
non-disclosure agreement or NDA?
Correct answer is to prevent the
disclosure of confidential information
between parties.
What is typically covered in a business
partners agreement or BPA? The defined
roles, responsibilities, and obligations
of each business partner engaged in a
shared project or service. The agreed
financial terms, conditions, and
contribution levels for investments
committed by each participating party.
these specific details outlining how
intellectual property rights will be
shared, licensed, and jointly managed or
the contractual terms and formal
conditions that govern the termination
of the partnership if required. What is
typically covered in a business partners
agreement or BPA?
Correct answer is the defined roles,
responsibilities and obligations of each
business partner engaged in a shared
product project or service.
What is the purpose of a compliance
reporting in a security program? To
monitor and evaluate organizational
employee productivity and overall
operational performance levels. To
measure and review the effectiveness of
security technologies and implementing
control mechanisms. to identify and
document newly discovered
vulnerabilities that may affect
organizational security posture or to
demonstrate and provide evidence of
adherence to applicable regulatory and
legal compliance requirements. What is
the purpose of compliance reporting in a
security program?
Correct answer is to demonstrate and
provide evidence or of adherence to
applicable regulatory and legal
compliance requirements.
What is the primary purpose of internal
compliance reporting? To provide
detailed reporting on the performance
and compliance practices of thirdparty
vendors and partners to deliver
structured feedback to stakeholders on
the organizational's internal security
posture and compliance status. to track
and document changes in regulatory
requirements that may impact
organizational compliance programs or to
record and monitor the behavioral
practices of employees for alignment
with corporate security policies. Was
the primary purpose of internal
compliance reporting?
Correct answer is to deliver structured
feedback to stakeholders on the
organizational's in internal security
posture and compliance status.
What is the primary purpose of external
compliance reporting? To provide reports
to external parties such as regulators
or auditors on organizational compliance
status to evaluate and analyze the
organizational's internal threat
landscape and potential security
vulnerabilities.
to review and document employee
adherence to established organizational
security policies and procedures or to
assess and report on the financial
performance and overall value of
security initiatives. What is the
primary purpose of external compliance
reporting?
Correct answer is to provide reports to
external parties such as regulators or
auditors on organizational compliance
status. What are potential consequences
of non-compliance in a security program?
Enhanced organizational security posture
resulting in greater efficiency across
business operations. A reduced
requirement for ongoing auditing
activities and continuous monitoring of
security controls, financial penalties,
significant legal repercussions, and
lasting reputational damage. or an
increase in organizational trust and
confidence from both stakeholders and
external partners. What are potential
consequences of non-compliance in a
security program?
Correct answer is financial penalties,
significant legal repercussions, and
lasting reputational damage.
Which of the following is a potential
financial consequence of non-compliance?
Loss of revenue due to damaged customer
trust, fines imposed by regulatory
enforcement agencies, higher operational
costs from inefficient processes, or
reduced access to beneficial business
partnerships?
What is a potential financial
consequence of non-compliance?
Correct answer is fines imposed by
regulatory enforcement agencies.
What are sanctions in the context of
non-compliance?
Penalties and restrictions formally
imposed by regulatory agencies or legal
authorities on organizations.
Structured training programs that are
developed and delivered to prevent
future instances of non-compliance.
incentive-based initiatives created to
encourage employees to consistently
follow established security policies or
financial reward programs designed to
recognize organizations that maintain
continuous regulatory compliance. What
are sanctions in the context of
non-compliance?
Correct answer is penalties and
restrictions formally imposed by
regulatory agencies or legal authorities
on organizations.
What is a potential reputational damage
consequence of non-compliance?
An improved organizational brand image
that enhances overall visibility in the
marketplace. A measurable increase in
customer trust and loyalty towards the
organization services. a significant
loss of consumer confidence combined
with long-term damage to brand
reputation or enhanced level of
stakeholder engagement resulting in
stronger collaborative partnerships.
There is a potential reputational damage
consequence of non-compliance.
Correct answer is a significant loss of
consumer confidence combined with
long-term damage to brand reputation.
Which of the following could result from
non-compliance in terms of business
operations? A potential loss of license
or authorization to operate within
certain industries or geographic
regions. Noticeable improvements in
overall service delivery efficiency and
organizational project completion
timelines. A measurable increase in
organizational market share along with
expansion of the customer base. or an
increase in partnership opportunities
resulting from improved credibility with
external stakeholders. Which of the
following could result from
non-compliance in terms of business
operations?
Correct answer is a potential loss of
license or authorization to operate
within certain industries or geographic
regions.
What are contractual impacts in the
context of non-compliance?
The potential loss of regulatory
licenses or certifications required to
operate within specific industries. The
termination or renegotiation of
contracts with vendors or clients
directly resulting from non-compliance.
The requirement for additional audits
and more frequent compliance assessments
imposed by oversight authorities or a
measurable reduction in operational
costs achieved through decreased
investment in compliance activities.
What are contractual impacts in the
context of non-compliance?
Correct answer is the termination or
renegotiation of contracts with vendors
or clients directly resulting from
non-compliance.
What is the primary purpose of not of
compliance monitoring in an
organization? To evaluate and measure
the overall effectiveness of
organizational security awareness
training programs. To calculate and
report on the return on investment from
implemented security tools and
solutions. To assess and monitor the
operational performance of critical
information technology infrastructure
systems or to ensure continuous
adherence to applicable regulatory
requirements and established internal
security policies. What is the primary
purpose of compliance monitoring in an
organization?
Correct answer is to ensure continuous
adherence to applicable regulatory
requirements and established internal
security policies.
What is the purpose of due diligence in
security management? to verify and
maintain the confidentiality and
protection of sensitive organizational
financial information. To ensure that
all employees consistently comply with
established organizational security
policies and standards to assess the
potential risks associated with
thirdparty vendors before establishing a
formal relationship or to provide
employees with required professional
training programs and industry
recognized technical certifications.
What is the purpose of due diligence in
security management?
Correct answer is to assess the
potential risks associated with third
party vendors before establishing a
formal relationship.
What does attestation and
acknowledgement typically involve in
security management? The process of
documenting employees understanding and
formal acceptance of established
organizational security policies. The
official approval and authorization of
an organizational security incident
response plan by senior management. The
automated system-based verification and
validation of technical security
configurations across organizational
assets or the formal review and signing
of legally binding security related
contracts and agreements with external
vendors. What does attestation and
acknowledgement typically involve in
security management?
Correct answer is the process of
documenting employees understanding and
formal acceptance of established
organizational security policies.
What is the key difference between
internal and external compliance
assessments? Internal assessments are
conducted by independent thirdparty
auditors while external assessments are
completed by the organization itself.
Internal assessments are primarily
focused on evaluating customer
satisfaction while external assessments
examine technical security issues.
Internal assessments are limited to
organizational financial audits while
external assessments are strictly
technical security audits or internal
assessments review internal processes.
External assessments evaluate compliance
with external regulations and
contractual obligations.
What is the key difference between
internal and external compliance
assessments?
Correct answer is internal assessments
review internal processes. External
assessments evaluate compliance with
external regulations and contractual
obligations.
Which statement best describes the
purpose of an internal compliance audit
within an organization? It helps
validate internal processes against
regulatory frameworks and policies. It
is performed solely to determine the
financial profitability of a company. It
focuses exclusively on competitor
analysis and market performance reviews
or is used to primar used primarily to
evaluate supplier contracts for pricing
and terms. What statement best describes
the purpose of an internal compliance
audit within an organization?
Correct answer is it helps validate
internal processes against regulatory
frameworks and policies.
What is the primary role of an internal
audit committee in an organization?
to oversee financial reports and
coordinate shareholder dividend
schedules
to ensure in audit independence and
monitor organizational control
activities
to evaluate competitor pricing
strategies and recommend marketing
tactics or to manage day-to-day
operations and approve individual
project budgets. What is the primary
role of an internal audit committee in
an organization?
Correct answer is to ensure audit
independence and monitor organizational
control activities.
What is the main benefit of conducting
an internal self assessment within an
organization? It allows the organization
to identify gaps and controls before
external audits. It ensures that
customer feedback surveys are fully
aligned with sales goals. It provides
marketing teams with detailed insights
into competitor pricing or it confirms
that vendors deliver products within
approved shipment windows. What is the
main benefit of conducting an internal
self assessment within an organization?
Correct answer is it allows the
organization to identify gaps in
controls before external audits. What is
the main purpose of an external
regulatory audit for an organization? To
analyze competitor growth trends and
identify new market strategies. To
review customer loyalty surveys and
create promotional campaigns to track
employee attendance rates and improve
weekly time sheets or to evaluate
organizational compliance with laws and
industry regulations.
What is the main purpose of an external
regulatory audit for an organization?
Correct answer is to evaluate
organizational compliance with laws and
industry regulations.
Why might an organization undergo an
external examination of its operations?
To evaluate financial profitability and
determine dividend payout schedules, to
gain independent validation of
compliance with external requirements,
to measure sales team performance and
quarterly product distribution goals, or
to plan staff training programs and
assign mandatory workshop attendance.
Why might an organization undergo an
external examination of its operations?
Correct answer is to gain independent
validation of compliance with external
requirements.
What is the key purpose of an external
assessment within cyber security audits?
To develop internal security policies
for employee access control management,
to monitor real-time network traffic for
potential cyber security threat
detection. to provide an unbiased
evaluation of security posture by
outside parties or to implement employee
cyber security training programs for
organizational threat awareness. What is
the key purpose of an external
assessment within cyber security audits?
Correct answer is to provide an unbiased
evaluation of security posture by
outside parties.
What is a key advantage of using an
external independent thirdparty audit?
It provides objective validation of
compliance without internal bias. It
develops internal policies for cyber
security risk management. It monitors
network traffic for real-time threat
detection or implements employee
training for cyber security protocol
adherence.
What is a key advantage of using an
external independent third-party audit?
Correct answer is it provides objective
validation of compliance without
internal bias. Why would an organization
conduct conduct a physical penetration
test? to evaluate cyber security
policies for internal network access
controls, to monitor employee compliance
with organizational cyber security
training requirements, to assess
performance of network security
appliances and firewalls, or to test the
effectiveness of locks, barriers, and
access procedures.
Why would an organization conduct a
physical penetration test?
Correct answer is to test the
effectiveness of locks, barriers, and
access procedures.
What is the primary focus of offensive
penetration testing in cyber security?
To proactively identify and exploit
vulnerabilities before attackers do, to
monitor network traffic for real-time
cyber threat detection. to develop
employee training for cyber security
policy compliance or to evaluate
performance of network security
appliances regularly. What is the
primary focus of offensive penetration
testing in cyber security?
Correct answer is to proactively
identify and exploit vulnerabilities
before attackers do. What is the primary
objective of defensive penetration
testing in cyber security? To develop
policies for internal cyber security
risk management to validate security
controls by analyzing simulated attack
attempts. to monitor network traffic for
real-time threat identification or to
implement training programs for employee
cyber security awareness. What is the
primary objective of defensive
penetration testing in cyber security?
Correct answer is to validate security
controls by analyzing simulated attack
attempts. What is the main goal of
integrated penetration testing in an
organization? To evaluate how multiple
security layers respond to coordinated
attack scenarios. To develop internal
policies for managing cyber security
risks across organizational systems. To
monitor network performance metrics for
optimizing cyber security threat
detection capabilities or to implement
employee training programs for enhancing
cyber security awareness and compliance.
What is the main goal of integrated
penetration testing in an organization?
Correct answer is to evaluate how
multiple security layers respond to
coordinated attack scenarios.
What best describes known environment
penetration testing? It simulates
attacks without knowledge of internal
system architecture. It requires testers
having prior awareness of system
architecture and controls. It evaluates
employees familiarities with the cyber
security environment they're working in
or test simulates simulated attacks with
publicly known large-scale environments
such as Fortune 500 companies. What best
describes known environment penetration
testing?
Correct answer is it requires testers
having prior awareness of system
architecture and controls. What is the
primary characteristic of partially
known environment penetration testing?
Testers have no prior knowledge of the
system under evaluation at all. Testers
are provided with limited information
about systems or controls. Testers fully
understand every internal process and
configuration detail or testers have
partial knowledge of the testing
parameters beforehand. Full details are
provided mid test.
The primary characteristic of partially
known environment penetration testing.
Correct answer is testers are provided
with limited information about systems
or controls.
What best describes unknown environment
penetration testing? Testers have no
access to internal network and
configuration details. Testers have no
prior knowledge of the industry
regulations of the systems they're
testing. Testers conduct assessments
without prior knowledge or of systems or
defenses. Or testers are unaware of
which environment they'll be testing
until the test begins.
What best describes unknown environment
penetration testing.
Correct answer is testers conduct
assessments without prior knowledge of
systems or defenses.
Why would a penetration tester perform
passive reconnaissance? To simulate a
real attacker gathering data without
alerting defenders, to analyze network
traffic for real-time cyber security
threat identification. To evaluate
internal security policies for
compliance with regulations, or to map
system architecture using active scans
of network defenses.
Why would a penetration tester perform
passive reconnaissance?
Correct answer is to simulate a real
attacker gathering data without alerting
defenders.
What defines the core trait of active
reconnaissance in penetration testing?
It gathers data without interacting with
systems or defenses. It involves direct
interaction with systems to gather
detailed information. It evaluates
compliance with internal cyber security
policies and standards where it monitors
network traffic for real-time cyber
security threat detection. Where defines
the core trait of active reconnaissance
in penetration testing.
Correct answer is it involves direct
interaction with systems to gather
detailed information.
What is the core objective of fishing
campaigns in security awareness
training? To develop internal policies
for cyber security incident response and
mitigation. To monitor employee
compliance with organizational cyber
security policies and procedures. To
evaluate employee ability to detect and
report simulated fishing attempts or to
assess network defenses against
real-time fishing and malware threats.
What is the core objective of fishing
campaigns in security awareness
training?
Correct answer is to evaluate employee
ability to detect and report simulated
fishing attempts.
Which sign most likely indicates a
fishing attempt in an email message? The
sender address is slightly altered to
mimic a trusted domain name. The message
is from a known contact that's currently
on vacation. The email urges you to sign
into a corporate portal using your login
and password or the subject line
consists of fear-based wording to create
a sense of urgency. What sign most
likely indicates a fishing attempt in an
email message?
Correct answer is the sender address is
slightly altered to mimic a trusted
domain name. How should an organization
respond after receiving multiple reports
of the same fishing attempt? Instruct
employees to mark the message as safe to
reduce false alarms. Update security
filters and notify staff about the
ongoing fishing threat. Encourage
employees to reply to the sender for
verification purposes or remove all
suspicious emails from the system
without documenting them. How should an
organization respond after receiving
multiple reports of the same fishing
attempt?
Correct answer is update security
filters and notify staff about the
ongoing fishing threat. What should
employees be trained to identify as
risky anomalous behavior? Authorized
access to secure systems during peak
operational business hours. Routine
password updates compliant with
organizational cyber security policy
mandates.
scheduled security scans initiated by
authorized IT personnel nightly or
unexpected access to sensitive files at
odd times without valid reasons. What
should employees be trained to identify
as risky anomalous behavior?
Correct answer is unexpected access to
sensitive files at odd times without
valid reasons.
What must security awareness training
prioritize for identifying critical
anomalous behavior? Logins from
unfamiliar devices or locations without
business justification,
authorized login during maintenance
windows by designed by designated IT
personnel, scheduled data backups
executed nightly by automated security
systems, or continuous multiffactor
authentication prompts triggered by
access policies. What must security
awareness training prioritize for
identifying critical anomalous behavior?
Correct answer is login from unfamiliar
devices or locations without business
justification.
Which scenario best exemplifies
unintentional anomalous behavior by an
employee? An employee deliberately
shares sensitive data with unauthorized
external parties. An employee
accidentally emails sensitive files to
the wrong recipient. An employee
routinely logs into systems during
authorized business hours or an employee
intentionally bypass security controls
to access restricted files. What
scenario best exemplifies unintentional
anomalous behavior by an employee?
Correct answer is an employee
accidentally emails sensitive files to
the wrong recipient. Why should
organizations train employees using
policy and guidance handbooks? To guide
implementation of technical cyber
security controls across systems to
monitor adherence to real-time network
security protocols daily to ensure
consistent understanding of security
rules and responsibilities or to
evaluate employee performance during
cyber security incident response drills.
Why should organizations train employees
using policy and guidance handbooks?
Correct answer is to ensure consistent
understanding of security rules and
responsibilities.
What is the primary goal of situational
awareness training for users? To ensure
employees recognize potential threats
and respond appropriately, to enforce
compliance with internal cyber security
policies and procedures, to monitor
real-time network activity for immediate
threat detection, or to implement
technical security controls across
organizational systems daily is the
primary goal of situational awareness
training for users.
Correct answer is to ensure employees
recognize potential threats and respond
appropriately.
Why is insider threat awareness training
important for an organization? It guides
staff in implementing technical cyber
security controls organizationwide.
It trains employees to monitor real-time
network security incidents. It teaches
staff to enforce compliance with cyber
security policies or ensures staff
understand how to spot unusual access or
misuse of data. Why is insider threat
awareness training important for an
organization?
Correct answer is it ensures staff
understand how to spot unusual access or
misuse of data.
What is a key principle employees should
follow for secure password management?
Use unique and complex passwords for
different systems and accounts. Store
passwords and encrypted files with
thirdparty password managers. Use
memorable passwords updated regularly
but reused across trusted systems or
enable multiffactor authentication while
using simple passwords for convenience
was a key principle employees should
follow for secure password management.
Correct answer is use unique and complex
passwords for different systems and
accounts. What defines the critical
focus of training for secure removable
media use? Scan removable media with
approved antivirus before connecting to
systems. Use only authorized removable
media that is encrypted and improved.
Share encrypted removable media only
with trusted internal team members. or
connect removable media to isolated
systems with relaxed security policies.
What defines the critical focus of
training for secure removable media use?
Correct answer is only use authorized
removal media that is encrypted and
approved. What defines the critical
action for social engineering defense
training? Forward urgent executive
emails to it for immediate security
review. Respond to verified colleague
requests with temporary account
credentials. Open attachment from
trusted sources after antivirus scanning
completes or verify suspicious requests
for sensitive information before
responding. What defines the critical
action for social engineering defense
training?
Correct answer is verify suspicious
requests for sensitive information
before responding.
What defines the critical focus of
operational security awareness training?
Sharing encrypted files with colleagues
via approved collaboration platforms
using personal devices for work with
enabled antivirus protection. following
procedures that protect sensitive
information in daily activities or
storing work data on approved devices
without encryption safeguards.
What defines the critical focus of
operational security awareness training?
Correct answer is following procedures
that protect sensitive information in
daily activities.
What is a best practice for employees
working in hybrid or remote
environments? Use secure VPN connections
when accessing company systems remotely.
Access company systems via encrypted
Wi-Fi on approved devices. Share
sensitive files using encrypted personal
cloud storage services or run endpoint
security scans only during non-working
hours remotely. What is the best
practice for employees working in hybrid
or remote environments?
Correct answer is use secure VPN
connections when accessing company
systems remotely.
What should employees do first when
noticing a potential security incident?
Monitor the event to assess impact
before reporting to management.
Investigate the incident independently
using approved internal diagnostic
tools. immediately report the event
through the organization's official
channels or notify colleagues via email
to coordinate an immediate response.
What should employees do first when
noticing a potential security incident?
Correct answer is immediately report the
event through the organization's
official channels.
Why is recurring monitoring emphasized
in security awareness programs? To
identify repeated suspicious behaviors
that may indicate emerging risks to
track compliance with cyber security
policies during routine employee
activities. To monitor network
performance metrics for optimizing
real-time threat detection or to assess
employee training effectiveness through
periodic cyber security knowledge tests.
Why is recurring monitoring emphasized
in security awareness programs?
Correct answer is to identify repeated
suspicious behaviors that may indicate
emerging risks.
What is the purpose of developing a
security awareness program within an
organization? To enforce compliance with
technical cyber security controls across
systems to monitor real-time employee
adherence to organizational security
policies.
to implement automated threat detection
systems for network protection or to
provide structured training that
improves user recognition of threats.
What is the purpose of developing a
security awareness program within an
organization?
Correct answer is to provide structured
training that improves user recognition
of threats.
What does execution of a security
awareness program primarily involve?
Implementing technical controls to
secure systems and network
infrastructure. Delivering training
sessions and applying policies to daily
operations. Monitoring employee
compliance with cyber security protocols
during routine tasks or evaluating
incident response effectiveness through
simulated cyber security attack drills.
What does execution of a security
awareness program primarily involve?
[Music]
Correct answer is delivering training
sessions and applying policies to daily
operations.
First question, what does AAA stand for
in the context of security? Access
authorization and auditing,
accountability, authentication and
auditing, authentication, authorization
and accounting or authentication access
and auditing. What does AAA stand for in
the context of security?
Correct answer is authentication,
authorization and accounting.
What is the meaning of ACL in security
terminology? Access code list, access
control list, authorization control list
or authenticated authenticated command
list. The meaning of ACL.
Correct answer is access control list.
What does AES stand for in cryptography?
Automated encryption system, asymmetric
encryption standard, advanced
incipherment standard, or advanced
encryption standard. What does AEES
stand for in cryptography?
Correct answer is advanced encryption
standard.
What is represented by AES 256 in
encryption standards? Advanced
encryption standard 256-bit,
advanced encryption scheme 256-bit,
authenticated encryption standard
256-bit or asymmetric encryption
standard 256-bit.
What does AES 256 mean?
Correct answer is advanced encryption
standard 256bit.
In network security, what does ah stand
for? Authenticated handshake,
authentication header, authorization
header, or access header? Network
security. What does ah stand for?
Correct answer is authentication header.
Which of the following correctly defines
AI in modern technology?
Automated interaction,
algorithmic interaction, analytical
implementation, or artificial
intelligence?
Which of the following correctly defines
AI in modern technology?
Correct answer is artificial
intelligence.
What does AIS stand for in the context
of cyber security threat sharing?
Advanced intrusion sharing,
authenticated indicator system,
automated indicator sharing or automated
intrusion sharing. What does AIS stand
for in the context of cyber security
threat sharing?
Correct answer is automated indicator
sharing.
What does AL represent when assessing
potential security risks? Annualized
loss expectancy, average loss
estimation, annualized liability
evaluation, or actual loss expectation.
What does AL represent when assessing
potential security risks?
Correct answer is annualized loss
expectancy.
In wireless networking, what does AP
commonly refer to? Authorized port,
access point, application portal, or
access port, access protocol. In
wireless networking, what does AP
commonly refer to?
Correct answer is access point.
What does API stand for in software
development? Application program
interaction, automated process
interface, application programming
interface, or advanced protocol
interface?
What does API stand for in software
development?
Correct answer is application
programming interface.
What is the full form of AP and cyber
security terminology? Advanced
persistent threat, authorized
penetration test, advanced fishing
tactic or active prevention technique is
the full form of AP in cyber security
terminology.
Correct answer is advanced persistent
threat.
What does ARRO mean in the context of
risk management? Annualized return on
operation, annualized rate of
occurrence, average rate of occurrence,
or automated rate of occurrence. What
does ARRO mean in the context of risk
management?
Correct answer is annualized rate of
occurrence in networking. What is the
correct meaning of ARP? Authorization
res resolution protocol, access request
protocol, address routing process or
address resolution protocol. What is the
correct meaning of ARP?
Correct answer is address resolution
protocol.
What does ASLR stand for in modern
operating system security? Address
security link randomization, authorized
space level randomization,
address space layout randomization, or
access secure level randomization. What
does ASLR stand for in modern operating
system security?
Correct answer is address space layout
randomization.
What does ATT and CK stand for in the
context of cyber security? Advanced
threat tactics, common knowledge and
skills.
Adversarial tactics, techniques, and
common knowledge, adversary threat
techniques and cryptography or
authenticated tactics, techniques and
cryptography. What does ATT and CK stand
for in the context of cyber security?
Correct answer is adversarial tactics,
techniques and common knowledge. What
does AUP represent in organizational
security policy? Authorized use
protocol, actual usage policy,
acceptable use policy or access usage
procedure.
Does AUP represent an organizational
security policy?
Correct answer is acceptable use policy.
In endpoint security, what does AV stand
for? Anti virus, audio verification,
automated validation, or access viewer.
In endpoint security, what does AV stand
for?
Correct answer is anti virus
in Unix based systems. What does bash
stand for? Basic automated shell, born
and shell, binary application shell, or
born again shell
in Unix based systems. What does bash
stand for?
Correct answer is born again shell.
In risk management, what does BCP refer
to? Business compliance program,
business continuity planning, backup
recovery plan, or business control
procedures. In risk management, what
does BCP refer to?
Correct answer is business continuity
planning. What is the full form of BGP
in network routing? Basic gateway
protocol, broadband gateway procedure,
border gateway protocol or balanced
gateway process. There's a full form of
BGP in network routing.
Correct answer is border gateway
protocol
in business risk management. What does
BIA stand for? Business impact analysis,
business investment assessment, baseline
impact analysis, or budget impact
analysis?
Business risk management. What does BIA
stand for?
correct answer is business impact
analysis
in computer hardware. What is BIOS an
acronym for? Binary input output
software, basic integrated operating
system, built-in operating system, or
basic input output system. What is BIOS
an acronym for?
Correct answer is basic input output
system.
In corporate context, what does BPA
typically refer to? business process
analysis, business partners agreement,
best practice assessment, or business
performance agreement. What does BPA
typically refer to?
Correct answer is business partners
agreement in networking. What does BPDU
stand for? Binary protocol data utility,
bridge packet distribution unit, bridge
protocol data unit, or basic protocol
data unit. What does BPDU stand for?
Correct answer is bridge protocol data
unit.
What does B YOD mean in modern workplace
policies? Bring your own device, build
your own device, bring your office
device, or bring your own data. What
does BYOD mean in modern workplace
policies?
Correct answer is bring your own device.
In the context of IT security, what does
CA stand for? Certificate authority,
computer access, critical authority, or
certificate analyzer? What does CA stand
for?
Correct answer is certificate authority.
What does capture stand for in cyber
security? Computer automated password
Turing challenge. Completely automated
public touring test to tell computers
and human apart. Compulsory automated
program to test computers or completely
automated program to test computer
algorithms.
What does capture stand for in cyber
security?
Correct answer is completely automated
public touring test to tell computers
and humans apart
within incident response documentation.
What does CR C represent? Critical
analysis report, computer audit record,
corrective action report, or compliance
assessment report? What does C
represent?
Correct answer is corrective action
report. What does CASB stand for in
cloud security solutions? Cloud
application security base, computer
access security base, cloud application
service broker or cloud access security
broker. What does CASB stand for in
cloud security solutions?
Correct answer is cloud access security
broker. In encryption methods, what does
CBC refer to? Cipher blockchaining,
cipher block check, code blockchaining,
or cipher batch chain. What does CBC
refer to?
Correct answer is cipher blockchaining.
Which term describes CCMP in wireless
security? Counter check and MAC
protocol, counter mode CBC MAC protocol,
counter mode coding MAC protocol or
cipher mode CC MAC protocol. Which term
describes CCMP in wireless security?
Correct answer is counter mode CBC MAC
protocol.
What is the full form of CCTV as used in
security systems? Centralized control
television, computerized camera
television, closed circuit television or
comprehensive control television which
is the full form of CCTV in security
systems.
Correct answer is closed circuit
television. In the context of cyber
security incident response teams, what
does CIRT or CERT stand for?
Computerized emergency recovery team,
cyber emergency response team, critical
emergency rescue team, or computer
emergency response team. What does cert
stand for?
Correct answer is computer emergency
response team in cryptographic feedback
modes. What does CFB mean? cipher
feedback, coded feedback, cascading
feedback, or critical feedback.
In cryptographic feedback modes, what
does CFB mean?
>> Correct answer is cipher feedback.
What does CHAP or CHAP stand for in
network authentication protocols?
Controlled handshake authentication
protocol, continuous handshake
authentication protocol, challenge
handshake authentication protocol or
comprehensive handshake authentication
process. What does CHAP or CHAP stand
for?
Correct answer is challenge handshake
authentication protocol
in information security. What does CIA
represent? Confidentiality integrity and
availability control integrity uh
control integrity and accessibility.
Confidentiality identification and
assurance or control identification and
accessibility. What does CIA represent?
Correct answer is confidentiality,
integrity and availability.
What does CIO stand for in the context
of organizational leadership? Computer
information organizer, chief information
or officer, corporate information
operator or centralized information
organizer. What does CIO stand for in
the context of organizational
leadership?
Correct answer is chief information
officer.
Which term best describes CERT or CIR in
the realm of cyber security incident
management? Computer investigation
response team, cyber security incident
recovery team, critical incident
response team or computer incident
response team. Which term best describes
CIR in the realm of cyber security
incident management?
Correct answer is computer incident
response team
in digital content management. What does
CMS stand for? Content management
software, content media system, content
management system, or centralized media
service. in digital content management.
What does CMS stand for?
Correct answer is content management
system.
What does co-op or COP represent in
continuity planning? Contingency
operations plan, continuity of operation
planning, corporate operational outreach
plan or central operations overhaul
plan. What does co-op represent in
continuity planning?
Correct answer is continuity of
operation planning.
In device management strategies, what
does cope or cop
stand for? Corporateowned,
organizational, provided, companyowned,
personally managed, corporate,
organized, personally enabled, or
corporateowned, personally enabled. What
does COPE or COP stand for?
Correct answer is corporateowned
personally enabled.
What does CP refer to in the context of
organizational risk management?
Contingency planning, crisis prevention,
critical procedures, or contingency
protocol. What does CP refer to in the
context of organizational risk
management?
correct answer is contingency planning.
What does CRC stand for when discussing
error checking methods? Coded redundancy
check, cyclic redundancy check, cyclical
redundancy check, or continuous
redundancy code. What does CRC stand for
when discussing error checking methods?
Correct answer is cyclical redundancy
check. What does CRL mean in the context
of digital certificate management?
Certificate revocation ledger,
certificate revocation list, certificate
reissue log or certified revocation
ledger. What does CRL mean in the
context of digital certificate
management?
Correct answer is certificate revocation
list.
Which of the following best defines CSO
in corporate security leadership? Chief
security officer, corporate security
organizer, central security overseer or
cyber security officer,
which best defines CSO in corporate
security leadership.
Correct answer is chief security
officer.
What does CSP stand for in cloud
computing? Cloud security program, cloud
system provider, cloud service provider
or cloud software provider. What does
CSP stand for in cloud computing?
Correct answer is cloud service
provider. In certificate management,
what does CSR represent? Certificate
security request, certificate signing
request, certified signature request, or
computer system request. In certificate
management, what does CSR represent?
Correct answer is certificate signing
request.
Which term defines CSRF in web
application security? Cross-system
request framework, clientside request
forgery, cross-sight resource function
or cross-sight request forgery.
Which term defines CSRF in web
application security?
Correct answer is cross site request
forgery.
What does CSU refer to in networking
equipment? channel service unit,
centralized system unit, circuit
switching unit or computer service
utility. What does CSU refer to in
networking equipment?
Correct answer is channel service unit.
In encryption modes, what does CTM stand
for? computed timing mechanism, counter
mode, control transmission mode, or
cipher text masking technique.
What does CTM stand for?
Correct answer is counter mode.
In corporate leadership, what does CTO
denote? Chief Technical Officer, Central
Technology Operator, Chief Technology
Officer or Corporate Technical
Organizer. What does CTO denote?
Correct answer is Chief Technology
Officer.
What is the full form of CVE in
vulnerability management? Common
vulnerability evaluation,
computer vulnerability event, cyber
vulnerability enumeration or common
vulnerability enumeration.
What does CVE mean in vulnerability
management?
Correct answer is common vulnerability
enumeration.
Which acronym represents CVsS?
Common vulnerability scoring system,
cyber security vulnerability scoring
standard, common virus scanning system,
or critical vulnerability severity
scale. Which acronym represents CVSS?
Correct answer is common vulnerability
scoring system. What does C YOD mean in
the context of device management
policies? Choose your own desktop,
choose your own device, choose your own
data, or customize your own device. What
does C YOD mean in the context of device
management policies?
Correct answer is choose your own
device. In access control, what does DAC
stand for? Distributed access control,
direct authorization control,
discretionary access control, or digital
access check. What does DAC stand for?
Correct answer is discretionary access
control.
What does DBA represent in database
management? Database analyst, database
associate, data backup administrator, or
database administrator. What does DBA
represent in database management?
Correct answer is database
administrator.
What does DD do or DDOS stand for in
cyber security? Distributed data over
systems, digital denial of service,
distributed denial of service, or
dynamic denial of service. What does
DDoS or DDOS stand for in cyber
security?
Correct answer is distributed denial of
service
in system security. What does DP
represent? Data encryption protocol,
data execution prevention, direct
execution process or disk encryption
protection. What does DP represent?
Correct answer is data execution
prevention.
Which of the following is the correct
full form of dees? Data encryption
standard, digital encoding standard,
dual encryption system, or digital
encryption standard.
What is the correct form of dees?
Correct answer is digital encryption
standard. What does DHCP stand for in
networking? Dynamic host configuration
protocol, data host connection process,
direct host communication protocol, or
digital host configuration procedure.
What does DHCP stand for in networking?
Correct answer is dynamic host
configuration protocol
in cryptographic key exchanges. What
does DHE mean? Dynamic hash exchange
data handling encryption, digital host
ephemeral or diffy helman ephemeral
in cryptographic key exchanges. What
does DH mean?
Correct answer is Diffy Helman
ephemeral.
Which is the following? Which of the
following is the correct expansion for
DKIM?
Domain key internet mail, domain key
identified mail, data keys in mail, or
digital keys for internet messaging.
Which of the following is the correct
expansion for DKIM?
Correct answer is domain keys identified
mail.
What does DLL stand for in software
libraries? Dynamic link library, direct
loading library, dynamic load list, or
data link loader. What does DLL stand
for in software libraries?
Correct answer is dynamic link library
in data protection. What does DLP stand
for? Digital loss prevention, data
leakage protocol,
data loss prevention or direct loss
protection.
in in data protection. What does DLP
stand for?
Correct answer is data loss prevention.
What does demark stand for in email
authentication?
Domain message authentication report and
conformance. Domainbased mail
authentication reporting and
conformance. Digital mail authentication
reporting and control or domain message
authentication reporting and
conformance. What does demark stand for
in email authentication?
Correct answer is domain message
authentication reporting and
conformance.
In network address translation, what
does DNA refer to? Dynamic network
address translation,
destination network address translation,
distributed network address translation,
or data network address translation.
What does DNA refer to?
Correct answer is destination network
address translation.
Which term describes the DNS in internet
infrastructure? Domain name system,
digital name server, data name system or
domain navigation service? Which term
describes the DNS in internet
infrastructure?
Correct answer is domain name system.
What does DOSS stand for in cyber
security attacks? Distributed operation
service, digital overflow service,
denial of service or direct operation
shutdown. What does DOS or DOS stand for
in cyber security attacks?
Correct answer is denial of service. In
organizational roles, what does DPO
stand for? Data protection organizer,
data privacy officer, digital protection
operator, or data process overseer. In
organizational roles, what does DPO
stand for?
Correct answer is data privacy officer.
What does DRP stand for in business
continuity planning? Data recovery
procedure, disaster reinstallation
process, disaster recovery plan, or data
reproduction plan. What does DRP stand
for in business continuity planning?
Correct answer is disaster recovery
plan. What does DSA represent in digital
security? Data security algorithm,
digital signature algorithm, digital
secure application or distributed
signature authority. What does DSA
represent in digital security?
Correct answer is digital signature
algorithm in networking. What does DSL
stand for? Data service link, digital
service line, digital subscriber line,
or direct subscriber link. In
networking, what does DSL stand for?
Correct answer is digital subscriber
line.
What does EAP stand for in the
authentication protocols? Encrypted
access protocol, extended authorization
protocol, enhanced authentication
process or extensible authentication
protocol. What does EAP stand for in
authentication protocols?
The correct answer is extensible
authentication protocol.
In encryption modes, what does ECB stand
for? Electronic code book, encrypted
communication block, electronic cipher
block, or enhanced code block. In
encryption modes, what does ECB stand
for?
Correct answer is electronic code book.
What is the full form of ECC in modern
cryptography? Encrypted curve
calculation, elliptic curve
cryptography, elliptic cipher computing
or extended curve cryptography.
Was the full form of ECC in modern
cryptography?
Correct answer is elliptic curve
cryptography.
What does ECDH
stand for in secure key exchanges?
Elliptic cryptography diffy helman
exchange encrypted curve diffy helman
establishment. Elliptic curve diffy
helman ephemeral or elliptic curve data
handling exchange. What does ECDH
stand for in secure key exchanges?
Correct answer is elliptic curve diffy
helman ephemeral.
Which option correctly expands ECDSA
in cryptograph cryptographic signatures?
Extended curve digital signature
application, elliptical code digital
security algorithm, electronic
certificate digital signature algorithm
or elliptic curve digital signature
algorithm. Which option correctly
expands ECDSA
in cryptographic signatures?
Correct answer is elliptic curve digital
signature algorithm
in endpoint security. What does EDR
stand for? Endpoint detection and
response, endpoint data recovery,
enhanced data response, or enterprise
detection and reporting in endpoint
security. What does EDR stand for?
Correct answer is endpoint detection and
response.
What is the meaning of EFS in file
system security? Electronics file
security, encrypted file system,
encrypted file storage or enhanced file
system. What is the meaning of EFS in
file system security?
Correct answer is encrypted file system.
What does ERP stand for in enterprise
management? Enterprise risk protection,
electronic resource planning, enterprise
resource planning, or enterprise
response program. What does ERP stand
for in enterprise management?
Correct answer is enterprise resource
planning in device identification. What
does ESN stand for? Encrypted serial
number, electronic service network,
enterprise serial number or electronic
serial number in device identification.
What does ESN stand for?
Correct answer is electronic serial
number. What does ESP represent in
secure communication protocols?
Encapsulated security payload, encrypted
security protocol, enhanced security
payload or encapsulated signal
processing. What does ESP represent in
secure communication protocols?
Correct answer is encapsulated security
payload
in file system management. What does
FACL stand for? File access control
list, file system access control list,
file allocation control list, or file
system account control list. In file
system management, what does FA
stand for?
Correct answer is file system access
control list. What is the full form of
FDE in data protection? file data
encryption, fast data encryption, full
disk encryption or full data encoding
with the full form of FD in data
protection.
Correct answer is full disk encryption.
What does FIM stand for in cyber
security? File integrity monitoring,
file inspection management, file
integrity management, or file
information management. What does FIM
stand for in cyber security?
Correct answer is file integrity
management. What does FPGA stand for in
hardware design? Field programmable gate
array, field process gate access,
flexible program gate array, or field
programmable general array. What does
FPGA stand for in hardware design?
Correct answer is field programmable
gate array in biometric security. What
does FRR represent? False recognition
ratio, false ree rejection rate, failed
recognition rate or frequent rec
rejection rate in biometric security.
What does FRR represent?
Correct answer is false rejection rate.
What does the acronym FTP stand for in
networking? Fast transfer protocol, file
transmission protocol, file transfer
protocol, or file transport process?
What does the acronym FTP stand for in
networking?
Correct answer is file transfer
protocol.
What does FTPS stand for in file
management? File transmission protocol
software, file transmission protocol
secure, file transfer protocol software,
or file transfer protocol secure. What
does FTPS stand for in file management?
Correct answer is file transfer protocol
secure in cryptography. What does GCM
represent?
Global cipher mode, general
cryptographic mode, galloid counter mode
or generic cipher mode in cryptography.
What does GCM represent?
Correct answer is Galloy counter mode.
What does GDPR stand for in data
protection? General Data Protection
Regulation, General Data Privacy
Regulation, Global Data Protection
Regulation, or General Digital
Protection Regulation. What does GDPR
stand for in data protection?
Correct answer is general data
protection regulation
in encryption tools. What does GPG stand
for? Global privacy gateway, general
public guard, new privacy guardian, or
new privacy guard. in encryption tools.
What does GPG stand for?
Correct answer is new privacy guard.
What is the full form of GPO in the
context of Windows environments? General
policy object, group policy object,
global policy organization or group
protection object. What is the full form
of go in the context of Windows
environments?
Correct answer is group policy object.
What does GPS stand for in navigation
systems?
Global positioning system, general
positioning system, geographic
positioning service, or global precision
system. What does GPS stand for in
navigation systems?
Correct answer is global positioning
system. In computing, what does GPU
stand for? General processing unit,
graphics performance unit, graphics
processing unit, or general purpose
unit. In computing, what does GPU stand
for?
Correct answer is graphics processing
unit. What does grre represent in
networking?
Global routing exchange, general routing
encapsulation,
general routing enclosure or generic
routing entity. What does GRE represent
in networking?
Correct answer is generic routing
encapsulation.
What is the meaning of HA in system
design? hybrid access, high
authentication, hardware abstraction or
high availability.
What is the meaning of HA in system
design?
Correct answer is high availability.
Which term describes HDD in computer
storage? hard data disc, highdensity
drive, hard disk drive or hybrid disk
device. Which term describes HDD in
computer storage?
Correct answer is hard disk drive.
What does HIDS stand for in cyber
security? hostbased intrusion detection
system, hybrid intrusion detection
system, host integrated detection
system, or hierarchical intrusion
detection system. What does HIDS stand
for in cyber security?
Correct answer is hostbased intrusion
detection system in endpoint security.
What is hips
stand for? Hybrid intrusion prevention
system, hostbased intrusion prevention
system, highle intrusion prevention
system or host integrated prevention
system. In endpoint security, what does
hips stand for?
Correct answer is hostbased intrusion
prevention system. Which option
correctly expands HMAC in cryptography?
Hashed message authentication codebase,
hashed message access control, hashed
message authentication code, or hybrid
message authentication check. Which
option correctly expands HMAC in
cryptography?
Correct answer is hashed message
authentication code.
What does HOTP stand for in one-time
password systems? hashed onetime
password, HMAC based on one-time
passcode,
high order time password, or HMACbased
one-time password. What does HOTP stand
for in one-time password systems?
Correct answer is HMACbased
one-time password.
In cyber security, what is the full form
of HSM?
Hardware security module, host security
manager, hardware software module or
hybrid security module. What is the full
form of HSM?
Correct answer is hardware security
module.
What does HTML stand for in web
development? Hyperlink text markup
language, hypertext markup language,
highle textual markup language, or
hyperlink markup language. What does
HTML stand for in web development?
Correct answer is hypertext markup
language.
Which option correctly defines HTTP in
networking? Hyper terminal transfer
protocol, hyperlink transfer protocol,
hypertext transfer protocol or high
transfer text protocol.
Which option correctly defines HTTP in
networking?
Correct answer is hypertext transfer
protocol.
What does HTTPS stand for in secure
communications?
Hypertext transfer protocol service,
hyper terminal transfer protocol secure,
hypertext transfer pro protection
protocol, or hypertext transfer protocol
secure. What does HTTPS stand for in
secure communications?
Correct answer is hypertext transfer
protocol secure
in building management. What does HVAC
represent? Heating ventilation air
conditioning
high value air conditioning heat
ventilation air flow control or heating
ventilation and climate. What does HVAC
represent?
Correct answer is heating, ventilation,
air conditioning.
What does AAS stand for in cloud
computing? Internet as a service,
infrastructure as a service, integrated
as a service, or information as a
service. What does AAS stand for in
cloud computing?
Correct answer is infrastructure as a
service.
In network structure, what does AC
represent?
Integrated as code, infrastructure and
application control,
infrastructure as code, or information
as code. What does AC represent?
Correct answer is infrastructure as code
in access management. What does AM or IM
stand for? Identity and account
management, information and access
management, identity access mechanism or
identity and access management.
What does Aam stand for?
Correct answer is identity and access
management.
What does ICMP stand for in network
protocols?
Internet control message protocol,
internal communication message protocol,
interconnected control message protocol,
or internet connection management
protocol. What does MP stand for in
network protocols?
Correct answer is internet control
message protocol.
In industrial cyber security, what does
ICS represent? Integrated control
systems, industrial control systems,
infrastructure control systems, or
industrial communication systems. What
does ICS represent?
Correct answer is industrial control
systems. Which option correctly expands
IDEA or IDA in encryption algorithms?
International digital encryption
algorithm, integrated data encryption
algorithm,
international data encryption algorithm
or integrated digital encryption
algorithm. Which option correctly
expands idea in encryption algorithms?
Correct answer is international data
encryption algorithm
in telecommunications. What does IDF
stand for? Integrated data frame,
internal distribution facility,
intermediate data facility or
intermediate distribution frame in
telecommunications. What does IDF stand
for?
Correct answer is intermediate
distribution frame.
What is the correct full form of IDP in
identity management? Identity provider,
identification process,
identity protocol or identification
provider?
What is the full form of IDP in identity
management?
Correct answer is identity provider.
Which option describes IDS in network
security? Intrusion detection service,
intrusion data system, integrated
detection system or intrusion detection
system? Which option correctly describes
IDS in network security?
Correct answer is intrusion detection
system.
What does it E stand for in the context
of engineering and technology?
International Electrical and Electronic
Experts, Institute of Energy and
Environmental Engineers, Institute of
Electrical and Electronics Engineers or
International Engineering and
Electronics Establishment. What does it
E stand for in the context of
engineering and technology?
Correct answer is Institute of
Electrical and Electronics Engineers.
In secure communications, what does IKE
stand for? Internal key exchange,
internet key exchange, immediate key
exchange, or interactive key exchange.
What does Ike stand for?
Correct answer is internet key exchange.
What does IM stand for when referring to
textbased real-time communication?
Instant messaging, immediate messaging,
interactive messaging, or internet
messaging. What does IM stand for?
Correct answer is instant messaging
in email protocols. What does IMAP
represent? IMAP.
Interactive mail access procedure.
Internet mail administration protocol,
internal message access protocol or
internet message access protocol. In
email protocols, what does imap or IMAP
represent?
Correct answer is internet message
access protocol.
Which of the following correctly defines
IOC in cyber security? Indicators of
control, indicators of compromise,
internet of cyber security or input
output control.
What correctly defines IOC in cyber
security?
Correct answer is indicators of
compromise.
What does IoT refer to in modern
technology environments? Internet of
technology, information of things,
internet of things, or interconnection
of tools. What does IoT refer to in
modern technology environments?
Correct answer is internet of things.
In networking, what is the full form of
IP? Internal protocol, integrated
protocol, internet provider or internet
protocol? What is the full form of IP?
Correct answer is internet protocol.
What does IPS stand for in network
security? Intrusion prevention system,
intrusion protection service, internal
protection system, or intrusion
prevention service. What does IPS stand
for in network security?
Correct answer is intrusion prevention
system.
Which option correctly expands IPSSE or
IPSC
in secure networking? Internal protocol
security, internet protocol security,
integrated protocol security or
interconnected protocol security.
Which option correctly expands IPSSE in
secure networking?
Correct answer is internet protocol
security. In cyber security, what does
IR stand for? Incident report,
information response, incident response
or internal review in cyber security.
What does IR stand for?
Correct answer is incident response.
What is the full form of IRC in online
communication?
Internet relay console, interactive
relay chat, internal relay communication
or internet relay chat. What is the full
form of IRC in online communication?
Correct answer is internet relay chat.
What does stand for in the context of
incident management? Incident response
plan, internal recovery procedure,
incident reporting protocol, or
immediate response plan. What does IRP
stand for in the context of incident
management?
Correct answer is incident response
plan.
Which of the following is the correct
expansion for ISO? International Systems
Organization, International Standards
Organization, Interconnected Systems
Organization or Integrated Standards
Office. The correct expansion for ISO.
Correct answer is international
standards organization.
What does ISP stand for in
telecommunications?
Internet service provider, international
service provider, internet signal
provider or integrated service provider.
What does ISP stand for?
Correct answer is internet service
provider.
In information security roles, what does
ISO or ISO denote? Information security
support officer, internal system
security operator, integrated security
systems officer or information system
security officer. In information
security roles, what does or iso denote?
Correct answer is information systems
security officer.
What is the full form of IV in
cryptography? Initialization vector,
internal verification,
initial value or information vector.
What is the full form of IV in
cryptography?
Correct answer is initialization vector.
What does KDC stand for in network
security? Key domain certificate, key
data converter, key distribution center,
or kernel distribution center. What does
KDC stand for in network security?
Correct answer is key distribution
center.
Which of the following is the correct
expansion for kek or kek? key encryption
key, key exchange key, key encoding key
or kernel encryption key was a correct
expansion for kek.
Correct answer is key encryption key.
What does L2TP stand for in tunneling
protocols? Level two tunneling protocol,
layer 2 transport protocol, link two
tunneling process, or layer 2 tunneling
protocol. What does L2TP stand for in
tunneling protocols?
Correct answer is layer 2 tunneling
protocol
in networking. What does LAN or LN stand
for? Large area network, local area
network, limited area network, or long
area network. What does LAN stand for?
Correct answer is local area network.
What is the full form of LDAP or LDAP?
Local directory access protocol, light
data access protocol, lightweight
directory access protocol or logical
directory administration protocol or is
the full form of LDAP or LDAP.
Correct answer is lightweight directory
access protocol.
Which option correctly expands LEAP or
LEAP?
Lightweight encryption and
authentication protocol, local
extensible authentication protocol,
lightweight extensible authorization
protocol or lightweight extensible
authentication protocol. Which option
correctly expands leap?
Correct answer is lightweight extensible
authentication protocol.
What does mass or mas stand for in cloud
services? Management as a service,
mobile as a service, monitoring as a
service or maintenance as a service.
What does mas stand for in cloud
services?
Correct answer is monitoring as a
service
in access control models. What does MAC
stand for in access control models?
Managed access control, mandatory access
control, modular access control, or
manual access control.
Correct answer is mandatory access
control
in networking. What does MAC stand for?
Modular access channel, multiple access
control, media access control, or manual
access channel. In networking, what does
MAC stand for?
Correct answer is media access control.
What is the correct expansion for MAC in
cryptography?
Message authentication code, machine
authentication certificate, message
access control or module authentication
code was the correct expansion for MAC
in cryptography.
Correct answer is message authentication
code. What does MAN or MN stand for in
networking? Mobile area network, main
area network, multi-reion area network
or metropolitan area network? What does
MAN stand for in networking?
Correct answer is metropolitan area
network in computer storage. What does
MBR stand for? Main boot record, master
boot record, master binary record, or
module boot recorder
in computer storage. What does MBR stand
for?
Correct answer is master boot record.
What does MD5 stand for in hashing
algorithms?
Message digest 5, media data 5, message
data 5, or master digest 5? What does
MD5 stand for in hashing algorithms?
Correct answer is message digest 5.
Which option correctly spans MDF in
telecommunications?
Modular distribution framework, medium
distribution frame, main distribution
frame, or main data frame. Which option
correctly expands MDF in
telecommunications?
Correct answer is main distribution
frame. What does MDM stand for in mobile
security management? Mobile data
monitoring, mobile device management,
manage device module, or mobile
distribution management? What does MDM
stand for in mobile security management?
Correct answer is mobile device
management.
What does MFA represent in cyber
security authentication?
Multiffactor authentication,
multifunction access, multifaceted
access or multiple factor au
authorization?
What does MFA represent in cyber
security authentication?
Correct answer is multiffactor
authentication.
Which option is the correct expansion
for MFD in IT devices? Multifunctional
data, modular file device, multifunction
device or multiple file display. Which
option is the correct expansion for MFD
in IT devices?
Correct answer is multi-function device.
In office equipment terminology, what
does MFP stand for? Multifunction phone,
multi-function format printer, modular
file printer, or multi-function printer.
What does MFP stand for?
Correct answer is multi-function
printer.
What does ML stand for in the context of
advanced technology?
Manual logic, machine learning,
multilevel or modular linkage.
What does ML stand for in the context of
advanced technology?
Correct answer is machine learning.
What is the full form of MMS in mobile
communications?
Multimedia message service, multiple
message system, media messaging service
or multiode message service was the full
form of MMS in mobile communications.
Correct answer is multimedia message
service.
What does MOA stand for in contractual
agreements, memorandum of authorization,
memorandum of analysis, memorandum of
arrangement or memorandum of agreement?
What does MOA stand for in contractual
agreements?
Correct answer is memorandum of
agreement.
Which option correctly expands MOU in
business contexts? Memorandum of use,
manual of understanding, memorandum of
understanding or management of users.
What correctly expands in business
contexts?
Correct answer is memorandum of
understanding.
What does MLS stand for in networking?
Multiple protocol link service,
multi-protocol label switching, modular
protocol label system, or multiplatform
label switching? What does MLS stand for
in networking?
Correct answer is multi-protocol label
switching. What is the correct expansion
for MSA in contract management? Master
service agreement, managed service
agreement, main service agreement or
modular service agreement. The correct
expansion for MSA in contract
management.
Correct answer is master service
agreement.
In network authentication, what does
MSHAP stand for? MSCAP.
Microsoft secure channel Handshake
Authentication Protocol. Microsoft
Standard Challenge Handshake
Authentication Protocol, Microsoft
System Challenge Handshake
Authentication Protocol, or Microsoft
Challenge Handshake Authentication
Protocol
in network authentication. What does MS
Chap stand for?
Correct answer is Microsoft challenge
handshake authentication protocol.
What does MSP represent in IT service
management? Managed security provider,
managed service partner, managed service
provider or mobile service provider.
What does MSP represent in IT service
management?
Correct answer is managed service
provider.
Which option correctly expands MSSP in
cyber security services?
Managed secure service provider, managed
security service provider, multis sector
security provider or managed
surveillance service provider
which correctly expands MSSP in cyber
security services.
Correct answer is managed security
service provider.
In reliability engineering, what does
MTBF stand for? Meanime between
failures, meanantime before failure,
maximum time between failures, or
meanantime between faults. What does
MTBF
stand for?
Correct answer is meanantime between
failures.
Which option correctly expands MTTF in
reliability metrics?
Meanime till failure,
maximum time to failure,
meanantime to fault or meanantime to
failure,
which correctly expands MTF in
reliability metrics.
Correct answer is meantime to failure.
What does MTR stand for in IT service
management? Meantime to repair,
meanantime to recover, meanantime to
reboot, or maximum time to respond. What
does MTR stand for in IT service
management?
Correct answer is meanantime to recover.
In networking, what does MTU represent?
Minimum transmission unit, maximum
transfer unit, maximum transmission
unit, or minimum transfer unit. What
does MTU represent?
Correct answer is maximum transmission
unit. What does NAC stand for in network
security? Network authentication
control, network allocation control,
network administrative control or
network access control. What does NAC
stand for in network security?
Correct answer is network access
control.
Which of the following correctly defines
NAT or NAT in networking? network
address translation,
network allocation table,
network access transmission or national
access terminal which correctly defines
NAT in networking.
Correct answer is network address
translation.
What does NDA stand for in business
agreements?
Non-distribution agreement,
non-design agreement, non-disclosure
agreement, or network disclosure
agreement. What does NDA stand for in
business agreements?
Correct answer is non-disclosure
agreement.
In wireless communications, what does
NFC represent? Near field communication,
network field communication, new field
communication, or near frequency
control. What does NFC represent?
Correct answer is near field
communication.
What does NGFW stand for in modern cyber
security?
Next generation file wrapper, next
generation firewall,
next gateway firewall or new generation
firewall.
What does NGFW stand for in modern cyber
security?
Correct answer is next generation
firewall.
What does NIDS stand for in network
security solutions? Network intrusion
detection system, network integrated
detection service, non-intrusive
detection system, or network interface
detection system. What does NIDS stand
for in network security solutions?
Correct answer is network intrusion
detection system.
What does NIPS or NIPS stand for?
Network security solutions.
Network integrated prevention service.
network-based intrusion prevention
system, network intrusion protection
system, or non-intrusive prevention
system.
What does NIPS or NIP stand for in
network security solutions?
Correct answer is network-based
intrusion prevention system. What is the
full form of NIST in cyber security
standards? NIST,
National Institute of Standards and
Technology, National Information
Security Team, Network Institute of
Security and Technology or National
Institute of Security and Technology
which is the full form of NIST in cyber
security standards.
Correct answer is National Institute of
Standards and Technology.
In file systems, what does NTFS stand
for? Network technology file system, new
transfer file system, new technology
file system, or next technology file
system? What does NTFS stand for?
Correct answer is new technology file
system. What does NTLM stand for in
Microsoft authentication protocols? New
technology land manager, network
technology land manager, new terminal
land manager, or network terminal land
manager. What does NTLM stand for in
Microsoft Authentication Protocols?
Correct answer is new technology LAN
manager. Which protocol is represented
by the acronym NTP?
network time protocol, national time
protocol, new time protocol or network
timing protocol.
What is represented by the acronym M
NTP?
Correct answer is network time protocol.
What does OOTH or O aut stand for in
authorization frameworks?
online authorization,
open authentication,
organized authorization or open
authorization.
What does OOTH stand for in
authorization frameworks?
Correct answer is open authorization
in certificate validation. What does
OCSP represent? Online certificate
security protocol, offline certificate
status protocol, online certificate
status protocol, or online certificate
synchronization protocol. What does OCSP
represent?
Correct answer is online certificate
status protocol.
What is the full form of oid and object
identification?
Object identifier, organizational
identifier, operational identifier or
object identification
was a full form of oid in object
identification.
Correct answer is object identifier.
In computing, what does OS stand for?
Object system, output system, overload
system, or operating system? What does
OS stand for?
Correct answer is operating system. What
does OSINT stand for in intelligence
gathering? Open system internal
technology, open-source intelligence,
operational source information or online
system integration. What does OSN stand
for in intelligence gathering?
Correct answer is open-source
intelligence.
Which option correctly expands OSPF in
routing protocols? Open system protocol
function, operational shortest path
finder, open shortest path first or
optimal shortest path forwarding
which correctly expands OSPF in routing
protocols.
Correct answer is open shortest path
first.
In industrial environments, what does OT
stand for? Operational technology,
organizational technology, optical
transmission, or operational
transmission?
What does OT stand for in industrial
environments?
Correct answer is operational
technology.
What does OTAA stand for in wireless
communications?
Over the area, over the air, open
transport architecture, or on time
access?
What does OTAA stand for in wireless
communications?
Correct answer is over the air.
Which option correctly defines Oval OVA
L in vulnerability assessments?
Operational vulnerability an analysis
link organized vulnerability assessment
logic open vulnerability assessment
language or open vulnerability analysis
list. Which option correctly defines
oval oval in vulnerability assessments?
Correct answer is open vulnerability
assessment language.
What does P12 refer to in cryptographic
standards?
Password 12digit protocol 12 public key
12 or PKCS number 12. What does P12
refer to in cryptographic standards?
Correct answer is PKCS number 12.
In networking, what does P2P stand for?
Pointtooint, peer-to-peer,
packet to packet, or protocol to
protocol? What does P2P stand for?
Correct answer is peer-to-peer.
What does P A stand for in cloud
computing? Platform as a service,
product as a service, process as a
service, or program as a service? What
does PAS stand for in cloud computing?
Correct answer is platform as a service.
Which option correctly expands PAC in
proxy configurations? Public access
control, proxy access code,
preconfigured access control or proxy
auto configuration?
Which option correctly expands PAC in
proxy configurations?
Correct answer is proxy auto
configuration
in securing user privileges. What does
PAM or PAM stand for? Privileged access
management, protected account
management, privileged authentication
mechanism or private access method. What
does PAM P A M stand for?
Correct answer is privileged access
management
within Linux authentication. What does
PAM represent? portable authentication
method, pluggable authentication
modules, password authentication module
or protocol access module within Linux
authentication.
What does PAM represent?
Correct answer is pluggable
authentication modules.
What does PAP or PAP stand for in
authentication protocols? Private access
protocol, public authentication process,
protected access protocol, or password
authentication protocol. What does PAP
or PAP stand for in authentication
protocols?
Correct answer is password
authentication protocol.
Which option correctly defines PAT PAT
in network address translation
techniques? Port address translation,
packet address translation, protocol
address translation or private address
translation.
Which option correctly defines PAT in
network address translation techniques?
Correct answer is port address
translation.
What does PBKDF2
stand for in cryptographic key
derivation?
Privatebased key distribution function
2. password-based key derivation
function two, public binary key
derivation format 2, or password binary
key derivation format 2. What does PBK
DF2 stand for in cryptographic key
derivation?
Correct answer is passwordbased key
derivation function 2 in telefanany.
What does PBX refer to? Public branch
exchange, private base exchange,
private branch exchange or public base
exchange
in telefan. What does PBX refer to?
Correct answer is private branch
exchange.
Which option correctly defines PCAP PCAP
in network analysis? Packet capture,
packet content analysis, protocol
capture or packet communication
analysis?
Which option correctly defines PCAP in
network analysis?
Correct answer is packet capture.
What does PCI DSS stand for in payment
security standards? Personal card
information data security standard,
payment card information data safety
standard,
payment card industry data security
system, or payment card industry data
security standard. What does PCI DSS
stand for in payment security standards?
Correct answer is payment card industry
data security standard.
In power management, what does PDU refer
to? power data unit, peripheral
distribution unit, power distribution
unit, or primary distribution unit. In
power management, what does PDU refer
to?
Correct answer is power distribution
unit.
What does PEEP stand for in wireless
authentication protocols? P EAP
public extensible authentication
protocol,
protected extensible authentication
private extensible authentication
protocol or password extensible
authentication protocol. What does PEEP
PAP stand for in wireless authentication
protocols?
Correct answer is protected extensible
authentication protocol.
Which option correctly expands peed in
the context of device security?
Personalized electronic dashboard,
professional electronic device, private
electronic device or personal electronic
device. What correctly expands peed in
the context of device security?
Correct answer is personal electronic
device.
What does PEM stand for in secure email
formats?
Privacy enhanced mail, personal
electronic mail, public encrypted mail,
or protocol encrypted message. What does
PEM stand for in secure email formats?
Correct answer is privacyenhanced mail.
In cryptographic protocols, what does
PFS refer to? private file system,
public forward secrecy, perfect forward
secrecy, or primary file security in
cryptographic protocols. What does PFS
refer to?
Correct answer is perfect forward
secrecy.
What is the full form of PGP in data
encryption? Private good protection,
pretty good privacy, public general
privacy or personal good privacy. What
is the full form of PGP and data
encryption?
Correct answer is pretty good privacy
in healthcare security. What does PHI
stand for? Public health information,
personal hospital information, protected
health insurance, or personal health
information
in healthcare security. What does PHI
stand for?
Correct answer is personal health
information.
Which option correctly defines PII and
privacy regulations? Personally
identifiable information, public identif
identifiable information, private
information identifier or personal
identification information? Which option
correctly defines PII in privacy
regulations?
Correct answer is personally
identifiable information.
What does PIV stand for in government
security standards? Public identity
verification,
personal identification validation,
personal identity verification or
private identity verification. What does
PIV stand for in government security
standards?
Correct answer is personal identity
verification.
Which option correctly expands PKCS in
cryptographic standards?
private key certificate system, public
key certificate specifications,
protocol key cryptographic scheme or
public key cryptography standards. Which
option correctly expands PKCS in
cryptographic standards?
Correct answer is public key
cryptography standards.
What does PKI stand for in cyber
security? Private key identification,
public key infrastructure,
public key integration or private key
infrastructure.
What does PKI stand for in cyber
security?
Correct answer is public key
infrastructure
in email protocols. What does POP or POP
stand for? Personal office protocol,
public office protocol, post office
protocol or private office protocol. In
email protocols, what does POP stand
for?
Correct answer is post office protocol.
What does POTS stand for in telefanany?
Private office telephone service, public
optical telephone service, primary
office telephone system, or plain old
telephone service. What does POTS stand
for in telefan?
Correct answer is plain old telephone
service.
Which protocol is defined as PPP?
Point-to-point protocol, packetto packet
protocol, private top to private
protocol, or peer-to-peer protocol.
Which protocol is defined as PPP?
Correct answer is pointto-point
protocol.
What does PPTP stand for in VPN
technologies?
Private point tunneling protocol,
point-to-point tunneling protocol,
peer-to-peer tunneling protocol, or
public point tunneling protocol.
What does PPTP stand for in VPN
technologies?
Correct answer is point-to-point
tunneling protocol.
In wireless security, what does PSK
represent? Public shared key, private
shared key, pre-shared key, or password
shared key. What does PSK represent in
wireless security?
Correct answer is pre-shared key. Which
option correctly defines PTZ in video
surveillance systems? Play track zoom,
pan tilt zone, point turn zoom, or pan
tilt zoom. Which option correctly
defines PTZ in video surveillance
systems?
Correct answer is pan, tilt, zoom.
In malware terminology, what does PUP or
PUP stand for? potentially unwanted
program, publicly unwanted process,
pre-installed unwanted package, or
potentially unwanted process. In malware
terminology, what does PUP stand for?
Correct answer is potentially unwanted
program
in data context. What does RA stand for
as a role? Remote administrator,
recovery agent, risk assessor, or
resource allocator.
What does RA stand for as a role?
Correct answer is recovery agent
within PKI. What does RA stand for
during certificate issuance?
Record authority, routing authority,
registration authority, or reference
authority within PKI. What does RA stand
for during certificate issuance?
Correct answer is registration
authority.
What does race stand for in
communications research? Research and
coordination in advanced communications
engineering, research and analysis in
cyber security engineering,
rapid application in communications
engineering, or research and development
in advanced communication technologies
in Europe. What does race stand for in
communications research?
correct answer is research and
development in advanced communication
technologies in Europe.
Which option correctly expands RAD RA in
software development? Rapid application
development, reliable application
deployment, remote application
development or responsive application
design. Which option correctly expands
RAD RA in software development?
Correct answer is rapid application
development.
What does radius stand for in network
authentication services? Remote access
dial-in user service, remote
authentication dial-in user service,
regional authentication dialin user
service, or remote access data user
interface service. What does RADIUS
stand for in network authentication
services?
Correct answer is remote authentication
dialin user service.
What does RAID stand for in storage
systems? Random array of inexpensive
discs, redundant array of inexpensive
discs, reliable array of inexpensive
discs, or rapid array of inexpensive
discs. What does RAID stand for in
storage systems?
Correct answer is redundant array of
inexpensive discs.
What does RAZ stand for in network
access solutions? Remote active service,
remote application server, remote access
server, or reliable access server. What
does RAZ RA stand for in network access
solutions?
Correct answer is remote access server.
In cyber security threats, what does RAT
stand for? Remote administration tool,
remote access Trojan, rapid access tool,
or reliable administration Trojan in
cyber security threats. What does RAT
stand for?
Correct answer is remote access Trojan.
What does arbback or RBAC stand for in
control models? record-based access
control,
resource-based access control,
region-based access control, or
role-based access control.
What does RBAC or arbback stand for in
control models?
Correct answer is rolebased access
control. What is another definition for
arbback in control models? Registration
based access control, rulebased access
control, resource-based access control,
or real-time access control was another
definition for arbback in control
models.
The correct answer is rulebased access
control.
What does RC4 refer to in encryption
algorithms?
Rivvis cipher version 4, riv code
version 4, riv cryptographic 4 or rivist
or revised cipher version 4. What does
RC4 refer to in encryption algorithms?
Correct answer is Rivst Cipher version
4.
What does RDP stand for in remote
connectivity solutions? Remote data
protocol, rapid desktop process, remote
desktop protocol, or remote display
protocol? What does RDP stand for in
remote connectivity solutions?
Correct answer is remote desktop
protocol.
What does RFID stand for in
identification technologies?
Remote frequency identification,
radio frequency indicator, remote field
identification or radio frequency
identification. What does RFID stand for
in identification technologies?
Correct answer is radio frequency
identification.
What does ripe MD stand for in hash
functions? RIP MD. Rivst integrity
protocol message digest.
Race integrity primitiv primitives
evaluation message digest.
Random Integrity Primitive Evaluation
Message Digest or Reliable Integrity
Primitives Evaluation Message Digest.
What is RIPMD? RIP PMD
stand for in hash functions.
Correct answer is race integrity
primitives evaluation message digest.
In financial analysis, what does ROI
stand for? Return on investment, rate of
investment, return of investment, or
ratio of investment. In financial
analysis, what does ROI stand for?
Correct answer is return on investment.
What does RPO stand for in disaster
recovery planning? Recovery performance
objective, restoration point objective,
return point objective, or recovery
point objective. What does RPO stand for
in disaster recovery planning?
Correct answer is recovery point
objective.
What does RSA stand for in public key
cryptography?
Rivst Shamir and Adelman,
Rivst Smith and Anderson, reliable
security algorithm or rapid security
application. What does RSA stand for in
public key cryptography?
Correct answer is Ribbist, Shamir, and
Adelman.
What does RTBH stand for in network
defense strategies?
Realtime black hole, remotely triggered
black hole, remote terminal black hole,
or rapidly triggered black hole. What
does RTBH stand for in network defense
strategies?
Correct answer is remotely triggered
black hole.
What does RTO stand for in disaster
recovery metrics? Recovery technical
operation,
return time objective,
response time objective, or recovery
time objective.
What does RTO stand for in disaster
recovery metrics?
Correct answer is recovery time
objective
in embedded systems. What does RTOS
stand for? Real time operations
software, real time operating system,
real time output service or real time
open system. In embedded systems, what
does RTOS stand for?
Correct answer is real time operating
system.
What does RTP represent in media
streaming protocols? Reliable transport
protocol, rapid transmission protocol,
real-time transport protocol, or remote
transfer protocol? What does RTP
represent in media streaming protocols?
Correct answer is real time transport
protocol.
Which option correctly defines SMEME in
email security? S MIME
secure multi-purpose internet mail
extensions
secure managed internet mail encryption.
safe multi-purpose internet mail
exchange or secure multi-user internet
mail encoding. Which option correctly
defines S MIME in email security?
Correct answer is secure multi-purpose
internet mail extensions
in cloud computing. What does SAS stand
for? Software and services, software as
a service, system as a service, or
solutions as a service in cloud
computing. What does SAS stand for?
Correct answer is software as a service.
In authentication methods, what does S
AE mean? Secure authentication exchange,
simple authentication element,
simultaneous authentication of equals or
server assisted encryption in
authentication methods. What does S AE
mean?
Correct answer is simultaneously au
simultaneous authentication of equals.
What does SML stand for in federated
identity management? Secure assertion
markup language, simple assertion markup
language, secure access markup language,
or security assertions markup language.
What does SML stand for in federated
identity management?
Correct answer is security assertions
markup language in data storage. What
does SAN or SAN refer to? Storage area
network server access network system
archive network or secure access node in
data storage. What does san or s refer
to?
Correct answer. Storage area network
in digital certificates. What does SAND
stand for? Storage area name, subject
alternative name, secure attribute name,
or secondary authorization name. In
digital certificates, what does SAN
stand for?
Correct answer is subject alternative
name. What does SAS stand for in network
security architecture?
Secure access service environment,
secure application service edge, secure
access service edge, or security and
access service edge. What does SAS stand
for in network security architecture?
Correct answer is secure access service
edge in industrial control systems. What
does SCADA S c a represent? Supervisory
control and data aggregation,
secure control and data acquisition,
supervisory command and data analysis or
supervisory control and data acquisition
in industrial control systems. What does
SCADA represent?
Correct answer is supervisory control
and data acquisition.
What does SCAP SCAP stand for in
security compliance tools? Security
content automated automation protocol,
system control automation program,
secure content analysis process or
security configuration assessment
protocol. What does SCAP or SCAP stand
for in security compliance tools?
Correct answer is security content
automation protocol
in certificate management. What does SCE
stand for? Simple certificate enrollment
process, simple certificate enrollment
protocol, secure certificate enrollment
protocol or standard certificate
enrollment procedure in certificate
management. What does SCE stand for?
correct answer is simple certificate
enrollment protocol.
What does SDWAN represent in modern
networking?
Softwardriven wide area network,
standard defined wide area network,
software distributed wide area network
or softwaredefined wide area network.
What does SDWAN represent in modern
networking?
Correct answer is software defined wide
area network in software development.
What does SDK stand for? Software
development kit, system development
kernel, software deployment kit, or
system development kit. In software
development, what does SDK stand for?
Correct answer is software development
kit.
What does SDLC stand for in project
management? System development system
development life cycle, software design
life cycle, system design life cycle, or
software development life cycle.
What does SDLC stand for in project
management?
correct answer is software development
life cycle.
What does SDLM represent in software
engineering?
Software development life cycle method,
software development life cycle
methodology, system development life
cycle model or software design life
cycle model. What does SDLM represent in
software engineering?
Correct answer is software development
life cycle methodology.
What does SDN stand for in modern
networking? Softwaredefined networking,
secure data networking, systematic data
network, or softwaredriven network. What
does SDN stand for in modern networking?
Correct answer is software defined
networking
in Linux security. What does SE Linux
stand for? Standard edition Linux
security enhanced Linux secure
enterprise Linux or system enhanced
Linux in Linux security. What does SE
Linux stand for?
Correct answer is security enhanced
Linux.
Which term best describes SED in
hardware security? Secure encrypted
data, software enabled drive, self-
encrypting drives, or simple encryption
device? Which term best describes SED in
hardware security?
Correct answer is self- encrypting
drives
in programming. What does stand for?
Standard exception handler, systematic
error handler, structured error handler,
or structured exception handler. In
programming, what does stand for?
Correct answer is structured exception
handler.
What does SFTP stand for in file
transfer protocols?
Secured file transfer protocol, simple
file transfer process,
secure file transmission protocol, or
safe file transfer protocol. What does
SFTP stand for in file transfer
protocols?
Correct answer is secured file transfer
protocol.
Which option correctly defines SHA in
cryptographic functions? Secure hashing
algorithmic.
Secure hashing algorithm. Simple hashing
algorithm or standard hash algorithm.
Which option correctly defines SHA in
cryptographic functions?
Correct answer is secure hashing
algorithm.
What does SHTP
stand for in web communications?
Simple hypertext transfer protocol.
Standard Hypertext Transfer Protocol,
Secure Hypertext Transfer Protocol, or
Safe Hypertext Transfer Protocol. What
does STTP stand for in web
communications?
Correct answer is secure hypertext
transfer protocol
in cyber security monitoring. What does
seam I sim stand for? System information
and event management, security
intelligent event management, secure
information and event monitoring or
security information and event
management. In cyber security
monitoring, what does SIM stand for?
Correct answer is security information
and event management in mobile
communications. What does SIM or SIM
stand for? Subscriber identity module,
secure information module, system
integration module, or subscriber
internet module. In mobile
communications, what does SIM or SIM
stand for?
Correct answer is subscriber identity
module. What does SLA stand for in
service agreements? System level
agreement, service level agreement,
standard level agreement or secure level
agreement. What does SLA stand for in
service agreements?
Correct answer is service level
agreement.
Which term defines SLE in risk
management metrics? Standard loss
estimate, system loss expectancy,
single loss expectancy or single loss
estimate. Which term defines SLE in risk
management metrics?
Correct answer is single loss
expectancy.
What does SMS stand for in mobile
communications?
System message service, simple message
service, secure message service, or
short message service? What does SMS
stand for in mobile communications?
Correct answer is short message service.
What does SMTP stand for in internet
communication?
Simple mail transfer protocol, secure
mail transmission protocol, standard
mail transfer procedure, or simple mail
transaction protocol? What does SMTP
stand for in internet communication?
Correct answer is simple mail transfer
protocol.
What does SMTPS stand for in internet
communications?
Secure mail transfer protocol standard,
simple mail transmission protocol
secure, simple mail transfer process
standard, or simple mail transfer
protocol secure. What does SMTPS stand
for in internet communications?
Correct answer is simple mail transfer
protocol secure.
What does SNMP stand for in network
management? Simple Network Management
Protocol, Secure Network Monitoring
Protocol, Simple Node Management
Protocol, or System Network Management
Protocol. What does SNMP stand for in
network management?
Correct answer is simple network
management protocol.
What does SOAP or S OAP stand for in web
services?
Standard object application protocol,
secure object access protocol, simple
object access protocol, or simple open
access protocol. What does SOAP sap
stand for in web services?
Correct answer is simple object access
protocol.
What does source stand for in cyber
security operations?
Security orchestration automation and
response, secure operations and
response, system orchestration and
automated response or security
optimization and automated response.
What does soar stand for in cyber
security operations?
Correct answer is security,
orchestration, automation and response.
In hardware design, what does S stand
for? Security on campus, service on
chip, system of components, or system on
chip.
What does SOC stand for in hardware
design?
Correct answer is system onchip.
In cyber security operations, what does
SOC stand for? Security operations
command, secure operations center,
security operations center, or system
operations center. In cyber security
operations, what does SOC stand for?
Correct answer is security operations
center. What does S. So stand for in
project management? Service of work,
schedule of work, summary of work, or
statement of work. What does S. stand
for in project management?
Correct answer is statement of work.
What does SPF stand for in email
authentication?
Sender policy framework, secure postmail
format, standard protocol framework, or
sender protection feature. What does SPF
stand for in email authentication?
Correct answer is sender policy
framework.
What does SPIM stand for in unwanted
messaging? Secure protocol for internet
messaging. Service protocol for instant
messaging, spam prevention in messaging
or spam over internet messaging. What
does SPIM stand for in unwanted
messaging?
Correct answer is spam over internet
messaging.
What does SQL stand for in database
management? Standard query language,
structured query language, simple query
language, or sequential query language?
What does SQL stand for in database
management?
Correct answer is structured query
language in web security. What does SQLI
refer to? Structured query logging
injection, standard query language
intrusion,
SQL injection, or structured query
language interference
in web security. What does SQLI refer
to?
Correct answer is SQL or SQL injection.
What does SRTP stand for in secure media
transmission?
Secure real-time processing, standard
real-time protocol, secure real-time
protocol, or secure real-time
protection. What does SRTP stand for in
secure media transmission?
Correct answer is secure realtime
protocol.
What does SSD stand for in computer
storage? Solid state drive, single
storage device, serial storage disc, or
secure storage device. What does SSD
stand for in computer storage?
Correct answer is solid state drive.
What does SSH stand for in secure remote
access? Simple shell, secure shell,
server shell, or system shell? What does
SSH stand for in secure remote access?
Correct answer is secure shell. In web
security, what does SSL stand for?
Secure socket login, secure system
layer, secure sockets layer, or system
secure layer in web security. What does
SSL stand for?
Correct answer is secure sockets layer.
What does SSO represent in
authentication systems? Single sign off,
simple sign on, secure sign on or single
sign on. What does SSO represent in
authentication systems?
Correct answer is single sign on. What
does STIX stand for in threat
intelligence sharing? Structured threat
information exchange, standard threat
information exchange, secure threat
information exchange or structured
threat indicator exchange. What does
STIS or STIX stand for in threat
intelligence sharing?
Correct answer is structured threat
information exchange
in web security. What does SSWG stand
for? Standard web gateway, secure web
gateway, simple web gateway, or system
web gateway. In web security, what does
SWG stand for?
Correct answer is secure web gateway.
What does tacax plus stand for in
network access control? Taxacs
plus terminal access controller access
control service. Terminal access control
and communication system. Terminal
access controller access control system
or telecom access control and security.
What does TACX plus stand for in network
access control?
Correct answer is terminal access
controller access control system.
What does taxi T axi
stand for in threat intelligence
exchange? Trusted automatic trusted
automated exchange of indicator info.
Trusted automated exchange of indicator
info, trusted access exchange of
indicator information or trusted
automated exchange of indicator
information. What is taxi stand for in
threat intelligence exchange?
Correct answer is trusted automated
exchange of indicator information.
What does TCP IP stand for in
networking? Transmission control
protocol internet protocol transfer
control protocol interconnect protocol.
Transmission Communication Protocol,
Internet Protocol, or Transfer
Communication Protocol, Interconnect
Protocol.
What does TCP IP stand for in
networking?
Correct answer is transmission control
protocol internet protocol
in Kerros authentication. What does TGT
stand for? Ticket granting token, ticket
granting ticket, token granting ticket
or ticket generating ticket in Kerros
authentication. What does TGT stand for?
Correct answer is ticket granting
ticket. What does TKIP or TKIP stand for
in wireless encryption protocols?
Temporal key integrity protocol,
transient key integrity protocol,
temporal key information protocol or
transitional key integrity protocol.
What does TKIP stand for in wireless
encryption protocols?
Correct answer is temporal key integrity
protocol.
What does TLS stand for in secure
communications?
Transport link security, transmission
layer security, transfer level security,
or transport layer security. What does
TLS stand for in secure communications?
Correct answer is transport layer
security. What does TOC stand for in
software security contexts? type of
control, term of condition, time of
check, or total order check. What does
TOC stand for in software security
contexts?
Correct answer is time of check. What
does TOTP stand for in authentication
mechanisms? temporary onetime password,
timebased onetime password,
times timed onetime passcode, or timed
operator password. What does TOTP stand
for in authentication mechanisms?
Correct answer is timebased one-time
password.
In billing and energy management, what
does TOU stand for? Time of use, time of
update, time of usage, or time of user.
In billing and energy management, what
does TOU stand for?
Correct answer is time of use. What does
TPM stand for in hardware security?
Trusted processing method, technical
platform module, trusted platform
module, or technology processing module.
What does TPM stand for in hardware
security?
Correct answer is trusted platform
module.
What is the correct expansion of TTP in
cyber security contexts?
Tactical threat protocol tactis tactics
techniques and procedures tactics
training and processes or targeted
threat procedures. What is the correct
expansion of TTP in cyber security
contexts?
Correct answer is tactics, techniques,
and procedures.
In DNS security, what does TIG or TSI
stand for? Time signature, transmission
signal, terminal signal, or transaction
signature?
Indiana security. What does T-IG stand
for?
Correct answer is transaction signature.
What does UAT stand for in software
testing process, user acceptance
testing, user automated testing,
universal acceptance testing or
unilateral acceptance test? What does
UAT stand for in the software testing
process?
Correct answer is user acceptance
testing.
What is the full form of UAV in modern
technology? Universal aerial vehicle,
unmanned aerial vehicle, unattended
airborne vehicle or unmanned autonomous
vehicle is the full form of UAV in
modern technology.
Correct answer is unmanned aerial
vehicle
in networking. What does UDP stand for?
Universal datagram protocol, user data
protocol, user datagramgram protocol, or
unified datagramgram protocol in
networking. What does UDP stand for?
Correct answer is user datagram
protocol.
What does UEFI stand for in computer
firmware? Universal extensible firmware
interface, unified extended firmware
interface, universal extended firmware
interface, or unified extensible
firmware interface. What does UEFI stand
for in computer firmware?
Correct answer is unified extensible
firmware interface
in endpoint management. What does UEM
stand for? Unified endpoint management,
universal endpoint management, unified
enterprise management, or user endpoint
management. In endpoint management, what
does UEM stand for?
Correct answer is unified endpoint
management. What does UPS stand for in
power protection systems? Universal
power system, uninterruptible power
supply, uninterrupted power source, or
uninterrupted power supply. What does
UPS stand for in power protection
systems?
Correct answer is uninterruptible power
supply.
What does URI represent in web resource
identification?
Universal resource identifier. Uniform
resource indicator. Uniform resource
identifier or universal resource
indicator. What does URI represent in
web resource identification?
Correct answer is uniform resource
identifier.
What does URL stand for in web
addressing? Unilateral resource locator.
Unilateral resource link, uniform
reference locator, or uniform resource
locator. What does URL stand for in web
addressing?
Correct answer is uniform resource
locator.
What does USB stand for in computer
connectivity?
Universal serial bus, unilateral system
bus, unique serial bridge or universal
signal bus. What does USB stand for in
computer connectivity?
Correct answer is universal serial bus.
What does USBOTG
stand for in mobile device connectivity?
Universal serial bus on time, USB on the
go, universal serial bus, universal
system bus on the go, or universal
serial bus on the ground. What does
USBOTG stand for in mobile device
connectivity?
The correct answer is USB on the go or
universal serial bus on the go.
In network security, what does UTM stand
for? Universal threat monitoring, uni
user threat management, unified terminal
management, or unified threat
management. In network security, what
does UTM stand for?
Correct answer is unified threat
management
in networking cables. What does UTP
stand for? universal twisted pair,
unshielded twisted protocol,
unshielded twisted pair or uninterrupted
twisted pair in networking cables. What
does UTP stand for?
Correct answer is unshielded twisted
pair. In programming, what does VBA
stand for? Virtual Basic Assembly,
Visual Basic, Visual Binary Access, or
Variable Business Application. In
programming, what does VBA stand for?
Correct answer is Visual Basic.
What does VDE stand for in computing
environments?
virtual desktop environment, visual data
exchange, virtual data engine, or visual
desktop engineering. What does VDE stand
for in computing environments?
Correct answer is virtual desktop
environment.
What does VDI stand for in virtual
solutions?
virtual data interface, virtual desktop
internet, virtual desktop infrastructure
or virtual device integration.
What does VDI stand for in virtual
solutions?
Correct answer is virtual desktop
infrastructure
in network segmentation. What does VLAN
stand for? Virtual local area network,
virtual line access network, variable
local area network, or virtual long-d
distanceance area network in network
segmentation. What does VLAN stand for?
Correct answer is virtual local area
network.
What does VLSM stand for in subnetting
techniques? Variable length sub subnet
mask, variable length subnet masking,
virtual length subnet masking, or
variable local subnet masking. What does
VLSM stand for in subnetting techniques?
Correct answer is variable length subnet
masking.
In computing environments, what does VM
stand for? Virtual memory, virtual
module, virtual machine, or verified
machine.
In computing environments, what does VM
stand for?
Correct answer is virtual machine.
What does VIP stand for in
telecommunications?
Voice over internet protocol,
virtualization over internet protocol,
virtualization of internet protocol or
voice over integration protocol. What
does VIP or VOIPE stand for in
telecommunications?
Correct answer is voice over internet
protocol
in cloud networking. What does VPC stand
for? Virtual public cloud, virtual
private cloud, virtual protected cloud
or verified private cloud. In cloud
networking, what does VPC stand for?
Correct answer is virtual private cloud.
What does VPN stand for in secure
communications?
Virtual public network, verified private
network, virtual private network, or
virtual protected network. What does VPN
stand for in secure communications?
Correct answer is virtual private
network. What does VTC stand for in
corporate communications?
Video teleconferencing,
visual telecommunication,
virtual task conference, or voice
telecon.
What does VTC stand for in corporate
communications?
Correct answer is video
teleconferencing.
Which of the following defines WAF in
web security? Web access framework, web
application firewall,
wide area filter or website
authentication facility.
Which of the following defines WAF in
web security?
Correct answer is web application
firewall.
In wireless networking, what does WAP
commonly refer to? Wireless application
protocol, wide area port, wireless
access point, or wired access point. In
wireless networking, what does WAP
commonly refer to?
Correct answer is wireless access point.
What is the meaning of WP in wireless
security?
Wireless encryption protocol, wired
equivalent protection, wireless
equivalent protection or wired
equivalent privacy. What is the meaning
of WP and wireless security?
Correct answer is wired equivalent
privacy.
What does WIDS stand for in wireless
security monitoring? Wireless intrusion
detection system, wireless integration
detection service, wideband intrusion
detection system, or wireless interface
detection suite.
What does WIDS stand for in wireless
security monitoring?
Correct answer is wireless intrusion
detection system.
Which term best describes WIPS in
wireless defenses? wireless intrusion
detection service, wireless intrusion
prevention system, wideband intrusion
prevention service, or wireless
integration protection suite. Which term
best describes WIPS in wireless
defenses?
Correct answer is wireless intrusion
prevention system.
In facilities and maintenance, what does
WO typically mean? Work order request,
work operation,
work order, or work overview.
What does WA WO typically mean in
facilities and maintenance?
Correct answer is work order. What does
WPA stand for in Wi-Fi security
standards? Wireless protection
algorithm, Wi-Fi protected access,
wireless privacy access, or wired
protected access? What does WPA stand
for in Wi-Fi security standards?
Correct answer is Wi-Fi protected
access.
What is WPS used for in wireless
networks? Wireless provisioning service,
Wi-Fi provisioning system, Wi-Fi
protected setup or wireless private
setup. What is WPS used for in wireless
networks?
Correct answer is Wi-Fi protected setup.
What does WTLS refer to in mobile
security? Wireless transport layer
security, web transport layer security,
wireless TLS extension, or wireless
transport layer security. What does WTLS
refer to in mobile security?
Correct answer is wireless transport
layer security
which best describes XDR in threat
management
cross detection and response extended
data recovery extended detection and
response or extreme detection resource
which best describes XDR in threat
management.
Correct answer is extended detection and
response.
What does XML stand for in data
interchange? Extensible markup link,
exchange markup language, extended
markup language, or extensible markup
language. What does XML stand for in
data interchange?
Correct answer. Extensible markup
language in logic and cryptography. What
does X mean? Exclusive on, exchange or,
exclusive or, or, or execute or. In
logic and cryptography, what does X
mean?
Correct answer is exclusive or.
What is another name for XSRF in web
security? Cross-sight request forgery.
cross-sight resource forgery,
cross-sight remote forgery, or cross
server request forgery. What is another
name for XSRF in web security?
Correct answer is cross site request
forgery.
What does XSS stand for when discussing
web vulnerabilities?
Cross-sight script, cross-sight
scripting service, cross-sight
scripting, or cross-sight secure
scripting. What does XSS stand for when
discussing web vulnerabilities?
Correct answer is crossite scripting.
And that is it for this part of the
CompTIA Security Plus. This was the
acronyms. If you've already watched the
rest of the sections, then good luck on
your exam and stay tuned for all the
different Security Plus as well as other
exam prep materials on the channel.